FISCAL AB REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE
WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD AFTER
MORNING EVERYBODY IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERED NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND PROTECT THE
PUBLIC. LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS TODAY HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE REMOTELY I'M NOT
SURE IF CENTER MELENDEZ ON
REMOTELY. AND DOCTOR PAN IS ON
HIS WAY IN. N. WE WILL NOT
BEGIN THE SECOND ITEM. WHICH
IS. THE FORTY TO SIXTY
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES RESTORATION OF DENTAL
FEES UNTIL HE ARRIVES. BUT WILL
BE STARTING THAT COMMITTEE TO
DATE WITH THAT. ISSUE NUMBER
ONE FORTY ONE FIFTY DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE CHILDREN
AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL INITIATIVE.
AT THE PROVIDING TESTIMONY
pPARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS IN
THIS WILL AID US IN BEING ABLE
TO. AT THAT MAKE SURE YOU DON'T
GET FEEDBACK AT EVERY TIME YOU
RECOGNIZE TO SPEAK USE A PART
OF THE RAISE YOUR HAND. TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN THE L.
A. O. PLEASE BE RAISING YOUR
HANDS OTHERWISE I MAY NOT CALL
ON YOU. FOR A FISSION SEASICK
AT TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS
WE HAVE AN OPEN UP TO ROOMS
THAT WE SEAT ROOM TWENTY FORTY-
AND THEN PEOPLE WILL ALSO BE
ALLOWED TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. ON OUR TOLL FREE
ACCESS LINE AND THAT NUMBER
TODAY IS. 844-291-4185 IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN FOUR NINE
SEVEN NINE EIGHT SEVEN. THERE
WILL BE INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THAT WORKS. AB PLEASE AGAIN
REMEMBER TO MUTE THE PHONE ON
WHICH YOU'RE WATCHING THE AT
COMMITTEE. AND I WILL READ
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THAT
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED. TODAY'S HEARING
WILL BE DISCUSSING MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS FROM VARIOUS HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS- WE WILL BE HEARING
ITEMS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
NOW WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH A
PRESENTATION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT. OF MANAGED CARE- AN
ICY ED DIRECTOR. ONE TOP MUCH
TO HELP ME. ONE AND I SHE'S
HERE BRIGHT AND EARLY READY TO
GO. ARE YOU PREPARED TO BEGIN.
I AM READY CAN YOU HEAR ME OK
YES MA'AM WE CAN. THEY ARE ABLE
GOOD MORNING AGAIN MERRY WATCH
NOT BE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MNAGED
HEALTHCARE. I'M I'M PLEASED TO
BE HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
DEPARTMENTS PROVIDES DEBRIS FOR
OVERVIEW OF THE DEPARTMENT'S
ROLE IN THE MAY REVISED
PROPOSAL RELATED TO CHILDREN IN
YOUR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE. DID THE DEPARTMENT
HAS TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FOR
THIS INITIATIVE BUT WE DO NOT
HAVE A REQUEST FOR RESOURCES-
OUR ROLE IS REALLY TO ENSURE
ALL CHILDREN AND YOUTH
REGARDLESS OF INSURANCE STATUS
WILL BE ABLE TO ACCESS HEROES
HEALTH SERVICES AT SCHOOL.
ANTHER SCHOOL AFFILIATED
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
OR OTHER FACILITIES. WE ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT SCHOOLS
WILL BE REIMBURSED FOR THE
SERVICES PROVIDED TO COMMERCIAL
AND ROWLEY'S. THE PROPOSED
STATUTORY CHANGES OUT A NUMBER
OF NEW REQUIREMENTS TO HEALTH
PLANS THAT ARE ALREADY REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE MEDICALLY NECESSARY
TREATMENT FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER SERVICES.
BEGINNING JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR PLANTS WILL BE
REQUIRED TO REIMBURSE FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
PROVIDED AT SCHOOLS. REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER THE PLAN HAS A
CONTRACT WITH THE SCHOOL OR
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER. IF THE
SCHOOL DOES NOT PROVIDE
SERVICES ON CAMPUS THIS WOULD
INCLUDE SERVICES LINKED TO THE
SCHOOL. SUCH AS SERVICES
PROVIDED BY COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. TO STREAMLINE
THE REIMBURSEMENT PROCESS AND
REDUCE THE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN ON SCHOOLS WE ARE
PROPOSING THAT HEALTH PLANS
WILL REIMBURSE THE SCHOOLS. ARE
SERVICES PROVIDED STUDENTS AT
THE GREATER OF THE CONTRACTED
RATE THEY HAVE A CONTRACT WITH
THE SCHOOL FACILITY. FOR THE
RATE SET BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR MEDIC
CALIBRATES. THE SERVICE IS
PROVIDED IN SCHOOLS WILL NOT BE
SUBJECT TO ANY FORM OF
CARSHARING. SUCH AS COPAYS
COINSURANCE OR DEDUCTIBLES.
HEALTH PLANS WOULD BE
PROHIBITED FROM REQUIRE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION AND WOULD ONLY BE
ALLOWED TO DENY A CLAIM. IF
THEY REASONABLY BELIEVE THE
STUDENT WAS NOT ENROLLED IN A
HEALTH PLAN THE SERVICES WERE
NEVER PERFORMED OR THEY WERE
NOT PROVIDED BY HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER PROPERLY LICENSED TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE
DETAILS THAT WE WILL NEED TO
WORK THROUGH BEFORE THE
IMPLEMENTATION IN TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR INCLUDING THE SPECIFIC
SERVICES THE HEALTH PLANS WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO REIMBURSE. IN
THE COMING YEARS WE WILL
COORDINATE WITH THE HEALTH
PLANS DEPARTMENT OF YOUR
SERVICES. CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
INSURANCE AND SCHOOLS ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
INITIATIVE IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE TO THE PLANTS BEFORE
IMPLEMENTATION. AND WE WILL
ULTIMATELY PROMULGATE
REGULATIONS- MONITOR CAN. DRUG
OVERSIGHT PROCESS PROCESSES
SUCH AS MEDICAL SERVICE
FINANCIAL EXAMS AND MONITORING
COMPLAINTS TO THE- HOPE CENTER.
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY OVERVIEW
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AS YOU
NOTED THIS IS A- THIS IS ONE OF
THE COMPONENTS AS WERE ALL
TRYING TO PROVIDE A MORMON
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT. AND TO
OUR KIDS IN SCHOOL TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE THAT AS SEAMLESSLY
AS POSSIBLE THROUGH VARIOUS
FUNDING STREAMS TO MAKE SURE
THAT NO CHILD BASICALLY IS LEFT
BEHIND ON THIS. BERMAN OF- NOT
ILLEGAL PLEASE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR HIS YOU
KNOW WITH THEL. A. ON THIS
ISSUE- JUST A FEW BRIEF
COMMENTS HERE WE WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT THIS PROPOSAL APPEARS
TO REPRESENT A FAIRLY
SIGNIFICANT POLICY CHANGE- THAT
ALONG WITH SEVERAL OTHER
PROPOSALS WITHIN THE CHILDREN
AND YOUTH BEHAVIOR HEALTH
INITIATIVE- WOULD LIKELY COME
WITH ADDITIONAL ONGOING COSTS
ESPECIALLY GIVEN LIMITATIONS
ON- PRIOR AUTHORIZATION AS THE
AS THE- THE ADMINISTRATION JUST
NOTED- THE LEGISLATURE JUST MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER WHETHER THE
TRAILER BILL PROCESS- WOULD
ALLOW FOR SORT OF SUFFICIENT
LEGISLATIVE DELIBERATION ON
THIS ITEM OR- WHETHER WOULD BE
MORE APPROPRIATE TO CONSIDER
THIS ITEM AND I'M SORT OF IN
THE POLICY PROCESS. THOSE ARE
ALL OF OUR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME HAPPY HAPPY TO PROVIDE
FURTHER ASSISTANCE WHERE NEEDED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH S. AND I
WOULD GUESS A DIRECTOR BUT-
IT'S ALSO WE'RE SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES THAT WE DON'T HAVE MUCH
INFORMATION YET AND SO AS WE GO
FORWARD- MORE INFORMATION WILL
NEED TO BE. PROVIDED BECAUSE
THEY'RE STILL SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAD QUESTIONS
ABOUT. THAT BEFORE. ON ON NOT.
A NEW KIND OF ROLES A NEW
FOLKS. PROVIDING RESOURCES AND
HELP. SO AS WE GO FORWARD WE'LL
WE'LL FIGURE OUT IF THIS IS
GOING TO BE JUST A BUDGET ASK
OR IF IT'S GOING TO BE MOVED A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER DOWN. AS WE
DEVELOP THE POLICY. ON ALL OF
OUR GOALS I THINK ARE VERY
ALIGNED AND BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO TAKE YOUNG
PEOPLE. NO MATTER WHERE THEY
ARE AND NO MATTER THEIR PAYMENT
SOURCE. BUT IT'S JUST A IN THE
POLICY HOW OF THAT I THINK THAT
THERE STILL ARE SOME QUESTIONS.
AND OF. A GIFT. CANNOT THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IT GIVES
US. RAY SOME. ISSUES THAT WE
PERHAPS NEED TO. FIGURE OUT IN
THE POLICY MAKING PROCESS BUT I
THINK OVERALL CONCEPTUALLY IT
SEEMS TO MAKE SENSE. MAKES
SENSE- BUT- YOU KNOW I THINK
THE IDEA IS WE HAVE A BUDGET
PASSED ON TIME BUT WE CAN STILL
TAKE A LITTLE TIME TO. SUREST
FLUSH OUT THE POLICY ISSUES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY
RIGHT ON TIME DOCTOR PAN HAS
ARRIVED AND SO WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON WE'RE GONNA THINK- THE
DIRECTOR AND W'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO- DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES HERE STILL- WITH
THE RESTORATION OF DENTAL FEE
FOR SERVICE IN SACRAMENTO AND
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. MISTER
LIGHT BURN DIRECTOR LIVE ONE
GOOD MORNING SIR. MORNING
HEARING WILL DOCTOR PASSED FROM
WORK OR NOT. BOB HEALTHCARE
SERVICES. ON THIS PROPOSAL. YES
TO. ALL TRANSITION THE DELIVERY
OF MEDICAL DENTAL SERVICES. FOR
MANAGED CARE TO FEE FOR SERVICE
AND SACRAMENTO AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTIES- JERRY WHAT TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. ALL MITCHELL LOWS-
TRANSITION RENT CARLY PEOPLE
SERVICE ENVIRONMENT ALLOWING OR
DH CS TO. IMPLEMENT MORE
EFFECTIVE IN UNIFORM PROVIDER
IN BENEFICIARY OUTREACH- THE
NET SAVING OFF TWENTY MILLION
TOTAL PHONES MILLION GENERAL
FUND- AND THIS IS PART OF OUR
COMMITMENT TO INCREASING
MEDICAL BENEFITS REUTILIZATION
OF DENTAL SERVICES STATEWIDE-
RESPONSE TO- THE QUESTIONS ON.
THE TRANSACTION PLAN WHICH WAS
ACTUALLY DEVELOPED LAST YEAR
WITH A STICK WITH STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS ALL. BUT SPAWN BECAUSE
OF THE- AND I MAKE. OTHER
PRIORITIES- COLLUDED-
TRANSITION PLAN WITH- NOTICED
THE BENEFICIARIES OF NINETY DAY
SIXTY DAY AND THIRTY DAY
MILESTONES. OF DEEP- PROVIDE
OUTREACH REQUIREMENTS AND
SERVICE PROVIDES FOR TREATMENT
CONTINUATION OF FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH AN IMPROVED APPROVE
TREATMENT PLAN. AND ESTABLISH
RELATIONS WITH THE PROVIDER
WILL ALSO GENERAL RENDERING AT
OF PEOPLE SERVICE PROVIDER
HOME. IN SACRAMENTO SOMETHING
LIKE 87% ALL OF THE ALL ALL OF
PROVIDERS WHO NO LONGER ON THE
BENCH CARE OR ALSO IN ROLES-
FOR PEOPLE SERVICE AND WE WILL
ALL BE. REACHING RECRUITING FOR
THOSE WHO ARE NOT YET BEFORE
SERVICE ALL ENROLLEES ALONE THE
TRANSITION PLANS WILL BE
PROVIDED TO THE FISCAL AND
POLICY COMMITTEES OF THE
LEGISLATURE. ALL NO LATER THAN.
NINETY DAYS PRIOR TO THE START
OF THE TRANSITION- ALTHOUGH.
PROPOSAL STOP. WE LOST YOUR
HEARING DIRECTOR. YOU BUILT
YOUR VOLUME IS GONNA. YOU'RE A
MUTE. OKAY I'M VERY BACK THANK
I'M SORRY PROBLEMS SO WITH THE-
TRANSACTION PLAN SORT OF WHAT
YOU ARE ARE INTENDED TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN IDENTIFY CONTINUITY
ALL ON CARE FOR OUR FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND WE WILL WORK
WITH YOU WITH OUR-
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES- OUR-
THE OFFICE THAT OVERSEES THE
REST OF PEOPLE SERVICE ACROSS
THE STATE. AUG TO OUT REACH
SPECIFICALLY TO OUR
BENEFICIARIES TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS CONTINUITY- AND THAT-
ANY COMPLEX CARE ALL WHO THAT
IS UNDERWAY IS CONTINUED.
WITHOUT WITHOUT ANY
INTERRUPTION- QUESTION WAS
POSED STIR PALM WHAT WE DON'T
DO WE AN UNDERSTANDING OF. WHAT
MAY HAVE LED TO LOWER-
UTILIZATION OF BROWN'S BECAUSE
WE ARE WE DON'T ON STARTING A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO THE
DEPARTMENT ENGAGED WITH THE
DENTAL MANAGED CARE PLANS. TO
ENCOURAGE THEM IN TERMS OF
OUTREACH- YOU DID ACTIVITIES
ALL ALSO OF ALLOWED THEM TO A
GREATER DEGREE OF PAYMENT
FLEXIBILITY THE WHOLE BECAUSE
IT MIGHT. CHANGE THE OUTCOMES-
BUT- AS WE OBSERVE OBSERVED IN.
ALLEN TO YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN-
UTILIZATION FOR ON THE ANNUAL
DENTAL VISITS FOR CHILDREN BOB
WAS SIX PERCENTAGE POINTS LOWER
IN DENTAL MANAGED CARE THAN FEE
FOR SERVICE ALL PREVENTIVE
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN. WAS
EIGHT PERCENTAGE POINTS LOWER
THAN DOUBLE MANAGED CARE AND
THEN IN THE NOVEMBER TO OCTOBER.
TWENTY TWENTY. OCTOBER TWENTY
NINETEEN OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY
WHICH IS THE LAST. QUARTER FOR
WHICH WE HAVE ALL FOR
INFORMATION THE PATTERN
CONTINUES ON AND THIS IS
CONSISTENT- SO- LET ME STOP
THERE AND SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS I CAN
RESPOND TO. HELLO I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR COREY ISSUED A GAME
WITH THE L. A. L. WE BROUGHT UP
AN ANALYSIS OF THIS ISSUE WHEN
IT WAS- PROPOSED IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET- AND REYES NO MAJOR
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL-
GIVEN YOU KNOW LOWER
UTILIZATION DATA INTO MANAGED
CARE AND THAT WAS- THAT WAS
PRESENT- AND SO ASSUMING YOU
KNOW NO FOR NO FURTHER REVISED
DATA INDICATING IMPROVED
PERFORMANCE AND DENTAL MANAGED
CARE- WE WOULD SORT OF HAVE NO
ISSUES TO RAISE WITH THIS
PROPOSAL AS WELL. THANK YOU
OKAY. THE CDVA. THANK YOU HAVE
A PRE SHEET- THE PRESENTATION
AND CERTAINLY I HAVE SHARED THE
CONCERNS ABOUT LOWER
UTILIZATION FACT GOING ALL THE
WAY BACK TO WHEN I WAS IN THE
STATE ASSEMBLY AND ACTUALLY
BROUGHT UP. SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT COME OUT THAT OUR FIRST
FIVE COMMISSION HAD PERFORMED-
SO I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND TO A
CERTAIN DEGREE OF WHERE. THIS
IS COMING FROM BUT I DID HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS. ABOUT THE
THIS PROPOSAL AND I THINK MIGHT
MY REMARKS IS THAT MY QUESTIONS
OF PERHAPS MORE TARGET TO
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I KNOW THIS
IS THE SECOND ROUND LOS
ANGELES. I THINK THERE MAY BE
SOME DIFFERENCES- SO FIRST OF
ALL IN TERMS OF THE- THE
EXPECTED. SAVINGS ARE YOU
PROJECTING IT NOW TWENTY TWO.
MILLION A REDUCTION AND-
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY- WHERE IS
THAT TWENTY TWO MILLION COMING
FROM SO FOR EXAMPLE. I HAVE C.
SET THE RATES FOR THE DENTAL
MANAGED CARE PLAN IF YOU SWITCH
TO FEE FOR SERVICE ARE YOU
EXPECTING IS THAT PROJECT IS
THAT SAVINGS COMING FROM-
UTILIZATION AS SIMILAR TO WHAT
THE MANAGED CARES HAVE NOW DO
YOU PROJECTING AN INCREASE IN.
REALISATION TO THE STATE
AVERAGE OR ABOVE- AND SO WHEN
YOU DID YOUR CALCULATION OF THE
SAVINGS IS THAT AS A RESULT OF
THAT- SO HE JUST PERHAPS
SPECIFY A LITTLE MORE HOW YOU
CAME UP WITH THE TWENTY TWO
MILLION IN SAVINGS AND WHAT
WHAT'S PROJECTED UTILIZATION-
IF ONCE YOU TRANSFER EVERYONE
TO FEE FOR SERVICE THAT. YOU
USE AND CREATING THIS
PROJECTION. WELL THERE WILL
ONLY BE SORT OF SIX MONTHS OR
AFTER THE TRANSIT AND- BUDGET
YEAR- THERE'S SORT OF A-
UTILIZATION IS WHAT SORT OF
SIGNIFICANTLY TAMPERED WITH FOR
THAT SIX MONTH PERIOD SO REALLY
WHAT DO YOU TO SAVINGS
REPRESENTS- JUST THE SORT OF
THE DELTA. DENTAL ACOSTA OF
PROGRAM IT IS OUR GOAL TO HAVE
ON BOTH COUNTIES SACRAMENTO
COURSE IS MANDATORY HELLO- AND-
BUT WITH THE KNOCKED OUT RIGHT
AWAY WITH IT WOULD IT WOULD
AUTOMATICALLY UNLIMITED OFFICE.
WHERE IS OF LOS ANGELES IS
OFTEN ALL SO BUT OUR GOAL IS TO
IS TO TRY TO YOU KNOW SMOOTH IT
OUT ON OVER HELLO OF EUROPE TOO
SO THAT WE GET TO. ON STATEWIDE
AVERAGES SO THE SAVINGS IS
ESSENTIALLY. THE APPLICATION
RIGHT. OKAY AND THEN JUST THE
OTHER I GUESS IN TERMS BECAUSE
AFTER ALL YOU NEGOTIATE THE
RATE WITH THE DENTAL PLANS
MANAGED CARE PLANS SO- SO SOME
OF THAT. SO IN TERMS OF THE
RATE WHICH IS NEGOTIABLE TO
DENTAL MANAGED CARE PLAN SO IT
BASICALLY YOU'RE SAYING THAT
YOU'RE ASSUMING THE SAME
UTILIZATION RATE BECAUSE YOU'RE
SAYING IT'S THE SAME HERE SO
YOU DON'T EXPECT ANYTHING TO
CHANGE SIGNIFICANTLY IF IT'S
MIDWAY THROUGH THE YEAR. DEBT
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT DISRUPTION
AND WHAT THAT MAY DO. BUT THEN-
BUT THEN YOU'RE ALSO SAYING
THAT IN YOUR NEGOTIATION ON THE
DOW MANAGED CARE PLANS
BASICALLY- THAT- THAT YOU'RE-
GIVING THEM. A HIGHER- RATE.
RELATIVE TO- IN. IT WHEN
WINDOWS WRITTEN NEGOTIATED.
YEAH I MEAN TO BE HONEST. THE
RATES WATERSHED JUST AS LONG
BEFORE MY TIME ALONG. THAT THIS
WAS AN EXPERIMENT BUT WAS
FANTASY CORD CUTTING HAIR
COORDINATION BE INCREASED AND
YOU LET ME KNOW PREVENTIVE
REALIZE NATION MEMBERS THROUGH
AN INVESTMENT YEAH THE
STRUCTURE. AND- IT THE OFFICERS
THAT HASN'T OKAY AND THEN THE
OTHER THING QUESTION I HAVE IS
THAT IN SACRAMENTO- THERE'S
ACTUALLY- SACRAMENTO COUNTY-
PARTNERED WITH THE DENTAL
HEALTH PLANS AND DOING A
PROGRAM CALLED EARLY SMILES.
SACRAMENTO WAS SO THE DEALER
COMMUNITY OUTREACH AND SO THAT.
YOU KNOW THE REACHED OUT TO
OVER SIXTY TWO THOUSAND
CHILDREN AND TO DO DENTAL
SCREENINGS AND OTHER TYPES OF
THINGS- IS THAT I MEAN SO
THEY'RE NOT THESE ARE VISITS
SAID IN A DENTAL OFFICE IS THAT
COUNTED IN THE UTILIZATION
RATES ARE I MEAN HOW HOW AND IN
WHAT HAPPENS THAT PROGRAM IF WE
GO TO FEE FOR SERVICE SIDE SO I
JUST YOU KNOW WE- WILL LOSE
SOMETHING HERE. THAT WE'RE NOT
COUNTING AND SO THAT'S JUST SO
THAT THAT'S A SO THAT THE
ISSUE. I MEAN STATEWIDE- YOU
KNOW WHAT WE OPERATE THE SMILE
CALIFORNIA RICH CAMPAIGNS AND-
BURKE FOR EXACTLY THE SAME
PURPOSE- AND FRANKLY TV
CAMPAIGNS IN SACRAMENTO
BASICALLY UTILIZED THESE ARE
STATE WIDE SMILE- MATERIALS- SO.
ARE YOU I DON'T SEE A- YOU KNOW
ME JUST THERE ARE SO SUGGEST TO
BE CLEAR BECAUSE HE'S OUTSIDE.
THERE SO YOU SAYING THAT THE
EARLIEST. SACRAMENTO PROGRAM.
WE'LL STILL CONTINUE. WHEN THE
SWITCH TO THE FOR SERVICE
HAPPENS SO THERE'S BEEN
CONVERSATIONS THE COUNTY BE
SURE THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN NO IT
WOULDN'T LET ME CLARIFY IT WHAT
WILL BE IN ITS PLACE AS THE
SMILE CALIFORNIA PROGRAM AND
YOU KNOW WILL CERTAINLY FOCUS
IN TO MAKE SURE THAT WHAT THE
LEVEL OF ENGAGEMENT IS. NO
CONTINUES AND THEN THERE BEEN
CONVERSATIONS THE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY ABOUT THIS YET I DON'T
THINK SO OKAY ALL RIGHT. OKAY
SO THAT WOULD THAT WOULD BE
YEAH I HAVEN'T HEARD ANY
CONVERSATIONS EITHER SO. I
THINK THAT WOULD BE AN ISSUE
THAT I HOPE THAT WILL BE
ADDRESSED PRIOR TO ANY ACTION-
BECAUSE WE WOULD HATE TO LOSE
THAT. PROGRAM OR SOME ITERATION
THAT PROGRAM WHERE WE'RE DOING
OUTREACH TO FAMILIES AND
GETTING THEM PLUGGED INTO-
DENTAL CARE ACTUALLY THERE YOU
MAKE REFERRALS FOR HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE IF THEY'RE UNINSURED
AS WELL SO- SO I HOPE THERE
WILL BE CONVERSATIONS WITH- THE
FOLKS AT. IN MY CERTAINLY MY
DISTRICT MY COUNTY ABOUT THIS
BEFORE HE DESTRUCT THE PROGRAM
LIKE THAT. JUST OVER IMPORTANT.
SO I MEAN WE ARE ABSOLUTELY.
COMMITTED THAT WE WILL KNOW.
BECAUSE PART OF THE THIS
TRANSITION WILL BE SITTING DOWN
WITH OKAY SACRAMENTO COUNTY
HEALTH HELP TO BE SOME
CONVERSATION BEFORE MAKING A
DECISION SO- WE START A FEW
WEEKS BEFORE THAT SO- THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR ME TO HEAR
BACK FROM MY LOCAL FOLKS THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE FEEL
SURE THAT WILL CONTINUE- IF
THIS IS A DECISION THAT'S
BEING. DECIMATED. OKAY THE
INSTRUCTOR. OKAY OKAY ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THE LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. DO
WE HAVE ON OUR SITE. WE NEED
TO. RIGHT YEP SIX ONE MISTER
WEBER. THERE WERE WE MOVING ON
TO DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
I'M SORRY I THINK I MISSED IF
YOU TO MOSHLING IF YOU NUMBER.
THE DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE
SERVICES STILL ISSUE NUMBER TWO.
STRICTER LIBRARY COMEBACK
MISTER BROTHER GONNA DO IT.
YOUR DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH.
ARE YOU LOOKING FOR SPEAKER I
WAS LOOKING FOR MR LIFE BORN I
THINK THAT ISSUE NUMBER TWO
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
TRANSITIONS EXPANSION. I DO NOT
SEE HIM ON. THE AUDIO PORTION
OKAY. WELL I COULD HAVE I COULD
HAVE SAID GOODBYE TO HIM TOO
SOON SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THEN CIRCLE BACK FOR ISSUE
NUMBER TWO. I WAS A LITTLE BIT
LATER OKAY. MR BROWSER YOU'RE
GONNA TAKE US THROUGH
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
CERTAINLY SO- I THANK YOU ADRIN
BROTHER THE SISTER- DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CENTER FOR
ACTIONS DISEASE'S. ADAM I'M
GONNA KICK US OFF WITH COVERING
ISSUE NUMBER ONE- WHICH DOES
COVER ARE EIGHT OUT- ESTIMATE
AND ALSO I BELIEVE THERE IS AT
REQUEST YOU GO OVER OUR
PRACTICE SYSTEMS PROGRAM
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE YES I'M
AND THEN OF COURSE I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. FOR A
FACT MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE- SO
TO GET STARTED WE DO HAVE A-
RELATIVELY STRAIGHTFORWARD-
UPDATE FOR OUR- AIDS DRUG
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM ESTIMATE.
THE MAY REVISION IS REFLECTING
AN OVERALL DECREASE OF ELEVEN
POINT NINE. MILLION A DROP
EXPENDITURE AT THE WORKING
LOCAL SUBSTANCE. AND THE
DECREASE YEARS PRIMARILY DUE TO
A LOWER PROJECTED- MEDICATION
EXPENDITURES FOR MEDICATION
ONLY CLIENTS. AND THEN AND
BUDGET YEAR WE'RE SEEING A
SIMILAR DECREASE OF THIRTEEN
POINT NINE MILLION IN ATOPIC
SPEND INSURER FORTY FOR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE. AND THE PRIMARY
REASON IS THE SAME REASON BEING
EIGHTY PROJECTED DECREASE
MEDICATION EXPENDITURE FOR
MEDICATION ONLY FINANCE. THANK
YOU PAUSE THERE- IF YOU'D LIKE
TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS ON OUR I'M NAY
REVISION PROJECTIONS AS MISS
PEDICURE EVERYTHING. NO MA'AM
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ANYTHING. THIS TIME I'M SURE.
NOW OKAY AND WHAT AND CAN YOU
JUST TALK A LITTLE BIT OF A BAR
YOU THINK THOSE ARE GOING DOWN.
YEAH SO- WE ARE ACTUALLY
ADJUSTING OUR ESTIMATES WITH
MORE REAL TIME- DATA THAT WE
HAD AVAILABLE ONE TO NOVEMBER
ESTIMATE. AND SO- ARE. UPDATED
DATA SHOWS THAT- YOU MAY HAVE A
SLIGHT DECREASE WE'RE STILL
REALLY TRYING TO GAUGE WHAT HE-
A POTENTIAL DRIVER BEHIND THAT
IS WHETHER- EAT PANDEMIC HAD
ANY INFLUENCE ON OUR- VIDAK AND
ROMANTIC BUT IT'S- IT'S-
TYPICAL THAT WE SEE SOME SORT
OF AN ADJUSTMENT FOR. THE MAY
REVISION AND REALLY WHEN WE
LOOK WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF OUR-
OVERALL BUDGET AND CLIENT
CASELOAD IT'S RAW IT'S A
RELATIVELY MINIMAL- UPDATE. HI
I MEAN IT DIDN'T HAVE THE
PROGRAM'S BEEN AS A AS I GUESS
WE CAN SAVE THEM ASSEMBLY USE
OR VIBRANT BUT AS AS A VIGOROUS
AS USUAL JUST BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC AND MAYBE PUBLIC
HEALTH RESOURCES HAVE BEEN.
OTHERWISE FOCUSED. RIGHT SO FOR
THIS SPECIFIC PROGRAM WE TOOK A
NUMBER OF STEPS EARLY ON IN THE
PANDEMIC TO ENSURE CONTINUITY
OF CARE AND ACCESS TO
MEDICATION- I'LL BE PROVIDED-
CLIENTS WITH LG ELIGIBILITY
EXPANSIONS. ARE WE ALSO PUT A
NUMBER OF PROCESSES IN PLACE TO
FACILITATE REMOTE ENROLLMENT.
SO WE'RE EXPECTING THAT PERHAPS
ANY IMPACT TO THE SPECIFIC
PROGRAM AS A RESULT OF THE
PANDEMIC IT'S RELATIVELY-
ANYTHING HONEST ARE DIFFERENT
THE OKAY. WE WANT ISSUE NUMBER
TWO. DID YOU WANT ME TO COVER
THE PROPER SYSTEMS PROGRAM
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AS WELL
YES YES OKAY PERFECT- SO JUST
VERY QUICKLY WE ARE PROPOSING A
TECHNICAL AMENDMENT TO HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE- TO ALLOW THE
PRACTICE SYSTEMS PROGRAM TO PAY
FOR IT SPECIFIED ANCILLARY
SERVICES. OR PERSON WHO'S
DISPENSED WORK BRITISH PROPER
PAT I'M PURSUING TO BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS CODE EXISTING
LAW WHICH IS CODIFIED IN HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE SPECIFIES THAT
IN ORDER FOR THE OFFICE OF AIDS
TO SUBSIDIZE THE COST OF PREP
AND PAP. PERSONS MUST POSSESS
OR OBTAIN A PRESCRIPTION I'M SO
I'M SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY NINE
AND TWENTY NINETEEN MODIFIED
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE.
I'M AUTHORIZING A PHARMACIST TO
DISPENSE ORPHANAGE PROPER PATH
TO PERSONS WITHOUT A
PHYSICIAN'S PRESCRIPTION AND-
THIS IN A DIFFERENT WE CREATED
A SMALL CONFLICT BETWEEN-
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
AND HEALTH AND SAFETY CODES.
I'M AS THE WORD PRESCRIPTION IS
DEFINED VERY DISTINCTLY FROM
FURNITURE DISPENSED- MEANING
BACK THE PROPER SYSTEMS PROGRAM
WOULD NOT TECHNICALLY BE
FOLLOWING THE LETTER OF THE LAW
TO BE PAID FOR SERVICES FOR
PURCHASE MAP WIRES- PROVIDED
PROPER BACK PURSUANT TO
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
SO THIS IS REALLY HARMONIZED.
WHAT WE KNOW IS YOUNG TALENTS
ARE BETWEEN THESE TWO STATUTES.
INCREASE ACCESS. OKAY THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY MY PLEASURE ALL
RIGHT SO LET'S MOVE ON TO
NUMBER. TWO NUMBER ONLY DO YOU
WANT TO START FOR ISSUE NUMBER
TWO. HI GOOD MORNING THIS IS
RICHARD ONLY FROM THE GENETIC
DISEASE SCREENING PROGRAM I'M
THE DIVISION DIRECTOR. AND
POSITION NUMBER TWO IS A
PROPOSAL TO REMOVE THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR OUR
H. HUMILITY DISEASE OF THE
NEWBORN. IN THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE- GOING BACK TO
NINETEEN SEVENTY THERE'S BEEN A
STATE REQUIREMENT FOR PROVIDERS
TO REPORT R. H. DISEASE STARTED
PARDON. BUT SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY ROUTINE TESTING OF OUR
EIGHT STATUS AND USE OF THE
THERAPY KNOWN AS ROGAN HAS
BECOME THE CLINICAL STANDARD OF
CARE. SO WHAT WAS ONCE A PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERN HAS FORTUNATELY
BECOME A RARE EVENT. CALIFORNIA
IS CURRENTLY ONE OF THE ONLY
STATES THAT COLLECTS DATA ON
CASES AND SUSPECT CASES OF OURS
DISEASE. THE ORIGINAL INTENT
INTENT OF THE LEGISLATION HAS
BEEN A CHIU STATEWIDE AND
NATIONALLY. AND CLINICAL
REQUIREMENTS WILL CONTINUE.
THIS CHANGE COULD ALLOW CITY PH
AND BIRTH HOSPITAL STAFF TO
FOCUS SURVEILLANCE RESOURCES
SOME MORE IMPORTANT CAUSES SUCH
AS PREVENTING OTHER EMERGING
ISSUES. THERE ARE MANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT. THANKS
FOR. THE VIOLATE JUST HOW MANY
CASES HAVE BEEN REPORTED IN THE
PAST YEAR TEN YEARS. YEAH IT'S-
THAT USED TO BE- WELL OVER- C.
WHICH OF MY FIGURES HERE WE
USED TO HAVE- HUNDREDS OF CASES
BUT- WHAT THE MORTALITY WAS
ONCE- FOUR HUNDRED AND TEN PER
HUNDRED THOUSAND. IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY AND NOW IT'S LESS THAN
FIFTEEN DOLLARS PER HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR. OKAY
THERE ARE STILL A FIFTEEN
ATTIRED EXPECTED ACTUALLY. YEAH
IT'S A RARE EVENT THOUGH
COMPARED TO WHAT IT USED TO BE-
YEAH I'M DEFINITELY AS A
PEDIATRICIAN I KNOW THAT BUT
THOSE CURIOUS AS TO HOW MANY WE
ACTUALLY ARE GETTING EVEN NOW
BUT YEAH MOST OF THE CASES ARE
REPORTED TO US OR ACTUALLY
SUSPECT CASES- AND NOT THROUGH
CONFLICT DISEASE OKAY ALL RIGHT
THANKS. HI THANK YOU THAN NOT
MOVING ON. OKAY SO- THIS IS
RICHARD ONLY STONE NEXT I'M
GOING TO DISCUSS- ARE MANY
REVISIONS FOR THE GSP ESTIMATE.
AND AS A REMINDER TO THE REMOTE
AUDIENCE- ARE BUDGET SUPPORTS
ACTIVITIES OF TWO MAJOR
PROGRAMS. OUR FIRST THE
MANDATORY CALIFORNIA NEWBORN
SCREENING PROGRAM KNOWN AS AND
THE US. BEYOND THE STATE WIDE
VOLUNTARY CALIFORNIA PRENATAL
SCREENING PROGRAM ALSO KNOWN AS
PNS. ARME REVISIONS HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED BY TRENDS IN LIVE
BIRTHS WHICH HAVE DECREASED
NUMEROUS REASONS STATISTICS AND
ARE PROJECTED TO CONTINUE TO
TREND DOWNWARD. THESE TRENDS
WILL AFFECT BOTH AND THE S. AND
P. AND ALSO GIVE AN OVERVIEW OF
THE COMBINED EFFECT. ON BOTH
PROGRAMS TOGETHER. SO FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR- IN THE MAY
REVISION WE'RE NOW ESTIMATING
ARE REQUESTED EXENDITURE
AUTHORITY. AT ABOUT A HUNDRED
FORTY POINT FIVE MILLION. WHICH
IS A VERY SLIGHT NOT CHANGED
PARTLY DUE TO INCREASED
EXPENDITURES ATTRIBUTED TO ON
AND THEN BURSARY. BOB FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR THERE IS A SLIGHT
DECREASE IN THE MAY REVISION
AND LOCAL ASSISTANCE
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY. BRINGING
THE TOTAL REQUESTED AUTHORITY
FOR FY. TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
TWO. ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE MILLION. AS EXPECTED
WITH THE CONTINUING DROP IN THE
BURST RATE WE CONTINUE TO SEE A
DROP IN CASELOAD AND REVENUE.
AND WE'RE ADJUSTING OUR CURRENT
YEAR REVENUE DOWNWARD BY THREE
POINT THREE MILLION AND THE
BUDGET YOUR DOLLARS OR ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION. HOWEVER
REVENUES ARE STILL SUFFICIENT
TO COVER EXPENDITURES. ARE FINE
CONDITION CONTINUES TO REMAIN
STRONGER THAN EXPECTED BALANCE
OF 4% BY THE END OF THE BUDGET
YEAR. CHANGES IN THE MAY
REVISION WITH OUR CELL FREE DNA
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL THAT WAS
INTRODUCED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. AND AS A REMINDER
LABORATORY COST INCREASES AND
FEE STRUCTURE CHANGES FIVE SEP
THOSE COSTS WILL BEGIN IN JULY
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. ANY
QUESTIONS OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I DON'T SEE L. A. O. OR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WITH
THEIR HANDS UP. I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING ON THE STAR TRIBUNE.
WELL JUST A THANK YOU- PRISCILA
WORK ON YOUR WINDSCREEN THANK.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY
ON TO- ISSUE NUMBER FOUR- IS
NELSON IS THAT YOU. YES GOOD
MORNING MORNING SILVA WITH
ESTIMATE I PROVIDE ABOUT HIS.
AND ALSO SOME OF THE IN. AN
INCREASE AND OUR NEXT THAT
COMING UP. I'M INSTEAD. OF TWO
TWO WHAT CAL WHICH- EIGHT AND
NINETY FOR. THAT MONEY. AND
THEN IN MARCH AND APRIL OF
TWENTY TWENTY WE SAW INCREASES
OF ABOUT 5% EACH MONTH. AND
THEN THROUGHOUT THE SUMMER-
SMALLER INCREASES JUST OVER 1%
EACH MONTH. AND BY OCTOBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY WE HAD HIT NINE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO THOUSAND
PARTICIPANTS WHICH IS ABOUT AN
18% INCREASE. OVER FEBRUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY AND SINCE OCTOBER
WE STAYED PRETTY FLAT RIGHT
ABOUT OF NINE HUNDRED FIFTY
TWO. THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS EACH
MONTH CONTACT A MAJOR DOWNSTAGE
MONTH THAT REALLY KIND OF
SLACKED OCT. AND SO IN THE-
ESTá. ARE CAO. IN THE. BIG
MONTHS MARK- MARCH THAT HAPPENS
TO BE MONTHS AND THEN ON-
INCREASES THROUGH THE SOME. AND
SO WITH THE REACH. AND MAY BE
MORE THOSE MONTHS WHERE WE'VE
REALLY HAVE TO SO JUST A LITTLE
BIT OF THE- IN OUR PURCHASE.
NUMBERS AND THEN ALSO. THE
RESULT FOOD EXPENSE. IN IN MAY.
BE CHANGED HAVE HAS HAVE IN
WAKE RECENTLY AS FROM THE
AMERICAN PLAN. THERE IS-
AUTHORITY AND- TO INCREASE THE
FOR AND BY. MONTHS ALEX. FOR
ANY PURCHASE A OVER TWELVE
MONTHS OF THE- WHERE NOW THE
MONTH FOR BATCH AND- IS NINE OR
DAHLE DEPENDING ON THE- A
CATEGORY. FILINVEST WILL AS
WELL OF THE- A DIFFERENT WAY OF
ISSUE BENEFITS AND WIKI THE-
ARE THE ACTUAL ITEM LIKE IT
DOES DAYS ARE DOWN MILK BUT FOR
FRIEDMAN BATCH. SO WE WILL BE
IMPLEMENTING THAT CHANGE ON
JUNE FIRST AND RUNS THROUGH THE
END OF SEPTEMBER AT A COST OF
ABOUT TWENTY NINE DOLLARS PER
MONTH AND SO THOSE ADDITIONAL
FOOD EXPENDITURES ARE INCLUDED
IN THE ESTIMATE REVISIONS.
THEY'VE ALREADY BEEN
COMMUNICATE WITH FAMILIES-
LOCAL AGENCIES ARE DOING A LOT
OF. SOCIAL MEDIA AND EDUCATION
pARE. FULLY AWARE THAT IT IS
THAT THERE IS A GREAT INCREASE
COMING AND IT IS SOMETHING THAT
IS JUST TEMPORARY WHAT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WELL EVERY
LITTLE BIT HELPS ESPECIALLY
OVER THE SUMMER MONTHS MONTHS
THAT. WE HAVE ALL THIS GREAT
FRESH FRUITS AND VEGETABLES-
THE BETTER BETTER.BETTER ALL
THE INDIGNATION SEASON RIGHT
NOW. M. OKAY WELL I AM GOOD I'M
GLAD AND WE'RE GLAD THAT YOU'RE
DOING ALL THIS GOOD WORK AND
MAKING SURE. THAT FOOD GETS OUT
TO PEOPLE DIED COMPENDIUM
ANYTHING HONEST. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND IS. BEFORE MOVE
ON AS MR LIGHT BORN I KEEP
GETTING MESSAGES HE'S HERE HE'S
HE'S NOT MISTER WHITE BORN ARE
YOU THERE. YES I AM. SORRY
THAT'S OKAY PERFECTLY HARD TO
MOVE ON THE PUBLIC HEALTH I
THOUGHT I SHOULD GO TO WORK
YEAH. COME ON BACK AND WE'RE
WITH US IN BIT LAW. OKAY SO
WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO NEW TWO.
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE
TRANSITIONED EXPANSION CLEAN UP.
YES VERY BRIEFLY WHAT THIS IS-
LASTED AS YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA
CREATED THE STATE ONLY VERSION
OF THE- CCTV PROGRAM THAT- THE-
NATIONAL PROGRAM WHICH IS
EFFECTIVE AFTER SOMEONE HAS
BIRD OR IS THIS ELIGIBLE FOR IT
AFTER THEY'VE BEEN IN AN
INSTITUTIONAL SETTING FOR
NINETY DAYS OR MORE IN DECEMBER.
FEDERAL DOLLARS. BOB GRAHAM
CHANGED BY STATUTE TO BEING
SIXTY DAYS OR MORE SO THIS ARE
ARE PROPOSAL SIMPLYCONFORMS
THE STATE BENEFIT THROUGH THE
FEDERAL BENEFITS SO AT THE
STATE LEVEL ANYONE
INSTITUTIONAL SIXTY DAYS OR
MORE IS ELIGIBLE FOR THE
TRANSITION SERVICES. TO HELP
OUR COMMUNITY BUSINESS. OKAY
THANK YOU. I DO NOT SEE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE OR THE L. A.
O. WITH ANY THING TO SAY ON
THIS I THINK WE'RE ALL OKAY
WITH THIS OKAY BUT THANK YOU
JUST COMING BACK IN AND MAKING
SURE WE DID THAT OUT LOUD BUT I
APPRECIATED AND MY APOLOGIES
FOR MONEY MY APOLOGIES TO ALL
RIGHT OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MOVING ON TO ISSUE. IS IT IS
USED SIX. PRIVATE DISAPPEAR SO
WILL GO RIGHT ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER SIX. DR RADHIKA GOOD
MORNING SIR. GOOD MORNING. THIS
ISSUE IS ABOUT- FUNDING FOR IT-
REVIEWING OR PANDEMIC RESPONSE
MANY RESPECTED THE MUST HAVE
GONE HAS T. PAY STRUCTURE IN
STATE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER.
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN
CALIFORNIA HAS HIGHLIGHTED THE
IMPORTANCE OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
IT HAS EXPOSED SIGNIFICANT
GAPS. IN THE ABILITY OF CDPH
AND LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS
TO RESPOND TO THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS. YEARS OF LIMITED
FUNDING OR FUNDING CUTS HAVE
DISMANTLED THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING
RESOURCES AND STAFF BOTH AT THE
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL. OVER THE
PAST FEW DECADES THE EROSION OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE ACROSS THE
NATION. HAS RESULTED IN A LACK
OF TRAINED PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE ANTIQUATED DATA AND
INFORMATION SYSTEMS. INCREASE
CATEGORICAL FUNDING ALLOWING
LITTLE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THE SPECIFIC NEEDS OF EACH
STATE. AND ITS COMMUNITIES. AND
ONE TIME FUNDING INJECTIONS TO
ADDRESS SPECIFIC EMERGENCIES
WITH NO LONG TERM IMPROVEMENTS
IN PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE.
IN ADDITION CALIFORNIA FACES
ENORMOUS PUBLIC HEALTH
CHALLENGES INCLUDING RACIAL AND
ETHNIC HEALTH INEQUITIES
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING
INSTABILITY. INCREASING MENTAL
ILLNESS AND SUBSTANCE USE
PRUDENT SECURITY. AN AGING
POPULATION CLIMATE CHANGE AND
EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS
INCREASED MEDICAL CARE COSTS
THREATS TO HELP THEIR
HEALTHCARE ACCESS AND NOW THE
COVE IN NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THE
PURPOSE OF THIS PROPOSAL IS TOO
FAST THE EXISTING PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND IDENTIFY
RESOURCES NEEDED TO STRENGTHEN
THE PUBLIC'S THE STATE'S PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL
AS LOCALS. THE KEY TO
PROTECTING AND IMPROVING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH LIES IN A STRONG
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
SUPPORTED BY ADEQUATE AND
STABLE FUNDING. HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS MUST BE READY
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN TO SERVE
THEIR COMMUNITIES THIS REQUIRES
ACCESS TO A WIDE RANGE OF
CRITICAL DATA SOURCES ROBUST
LABORATORY CAPACITY
PREPAREDNESS OF POLICY PLANNING
CAPACITY MODERNIZE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS STRONG
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
COMMUNICATIONS FIRST STRATEGIC
HEALTH CARE PARTNERSHIPS. AND A
BREATH AND DEPTH OF SUSTAINED
EXPERT STAFF WE MUST THINK NOT
ONLY SHORT TERM NOT ONLY THE
SHORT TERM NEEDS OF THE
PANDEMIC BUT CONSIDER THE LONG
TERM READINESS OF OUR STATE AND
HOW AN IMPROVED BASELINE HEALTH
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS. CAN HELP
WHETHER THE NEXT PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY IT'S CRITICAL THAT
THE STATE UNDERTAKE THIS REVIEW
AND TAKE THE NECESSARY STEPS TO
INSURERS CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE IS
ADEQUATELY RESOURCE. WE WILL
ASSESS ONGOING WORKFORCE NEEDS
LABORATORY CAPACITY CRITICAL
RESOURCES AND WILL ENGAGE
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING HEALTH
DEPARTMENT LEADERS AND KEY
STAFF. OF ALL OF THIS. BASIC
STEP AND COMMITMENT TOWARDS
BUILDING A TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM CDPH WILL
LEVERS AND NEEDS ASSESSMENT TO
IDENTIFY OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STRATEGIC INVESTMENTS OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND TO SERVE AS A
FOUNDATION FOR BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL AS PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE BUDGET. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I DON'T SEE
DEPARTMENT FINANCIALLY. ILLEGAL
PLEASE. AND MANAGE YOUR THIS IS
US ON YOU PICK FROM THE ILIO
AND- I WOULD JUST SAY THAT DR
AIRGUNS DESCRIPTION SOUNDED A
BIT MORE LIKE- ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT THE PANDEMIC RESPONSE
REVIEW AND I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE- WE DO HAVE SOME COMMENTS
ABOUT THE PANDEMIC RESPONSE
RUBIO AND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WANT TO TALK ABOUT COMMON
EXPENDITURES AT THE MOMENT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARE GOING TO
DO IT I SPOKE OUT OF TURN I
SPOKE OUT OF TURN SORRY OKAY
WE'RE NOT HAVING HEARINGS IN
THE MORNING THAT'S OKAY LET'S
JUST HAVE IT LET'S JUST MAKE
THE NUMBER SIX OKAY NUMBER
EIGHT OKAY I WAS ELECTED TO
NUMBER. EIGHT SINCE YOU DID IT
AND THEN. IT MADAM PRECIADO I
WOULD NOTE MADE- SIX SEVEN AND
EIGHT ARE SORT OF INTERWOVEN
AND JUST LOOKING AT THEM
BECAUSE SIX IS THE- USER THAT
ANDERSON THAT WE HAVE THE
FEDERAL GRANT AUTHORITY AND I
REALIZE THERE'S ACTUALLY
DIFFERENT QUESTIONS ASSOCIATED
WITH EACH SO. I GUESS WE COULD
GO THEM BACKWARDS OR I DON'T
KNOW IF ELLIE- HASN'T ARE YOU
HAVE SOME SORT MANAGER WHETHER.
WE SHOULD. PUT THEM ALL
TOGETHER OR ARE. WHATEVER YOU
WISH BUT I WOULD MAKE AN
OBSERVATION THOSE THREE SEEM TO
BE ALL INTERLINKED OKAY. BUT
SINCE HE JUST DID NUMBER EIGHT.
MISTAKE ARE YOU PREPARED TO
REMARK ON NUMBER EIGHT. I AM
FOCUSED BUT WE JUST GRABBED
THIS AND KEEP IT CLEAN AND
BRIGHT THERE. OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH AGAIN I'M SORT OF HEADED
FROM THE L. A. O. WE JUST HAVE
A FEW A FEW COMMENTS ABOUT THIS
ONE IN PARTICULAR SO I WE NOTE
THAT THIS PANDEMIC RESPONSE
REVIEW MENTIONS THREE KEY
ASPECTS OF THE REVIEW. THE
FIRST IS TO ASSESS THE STATE'S
PUBLIC HEALTH INTERESTS. I'M
SORRY THE STATE'S PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSE TO THE KOBE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THE SECOND IS TRUE
VIEW. IS CENTRAL PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND- I NEEDS AND
RESOURCES AND THEN THE THIRD IS
TO ASSESS ROOT CAUSES OF THE
DISPARITIES EXPERIENCED BY
THOSE WHO ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
COBIT- AND THE PROPOSAL STATES
THAT THESE ACTIVITIES WILL BE
UNDERTAKEN TO INFORM. A. B. A
PROPOSAL OUT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
IN JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. I OTHER YOU KNOW SOME OF
THE DETAILS ARE NOT KNOWN ABOUT
THIS REVIEWS SO FOR EXAMPLE%
WHAT EXACTLY WILL THE PROCESS
BE HAPPY WILL BE AND WHAT WILL
THE DEIVERABLES BE ASIDE FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL.
AND THEN WHAT WHAT WILL THE
FUNDS BE SPENT ON ASIDE FROM
THE POSSIBILITY OF- PROCURING A
VENDOR TO HELP CONDUCT THE
RADIO. AND SO. YET BREEDING
AGAIN HAVE A FEW KEY POINTS-
FIRST WE KNOW THAT THE TIMING
OF THIS- BUT THESE PROPOSED
ACTIVITIES AS WELL AS THE PIECE
OF THE PROPOSAL THAT OUR OUR
REVIEW OF THE COMPANY EIGHTEEN
RESPONSE. REALLY APPEAR KEEN TO
AN AFTER ACTION REVIEW. AN
AFTER ACTION REVIEWS ARE
CONDUCTED IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING
A PUBLIC HEALTH EVENTS- JUST TO
GIVE AN EXAMPLE- AFTER
HURRICANE KATRINA AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL CONDUCTED
AN AFTER ACTION REVIEW JUST
FIVE- WITHIN JUST FIVE MONTHS-
IT'S REALLY HELPED MEANT TO
HELP THE KEY PLAYERS UNDERSTAND
THE VARIOUS ACTIONS THEY TOOK
TO RESPOND TO THE TO THE
EMERGENCY TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
WENT WELL WHAT DIDN'T GO WELL
WHAT NEEDS TO BE CHANGED. SO I
AM BASED ON ON THIS- WEEK WE
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT AN AFTER
ACTION REVIEW IN THE CASE OF
CODE NINETEEN IS BOTH CRITICAL
AND VERY IPORTANT. HOWEVER WE
WOULD NOTE THAT THE SCOPE OF
THIS PROPOSAL SEEMS MUCH
BROADER DESPITE THE VERY
AGGRESSIVE TIMELINE. I'M NOT
ONLY WOULD THEY BE ASSESSING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE TO
COVET BUT THEY WOULD ALSO BE
SEEKING TAKE ANSWER A SET OF
COMPLEX QUESTIONS ABOUT PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND
RESOURCE NEEDS. AS WELL AS
ASSESS THE ROOT CAUSES OF
DISPARITIES WHICH WERE
EXACERBATED BY COVERT NINETEEN.
ANOTHER POINT WOULD MAKE ABOUT
THE PROPOSAL ITSELF IS THAT
THERE APPEARS TO BE SOME
DUPLICATION WITH ANOTHER STUDY
PROPOSED WITHIN THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY. AND THE
AGENCY HAS PROPOSED ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION TO CONDUCT A
RETROSPECTIVE ANALYSIS OF THE
INTERVIEW INTERSECTION OF
COVETED NINETEEN AND-
DISPARITIES. SO THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY A VERY IMPORTANT LENS
THROUGH WHICH TO VIEW THE
PANDEMIC RESPONSE WE JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
DUPLICATION AND I'M BETWEEN THE
TWO EFFORTS. I'M SO THE ISSUES
WE WOULD RAISE FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION. INCLUDE THE
FOLLOWING SO FIRST- WE'D
SUGGEST THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER BREAKING- THE REVIEW
INTO TWO DIFFERENT STUDIES THE
FIRST WOULD BE THE AFTER ACTION
REVIEW IT WILL BE DONE QUICKLY
IT COULD LIKELY BE DONE IN
HOUSE THE COST COULD LIKELY BE
ABSORBED- WITHIN THE EXISTING
BUDGET- IT COULD HELP WITH NEAR
NEAR TERM DECISION MAKING- AND
CLOSING SOME OF THE IDENTIFIED
GAPS. WE WOULD THEN SUGGEST A
MOLD A MORE MULTI YEAR
ASSESSMENT TO CONDUCT A
COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS AS WELL AS
RESOURCE NEEDS OF BOTH THE
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL WE ALSO
WOULD SUGGEST TO TAKE IT EVEN
FURTHER AND LOOK AT THE ROLE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH IN CALIFORNIA AND
THE GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE. TO
HELP- AT HELP DECISION MAKERS
FIGURE OUT EXACTLY WHAT THEY
WANT- THE DEPARTMENT TO DO. I
WOULD SUGGEST CONTRACTING OUT
FOR THIS STUDY SOTHAT IT'S AN
INDEPENDENT AND UNBIASED
ASSESSMENT. THE COST- IT
DEPENDS REALLY ON THE SCOPE IT
COULD SOMEONE EXCEED THREE
THREE MILLION BUT WE YOU KNOW
WE DON'T KNOW FOR SURE PROBABLY
NOT BY A LOT MORE THAN THREE
MILLION- AND THEN IN THE
MEANTIME THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT
WANT TO CONSIDER TEMPORARY
FUNDING TO BOLSTER DEPARTMENT
AND LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS.
WE KNOW THAT THE FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT IS AVAILABLE TO AT
BOTH THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL
IS VERY COVERT SPECIFIC RIGHT
NOW AND UNLIMITED. AND WHILE A
COMPREHENSIVE STUDY IS UNDER
WAY LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO
CONSIDER TEMPORARY ASSISTANCE
ALONG WITH ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES TO BOTH THE DEPARTMENT
AND- LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO MAINTAIN SOME OF
THE STAFFING CAPABILITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN DEVELOPED OVER THE
LAST YEAR. AND THEN ONCE THE
REVIEW IS COMPLETED THE
LEGISLATURE CAN DETERMINE THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF ONGOING
FUNDING FOR BOTH THE DEPARTMENT
AND THE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS BASED ON. SORT OF
THE RESPECTIVE RESPONSIBILITIES
AND ANY FUTURE REQUIREMENTS. SO
WE'RE SUGGESTING THAT TO ENSURE
FUNDING IS AVAILABLE TO ADDRESS
BOTH NEAR TERM AND LONG TERM
NEEDS THE LEGISLATURE COULD NOT
SET ASIDE SOME FUNDING AS PART
OF THIS YEAR'S BUDGET. BUT MAKE
THE ALLOCATION OF THOSE FUNDS
DEPENDING ON FINDINGS OF BOTH
REVIEWS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH S. PUBLIC-
WELL LOOK YOU'RE GOING TO I
WOULD- AND- I WOULD SUGGEST
MAYBE WAS. AN ACCIDENT THE
PRESENT A NUMBER EIGHT FIRST
BUT I THINK- I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND AND I THINK IN LIGHT
OF WHAT MISS PEGGY SAID AND I
THINK WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT SOME
OF US WAS BEEN FEELING THERE
MAYBE THERE WASN'T ENOUGH OR AS
MUCH AS THAT WE THOUGHT THERE
WAS GOING TO BE. GIVEN THE-
PANDEMIC THAT WE'VE JUST COME
OUT OF AN ARM AND THE ECONOMY
WITHOUT THE LACK OF INVESTMENT
IN PUBLIC HEALTH PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC AND THEN WITH THIS
FIRST CHANCE WITH THE BUDGET.
SO WE DO APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO DO- A
LOOK BACK AND A LOOK FORWARD-
AND I THINK I THINK THAT FOR MY
REMARKS ARE MORE. AND AS WE
TALKED ABOUT WITH MENTAL HEALTH
THERE'S A LOT OF A LOT OF GOOD
PLANS FOR GOING FORWARD. BUT
THERE SEEMS TO BE SOME. URGENCY
NOW THAT WE THAT WE MAY BE
OVERLOOKING- AND- AND SO I
WOULD I WOULD I WOULD AGREE
WITH MISS PETTICOAT SOUNDS LIKE
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS. TAKE A
GOOD LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED. BUT
THEN GOING FORWARD REALLY RE
ENVISIONING I THINK WHAT PUBLIC
HEALTH IS GOING TO LOOK LIKE IN
CALIFORNIA. IS A IS A REALLY
GOOD IDEA- ALL ASPECT PAN IF HE
HAS ANY QUESTIONS BUT THEN I
THINK THE BEST THAT WE CAN GO
BACK AND LOOK AT. IN THE WORLD.
WHAT WE ARE DOING- BUT I THINK
ENOUGH. I THINK THAT I THINK
WILL WILL WILL COME BACK WITH
SOME IDEAS OF OUR OWN. ABOUT
HOW TO PROVIDE SOME MORE
ASSISTANCE. IN A MOTOR THE MORE
SHORT TERM. BUT DEPEND. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND-
SEVERAL QUESTIONS- SO FOR A
FIRST OF ALL- YOU KNOW I HOPE
THAT AS WE'RE TALKING WITH THIS
ITEM THE PROPOSAL IS FOR THREE
MILLION FOR OF YOU AND I
APPRECIATE THE L. A. AS-
ANALYSIS OF THAT BUT THIS IS
THE PLAY ALSO THE PLACE AND I
MADE REFERENCE ANNIE WE'VE IN
SOME OF THE STUFF THAT WILL
TALK ABOUT A LITTLE LATER WITH-
SEVEN SIX AND SEVEN. IN THIS-
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE ALREADY
KNOW. SO I MEAN AND LET'S AND
LET'S NOT PRETEND WE DON'T KNOW
THERE ARE PROBLEMS. WE ARE YOU
KNOW THEIR PROBLEMS. AND TO SAY
THAT WE'RE GOING TO WAIT A
WHOLE YEAR. RIGHT BECAUSE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THIS BUDGET YEAR
FOR THREE MILLION THAT AND
WE'LL GO INTO A GENDER PROPOSAL
WHICH WE WON'T DECIDE UNTIL
NEXT. JULY ACTUALLY LITTLE MORE
THAN A YEAR AND THEN AFTER
IMPLEMENTED- I THINK IS THIS
DANGEROUS FRANKLY- BECAUSE WE
THOUGHT THE BY THE WAY THE
PANDEMIC HAS NOT GONE AWAY I
MEAN. VERY HOPEFUL THINGS ARE
WINDING DOWN BUT IT'S NOT GOING
AWAY IN FACT. EXPECT WE HAVE
OUTBREAKS OF CODED HERE AND
THERE ACROSS THE COUNTRY- NOT.
LIKE WHAT WE SAW LAST HOLIDAY
YOU KNOW LAST JANUARY BUT- WE
WERE IT'S NOT GOING AWAY. AND-
SO LET ME JUST TOUCH ON SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT I THINK WE KNOW
WE HAVE PROBLEMS WITH SO LET'S
JUST TALK ABOUT INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY- AND THEN AGAIN I
THINK THE ROLE PUBLIC HEALTH
ACTUALLY- I. SURE WE CAN
REIMAGINE IT BUT- I THINK OF A
PRETTY GOOD IDEA WHAT THE ROLE
PUBLIC HEALTH CENTER SOCIETY
AND IT'S BEEN AROUND FOR A
WHILE. AND THE QUESTION IS CAN
WE EXECUTE ON THAT- I'M NOT
SAYING THAT- WE CAN'T MAKE IT
BETTER WE CAN'T DO SOME RE
IMAGINING BUT- I THINK-
INVESTING IN WHAT WE KNOW
PUBLIC HEALTH IS NOW IS NOT
GOING TO BE WASTED. AND WE'RE
NOT GONNA TURN AROUND SAY WELL
THAT ACTUALLY PUBLIC HEALTH IS
NEED TO DO THAT ANYMORE.
CERTAINLY NOT CONTROL OF
CONTAGIOUS DISEASES NOT MANAGED
YOU KNOW SURVEILLANCE OF
CHRONIC DISEASES- LIMITING
STDS- YOU KNOW- OVERALL I MEAN
THERE'S JUST SO MANY THINGS
THAT- PUBLIC HEALTH WE KNOW
WHAT SUPPOSED TO DO. SO MAY
JUST GO BACK AND SO FOR
EXAMPLE- GOING ON- INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY- YEAH SO WE KNOW
THAT CAL READY- ESSENTIALLY
COLLAPSED MID YEAR- WE ALSO
KNOW WE HAVE TO VASTLY RAMP UP
OUR VACCINE- OR ITS MUSICIAN
REGISTRY WHICH BY THE WAY- I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S READY TO
PROVIDE VERIFICATIONS ARE NOT-
BECAUSE THAT'S GOING TO BE AN
ISSUE GOING FORWARD. AS WELL-
AND- SO CAN YOU SPEAK TO ME
ABOUT HOW ROBUST THOSE SYSTEMS
ARE AND ALSO HOW WELL ARE WE
ABLE TO INTERFACE BETWEEN NOT
ONLY OUR LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
AGENCIES WITH THE STATE AND
THEIR REGISTRIES BUT ALSO WITH
OTHER HEALTH SYSTEMS BECAUSE IS
SAID TO. WE ERTAINLY HAVE
STORIES ABOUT PEOPLE HAVING A
FAX INFORMATION OVER AND THEN
INFORMATION BEING MANUALLY
ENTERED INTO SYSTEMS AGAIN
TYING UP RESOURCES TIME WORK
FORCE AT CETERA- BUT IF THOSE
ISSUES GONE AWAY OR THEY'RE
STILL HERE BECAUSE THOSE ARE
CERTAINLY TO ME THINGS WHICH
IT'S OFF RIGHT NOW. CENTER PAN
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THOSE
QUESTIONS AND YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT THAT THOSE ISSUES HAVE
NOT GONE AWAY WE HAVE BEEN
FORTUNATE TO GET. EMERGENCY
FUNDING FROM THE STATE BUT ALSO
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR A LOT OF
THE FEDERAL FUNDING THAT'S
COMING DOWN IS BEING USED TO
ADDRESS THOSE. ISSUES AND SO WE
GOT TO COMPLETELY AGREE WITH
YOU AND WE'RE TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF ALL THIS ESPECIALLY THE
FEDERAL FUNDING IS COMING DOWN
SO THAT WE CAN WE CAN USE THAT
AND IN A VERY FOCUSED WAY. IT'S
A LONGER TERM ISSUES THAT ARE
GOING TO BE REALLY CRITICAL AND
IT IS GOING TO REQUIRE IT IS
GOING TO REQUIRE- MORE
ASSESSMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE INVESTMENTS WE MAKE ARGAN
ARGAN INC. ARGAN BENEFIT US
DOWN YOU KNOW FIVE TEN YEARS
FROM NOW BUT YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT OKAY SO AND AGAIN I
UNDERSTAND THIS FUNDS ARE
PRIMARILY. RESTRICTED TO KOVIN.
RELATED THEY ARE IN A THINK I
MEAN THE THAT WE SEE OF THE WAY
THAT WE THINK ABOUT IT IS THAT.
YOU KNOW WE WERE USING WERE
USING THE COLORS FUNDING TO
REALLY TO BUILD OUR CURRENT
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE RESPONSE.
YOU KNOW WE'RE BUILDING FOR
EXAMPLE THE CAL READY WYCHECK
CAL READY HANDLES NOT JUST
CULTIVATING HANDLES. READY FOR
ALL COMMUNICABLE DISEASES. THE
CARE REGISTRY HANDLES NOT JUST
A COVERT FAXING BACKS NATIONS
BUT IT HANDLES- VACCINATIONS
FOR ALL ALL ALL. ALL THE
EXHIBITIONS FOR THE STATE AND
SO IT IT'S SORT OF A- A CO
BENEFIT OR DUAL PURPOSE WERE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THIS
FUNDING. TO REALLY TO REALLY
IMPROVE OUR INFRASTRUCTURE BUT
WE RECOGNIZE YOU KNOW PART OF
IT WE RECOGNIZE IT COST A LOT
OF MONEY AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DO WE DO IT RIGHT.
WE DO IT IN SUCH A WAY THAT
REALLY LOOKS TO THE FUTURE
BECAUSE THE OTHER THING WE
REALLY NEED TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF. IS HOW WE WORK MORE CLOSELY
WITH THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS.
ONE OF THE BIG CHALLENGES WE'VE
HAD. IS ACTUALLY- YOU KNOW THE
WAY PUBLIC HEALTH WORKS IS THAT
WE GET WE GET DATA FROM THE
HELP WE GET DATA FROM A
LABORATORY AND- HOUSE IS
REPORTING TO US TO GO INTO OUR
CAL READY. BUT SORT OF THE
MODERN APPROACH REALLY TAKES
ADVANTAGE OF HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGES AND WORKING WITH
HEALTH SYSTEMS. AND BEING ABLE
TO GET REAL TIME DATA ACROSS
THE STATE NOT DEPENDING ON
PEOPLE TO REPORT TO US. SO WE
HAVE. TO REALLY THINK ABOUT.
THAT FUTURE SOLUTION THAT ARE
MUCH. EASILY AND APPARENTLY ASK
YOU SEE. HE KEEPS WITH ABOUT.
AS THE POTTERY HOW. AND CAN WE
JUST GO AND DO IT. I MEAN.
SORRY ARE YOU KNOW DO WE HAVE
TO KEEP THINKING ARE HAVE
PEOPLE DO WE HAVE MODELS OF HOW
PEOPLE HAVE DONE IT. AND SO WE
JUST GO AHEAD I MEAN I'M NOT
SAYING THAT WE'RE READY TO GIVE
SOMEONE A YOU KNOW A CONTRACT
SOMETHING TO DO IT RIGHT NOW.
BUT DO WE HAVE TO WAIT A WHOLE
YEAR. BEFORE WE START WORKING
ON THIS I MEAN EIGHT BLACK
PEOPLE BEEN THINKING ABOUT THIS
I MEAN I'VE BEEN READING ABOUT
THIS. A LONG TIME CREE COVE IT
SO. CAN WE JUST DO IT. YES I
ALSO THE WAY THAT I'M THINKING
ABOUT IT IS A WE- WE'VE WE'VE
JUST STARTED PLANNING WITH THE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS- FOR
THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS SO WE
HAVE WORK GROUPS INVOLVING.
HEALTH OFFICIALS FROM ACROSS
THE STATE FOR THE NEXT SEVERAL
MONTHS TO MAKE SURE THAT.
YOU'RE CORRECT IN THE NEXT
SEVERAL MONTHS BACK KOBE MAY
INCREASE BECAUSE WE'RE OPENING
UP THE ECONOMY RIGHT MAYBE MORE
TRANSMISSION. NOT EVERYONE IS
VACCINATED SO RIGHT NOW WE'RE
DOING PLANNING FOR THAT. ROLE
SO CONVENE A HIGH LEVEL GROUP.
TO START DOING THAT THE MORE
DETAILED LONGER TERM PLANNING.
AS A WE'RE GONNA BE USING THE
EXISTING MONEY THAT'S COMING IN
TO DO THAT. AND TO BE PLANNING
FOR THE NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET TO
HAVE MORE PERMANENT. FUNDING
HAS THE FEDERAL FUNDS AND
EMERGENCY FUNDS START GOING
AWAY. SO WE'RE TRYING TO REALLY
WE'RE WE'RE PLANNING TO MOVE TO
MAKKAH MASTERS OUT. OKAY I KNOW
YOU CAN'T DISAGREE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET YEAR AFTER
YEAR. DIRECTOR HAD BUT I I'M
GOING TO SAY THAT YOU I THINK
YOU CAN. I HAVE CONFIDENCE YOU
AND YOUR PARTNERS CAN WORK
FASTER THAN HAVING TO WAIT A
WHOLE YEAR FOR THE NEXT BUDGET-
D. HOW MUCH FEDERAL MONEY ARE
YOU GETTING FOR THE I. T. RIGHT
NOW. AT THAT'S NOT DETAILED
ANYWHERE SOME YOU SAID YOU'RE
GETTING FEDERAL MONEY BUT HOW-
HOW MUCH FEDERAL FUNDS ARE YOU.
DEVOTING TO THIS- INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY AND FOR THAT. ANSWER
AND FOR STRUCTURE. ITSELF BOTH
FEDERAL AND- EMERGENCY MONEY
FROM THE STATE OF BRITAIN
BRANDON NEWNESS. I THINK YOU
MAY BE ABLE TO SUMMARIZE THAT
FOR US. IN MINNESOTA HAND UP
THERE. YES I CAN YOU. HEAR ME
YES. OKAY THANKS FOR THE CALL
CENTER AND- YEAH. PRIMARILY A
LOT OF THE FUNDING THAT WE'VE
GOTTEN AND- ARE HAPPY AND
LAUGHED ABOUT CITY GRANTS HAS
BEEN GOING TO SOME OF THE
UPDATES TO THE- ALREADY SYSTEM
THE- NEW CODE REPORTING SYSTEM.
AND THEN THE FIRST GRANT THAT
WE RECEIVED FOR VACCINES THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN MILLION. A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
AMOUNT AND KEEP IN MIND. THAT
AMOUNT ROUGHLY HALF WENT OUT TO
THE LOCALS- SO WE KEPT ABOUT
HAPPENED AT THREE FIFTY SEVEN.
AND I THINK ABOUT A HUNDRED
MILLION OF THAT ROUGHLY WAS
GOING TO UPGRADE OUR
IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY SYSTEMS I
CAN PROVIDE. SOME MORE DETAIL
AS FAR AS WHERE WE SPECIFICALLY
BECAUSE- LOTS OF THE FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR- I. T. RELATED
SYSTEMS. BUT THOSE ARE THE TWO
BIG ONES THAT POPPED TO MIND AS
FAR AS THE FEDERAL FUNDING THAT
WE USE. OKAY AND FOR THE GREAT
SOME OF OUR SYSTEMS FOR THE
PUBLIC RECORD I WILL NOTE THAT
THIS IS NOW ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN-
UNDER THE SAME A PUBLIC HEALTH
AREA TALKING ABOUT. LABORATORY
CAPACITY AND THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN. OKAY YES MADAM
CHAIR AND WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE
TO I CAN GO BACK AND- TOUCH ON
A LITTLE BIT ON ISSUE NUMBER
SIX AND SEVEN AND I THIK WE'LL
BE DOING THAT IN TANDEM WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YOU JUST
WHEN YOU'RE READY FOR THAT.
OKAY SO OKAY I APPRECIATE THAT
I WOULD MAKE NOTE OF THAT-
POLICE I'VE- TALKED TO PEOPLE
LOCALLY. SAID THEY'VE HAD SOME
CHALLENGES- ENTERING THINGS AND
REGISTRY. SO AND I WOULD ALSO
MAKE NOTE LET'S HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS AND HE'S QUITE A LOT OF
MONEY BUT ON I. T. PROJECT-
THAT'S FAIRLY SMALL. HE'D SAY
THAT BUT IT IT DON'T WANT IT IS
WE'VE SEEN VARIOUS IT PROJECTS
FOR STATE THE SCALE OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S- THAT'S NOT A
LARGE AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR I. T.
SO. IT'S AND JUST TO TALK ABOUT
BECAUSE THIS IS ABOUT PUBLIC
HEALTH OVERALL WE CAN TALK MORE
THROUGH THE CODE SO WE TALK
ABOUT TO IT SYSTEMS CAL READY
AND THE IMPOSITION. REGISTRY
BUT FRONTLINE JUST AND JUST
TELL ME I GOT THIS- AND IS LIKE
FOR. DIFFERENT IN. SYSTEMS IN
SEAT. FOR VARIOUS SURVEY. AND
SO. CORRECT DID I GET THE
NUMBER CORRECT. THAT'S PROBABLY
AT LEAST FOURTEEN OKAY AT LEAST
FOURTEENTH OF JUST KEEP IN MIND
WE'RE FUNDING ONLY TO AND AGAIN
THOSE ARE THE MOST COVERT
RELATED RIGHT I MEAN NO YOU
HAVE A- ARE- CAL READY WHICH IS
ABOUT- MEDIATION BY THE WAY-
OUR DISCOUNT READY ABLE TO I
MEAN WE SAID IT COLLAPSE WE HAD
TO REBUILD IT. I CAN HANDLE IS
IT IS IT ACTUALLY CONTAINING
INFORMATION ON CONTACT FACING
OR NOT YEAH SO IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT CAO CAO READY-
IS THE IS A DATABASE FOR
REPORTABLE DISEASES- IN ONE OF
THE CHARGES CAL READY SET FOR
COVE IT IS RECEIVING BOTH
POSITIVE TEST IN NEGATIVE
TESTS. FOR COMMUNICABLE
DISEASES IS USUALLY JUST
POSITIVE TEST THAT WE HAVE CARE
WHICH IS ORGANIZATION REGISTRY
WE HAVEN'T CAL CONNECT WHICH IS
OUR SYSTEM FOR- CASE
INVESTIGATION AND CONTACT
TRACING. WE HAVE CAL BACKS
WHICH IS A SYSTEM FOR PROVIDE
VACCINE PROVIDERS TO REGISTER
REGISTER- IN ORDER VACS THE
WORKER VACCINES THAT'S ALL THAT
INVENTORY MANAGEMENT AND WE
HAVE MY TURN WHICH IS MY TERM
PUBLIC TO THE PUBLIC. IT'S A
WEB BASED INTERFACE THAT PEOPLE
GO GO AHEAD AND REGISTER FOR
APPOINTMENTS AND THEN MY TURN
CLINIC THAT ALLOWS CLINICS TO
ACTUALLY JUST RUN OUT THE WHOLE
CREDIT CAN DO APPOINTMENTS. AND
SO THOSE EARLY SO I JUST
MENTIONED FIVE DIFFERENT
SYSTEMS THAT ARE CURRENTLY-
DIRECTLY FOCUSING ON CO THEY DO
OVERLAP BECAUSE- MY CARING CAL
READY DEAL WITH OTHER
COMMUNITIES. SO BUT BUT- YOU
KNOW AS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE.
OVERALL PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. THOSE ARE THE
ONES AND WE HAVE A MANY. THAT
ALSO LIKE. AND FOR- THAT WOULD
BE A- SYSTEMS OUT THERE CANCER
REGISTRIES- YOU KNOW ABOUT US
REGISTRY OUT THERE ARE VARIOUS
REGISTRIES YELLS AT THE NEWBORN
SCREENING WE JUST TALKED ABOUT
YOU KNOW DATA ETCETERA AND-
EVEN LIKE CHRONIC DISEASE
SURVEILLANCE WAS GONNA BE VERY
IMPORTANT TO FIGURE OUT THINGS
LIKE ENVIRONMENTAL EXPOSURES
OTHER TYPES OF ISSUES AS WELL-
THAT- THAT FRANKLY I THINK- WE
HAVEN'T BEEN FUNDING VERY MUCH
CORRECT- I. WILL HAVE TO LOOK
AT THAT SPECIFICALLY BUT YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT YOU TAKE A
VITAL RECORDS CANCER REGISTRY
AND THEY DON'T THINK OF. THE
DATABASES ACROSS THE STATE
BECAUSE EACH JURISDICTION HAS
OUR OWN SYSTEM FOR COLLECTING
DATA. AND THEN THE INTO COULD
THE COMMUNICATIONS WITHOUT THE
LACK THE CLINICAL LABORATORY
LABORATORIES IN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH LABORATORY OKAY SO AND-
I KNOW WE CAN TALK ABOUT THIS
ALL DAY BUT I'M- OKAY LET'S
MOVE ON TO AND SO IT CLEARLY
NEEDS A LOT MORE WORK. I
APPRECIATE THAT THERE IS
FUNDING COMING DOWN BUT IT'S
VERY FOCUSED TOWARD COVERT
RELATED ONES AND THERE'S A LOT
OF OTHER ONES- STACK THE STAFF
AND WORKFORCE- I WOULD MAKE
NOTE OF THAT YEAH WE DO HAVE
THAT PROPOSAL FROM- FROM LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. LOOKING FOR
MORE LOCAL STAFF I KNOW- THAT-
ALSO- EXAMPLE I UNDERSTAND
THAT- WE HAVE A SHORTAGE OF
STAFF IN OUR LABS AND TIES A
LITTLE BIT TO OUR LAB CAPACITY
AND WE NEED A PIPE BUILD THE
PIPELINE FOR TRAINING PEOPLE.
MICROBIOLOGISTS- OF- SELF- ARE
THERE IT IS ARE THERE PROPOSALS
OUT THERE FOR I MEAN FOR
EXAMPLE SHOULD ARE UC'S OR
OTHER HIGHER EDUCATION
UNIVERSITIES BE. PARTNERING TO
TRY TO BUILD THAT PIPELINE WE
TALK ABOUT PIPELINE FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FIVE POINT
FOR OTHERS HERE IN. THIS
COMMITTEE- WHAT WHAT SHOULD BE
DONE TO STRENGTHEN THE PILOT
ARE YOU ABLE TO HIRE THE PEOPLE
YOU NEED. I MEAN I IT'S I MEAN
THERE'S NO CULVERHOUSE HARD
BECAUSE NOW YOU KNOW THAT'S A
CRISIS BUT- EVEN DURING REGULAR
TIMES UNDERSTAND THAT DOOR LABS
THAT CLOSE BECAUSE THEY CAN
HIRED PERSONNEL THEY NEEDED
THAT YOU CAN GET A LAB
DIRECTOR. YEAH THE- THE
LABORATORY THE LABORATORY A
LABORATORY HAS VERY SPECIAL
ISSUES RELATED TO HOW LABS RUN.
AND THE REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
HIGH LEVEL OF TRAINING FOR THE
FOR THE DIRECTORS. AND THEN THE
MICRO BY BIOLOGISTS OFTEN TIMES
THEY GET RECRUITED TO THE
PRIVATE SECTOR WHERE THEY CAN
EARN SOME EXTRA MONEY. AND SO
IT'S EASIER TO BRING THE MAN
IT'S HARDER TO GET STARTED. TO
KEEP THEM- IN TERMS OF HAPPY
CAPACITY I COMPLETELY AGREE
WITH YOU I'M I'M A TIME IT I'M
TRADING I WOULD HAVE DOCTOR
LEVEL HAVE BEEN EMAILED YOU
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK WE NEED
TO DO THEIR- NOT JUST IN TERMS
OF TRAINING BUT ALSO REALLY.
SHORING UP OUR REGIONAL
CAPACITY OUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE FROM A DISTANCE
BECAUSE SOME OF THIS CAN
ACTUALLY BE A PROVIDED FROM
JUST SOMETIMES ANY FIELD TEAMS
ANY PEOPLE IN THE FIELD. WHAT I
OFTENTIMES JUST NEEDING AND-
ANALYTIC POWER- THAT CAN BE
DONE THAT CAN BE DONE TO
DISTANCE. AND THEN THE LAST
AREA I WANT TO MENTION THAT'S
REALLY CRITICAL FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE. IS THAT WE
REALLY DO NEED TO RECRUIT RICK
RECRUIT IN OUR ACROSS OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEMS ACROSS
THE STATE FOR EXAMPLE COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS. WE NEED TO
RECRUIT PEOPLE FOR OUR FROM THE
COMMUNITY AND CREATE PATHWAYS
SO THAT LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR. ACTUALLY
HAVE A PATHWAY TO ENSURE THE
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE. PUBLIC
HEALTH WORK FORCE HAS A LARGE
WE ARE WE REALLY DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH PEOPLE OF COLOR IN THE
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE AT ALL
LEVELS SO WE NEED TO. FIGURE
OUT HOW TO IMPROVE THAT OKAY I
APPRECIATE THAT. I WOULD I
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT THAT- WELL
THIS IS WAIT- OUR SHORE OF
LAUGHTER PASSAGE- WAS. IN THERE
ARE OTHER I THINK CONCERN AS
START OF THE PANDEMIC INABILITY
TO KEEP UP I DO APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S LEADERSHIP AND
STANDING UP THE VALENCIA LAB
EVENTUALLY BUT THAT THAT WAS
THAT WAS A MAJOR ISSUE FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS- THE-
ALSO- OUR ABILITY TO CONTACT
RACING I THINK WAS CONSTRAINED
AGAIN BY LACK OF STAFF. AS
WELL- BUT BUT LET ME JUST AND
POSE THIS QUESTION BACK AGAIN
YOU YOU DO YOU RELATE TO ME ALL
THE ISSUES- THESE ARE ISSUES BY
THE WAY I WAS FAMILIAR WITH THE
FACT PRIOR TO COPE AND WE WERE
ENTERTAINING. A PROPOSAL- TO
ACTUALLY INCREASE TO FUND
ADDITIONAL EPIDEMIOLOGISTS-
WASN'T INCOME FROM C. PH COME
FROM FROM A STAKEHOLDER BUT SO
WE KNOW THIS IS A- SO- DO WE
NEED TO WAIT FOR A PLAN FOR
THIS I MEAN WE ACTUALLY HAD A
PROPOSAL PRE COVE IT TO GET
MORE EPIDEMIOLOGISTS AND OTHER
STAFF. IS ISN'T THERE WHAT WHY
ISN'T THERE A PROPOSAL IN FRONT
OF ME RIGHT NOW FROMTHIS
COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW FOR THE
STAFF WE KNOW WHAT. WE'RE DOING
WE DON'T NEED TO SPEND THREE
FIGHT WE NEED SPEND A WHOLE
YEAR TO FIGURE THIS OUT WE KNOW
WHAT IT IS. NO WILL IT WILL.
THE WHOLE YEAR IT'S REALLY
GONNA BE THE NEXT THE NEXT
SEVERAL MONTHS AND I AND I
THINK OKAY SO IT IS. THAT PART
OF THE BUDGET THEN AND WHERE.
IS IT WILL IT WILL HAVE BEEN
ABOUT THREE MONTHS WILL HAVE A-
WILL HAVE A PROPOSAL- WE'RE
WE'RE ACTUALLY LIKE I SAID WE-
JUST STARTED MEETING WITH.
STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS. THE STATE
BECAUSE A PLANNED FOR JUNE
FIFTEENTH SO WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING AT RELIGION OR PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE. OVER THE
NEXT SIX SIX MONTHS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
CONTAIN COVE IT. BECAUSE WE ARE
GOING AFTER JUST GEN FIFTEEN
FOR PLANNING TO OPEN THINGS UP.
AND WE'RE CONVENE A HIGHER
LEVEL GROUP TO BE LOOKING
BEYOND THAT. LOOKING BEYOND
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES BECAUSE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
REALLY HAVE. A WELL ROUNDED
PORTFOLIO THAT ADDRESSES
CHRONIC DISEASES CHRONIC.
STRESS BOB. CLIMATE CHANGE
EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS. THERE'S
REALLY JUST A VARIETY OF PUBLIC
HEALTH INSURANCE AND GET PUBLIC
UNPREPARED TO CALL AT ALL AS
FOR. THE WE HAVE TO TAKE ALL
HAZARDS APPROACH. WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE WE PRINCIPLES OF FROM
AN ECOLOGICAL PERSPECTIVE IN A
LIFE COURSE PERSPECTIVE PUTS
ALL THE THINGS THAT WE REALLY
WANT TO BILL DOT. INFUSION A
WAY TO MAKE COMMUNITIES RECALL
THAT IT IS GOING TO TAKE IS
GOOD IT'S GONNA TAKE A LITTLE
BIT OF TIME SO WE JUST DON'T.
SORT OF LOCK IN OUR- RESOURCES
JUST ON. DISEASES I'VE BEEN
AROUND PUBLICHEALTH LONG
ENOUGH. TO KNOW THAT THAT CAN
HAPPEN WHERE A LOT GOES INTO
ONE AREA. AND THEN ALL THE
SETTINGS ARE CHRONIC DISEASES
OUR COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
DOESN'T HAVE THE ATTENTION IT
NEEDS. AND THE THING IS WE
REALLY DO NEED TO GO MORE
UPSTREAM AND LOOK MORE CLOSELY
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
OKAY. AND AM PARTNERING WITH
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM THAT'S THE
OTHER AREA THAT WE- HAVE
EVERYTHING THAT THEY CAN THANK
YOU I'M JUST SORRY I'M TRYING
MOVED BECAUSE I WHAT. THE TAXES
ARE TIGHT HERE TO US SO IT'S A
TOTAL OF THREE MONTHS. PROPOSAL
IS THIS BOTH C. PH AND LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS JUST C. PH
SO JUST THE SCOPE. OF YOUR
THREE THREE MONTHS. WELL
CORRECTIVE. IT'S MORE
CONVENIENT WE'RE CONVENING THE
LOCAL HALL OKAY EVERY. WE'RE
GONNA WORK TOGETHER TO COME UP
FOR IF THE WHOLE SYSTEM OKAY
ALL RIGHT OKAY THREE MONTHS ALL
RIGHT AND- AND I REALIZE YOU
SEE DON'T BE LOCKED IN BUT IS
THERE A SENSE OF WHAT THE SCALE
OF THIS WOULD BE I MEAN ARE WE
TALKING I ASSUME IT'S MORE THAN
A MILLION AND MILLIONS IT PRY
TENS OF MILLIONS HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS. DID TO IS AT LEAST A
SENSE OF THE MAGNITUDE OF WHAT
THE THIS IZE OF THIS SO
WORKFORCE NEED IS IN TERMS OF
RESOURCES. SO YEAH EARLY IN
THIS IS PROBABLY NOT BILLIONS-
BUT CAN WE GET YEAH I YOU KNOW
I THINK YOU CAN GET AN IDEA
JUST FROM LOOKING AT JUST DOES
JUST FROM THE FEDERAL FUNDING
WHAT IT WHAT IT TAKES TO JUST
RESPOND TO COPE WITH OKAY SO
IT'S GOING TO BE IT'LL BE IT'LL
BE I THINK IT'LL BE. A SIX
MINUTE IT'LL BE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT I CAN'T TO I DON'T WANNA
OKAY OKAY WELL SO I WON'T BE
SURE WE HAVE THOSE RESOURCES
READY AND NOT WAITING UNTIL
NEXT JANUARY THE NEXT JULY OR
JANUARY WHATEVER OKAY- AND THEN
THE OTHER ISSUE ACTUALLY JUST
RELATED TO LAB YOU KNOW WE HAVE
TO DO MANTRA VERY AND OTHER
THINGS A LOT OF CODE RELEASE
STUFF OBVIOUSLY THERE'S OTHER
NON COVERED RELATED THINGS-
FOR- OTHER THINGS WE NEED ON
OUR LABORATORY FRONT- IN TERMS
OF- INFRASTRUCTURE RESOURCES.
WE APPRECIATE THE VALENCIA LAB-
BUT- OTHER YEAH F THE SENATE
VARIANTS SCREEN E. L. VARIANT
GENERIC VALUATION AND. OTHER
TYPES OF LAB CAPACITY ISSUES.
YES RIGHT NOW WE'RE- FOR FUNDS
FOR THAT WE INTEREST. THAT THE
FIRM THE FEDERAL INVESTMENT
THAT WILL INCREASE BECAUSE IT'S
REALLY AN INTERNATIONAL
PROBLEM. IT HAS TO BE REALLY
COORDINATED AT. THE NATIONAL
LEVEL. THE OTHER THING I WANT I
ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT IS THAT
WE'VE WE'VE HAD- REALLY GREAT
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE
UNIVERSITY'S. BOTH STAFFERS THE
UC'S- THIS THE STATE
UNIVERSITIES TO REALLY HELP US.
AND THEY'VE BEEN FANTASTIC
PARTNERS IN BOTH FROM AND FROM
PROVIDING ANALYTICAL
PERSPECTIVES. AND WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO STRENGTHENING OUR
RELATIONSHIPS. NOT JUST IN
TERMS OF RESEARCH A LOT OF
RESEARCH NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND. THE LONG
TERM IMPACTS OF KOBE BUT ALSO
HELPING US IN TERMS OF OUR
TRAINING PROGRAMS. OKAY SO AND
I WASN'T ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT
ASIDE FROM THE VALENCIA LAB AND
SEE ANY DETAILS ON LABORATORY
ON THE OTHER TO PRESS OTHER TWO
ISSUES WE HAVEN'T DISCUSSED
ABOUT YET SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN
ELABORATE. ON THAT SO I
APPRECIATE THE VALENCIA LAP BUT
SOME BUT- BEYOND OF THE LENS
ALLOWANCE EVEN THAT MUCH. AND
THEN FINALLY- A COMMUNICATIONS-
THIS IS REALLY VITAL ANYTHING
SOMETIMES WE OVERLOOK THIS AND
I THINK. WE THINK ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED COVE IT DOES A LOT OF
CONFUSION OF SOME OF THIS WAS I
THINK SOME CONFUSION BY CERTAIN
POLITICAL LEADERS- SOME. AND
PERHAPS A FORMER PRESIDENT
UNITED STATES AND HIS SOME OF
HIS FOLKS GOOD. SENDING OUT
THE- INCORRECT INFORMATION BUT-
BUT EVEN WHEN WE HAVE YOU KNOW
HE JUST TRYING TO NAVIGATE SO
EVEN NOW AS WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT GUIDELINES AND- GET.
THE PEOPLE ACTED INFORMATION-
WHAT KIND OF CAN WHAT KIND OF
RESOURCES ARE GOING TOWARD
PUBLIC COMMUNICATION OR TRY TO
CONVINCE PEOPLE TO GET
VACCINATED WERE. TRYING TO GET
PEOPLE ACCURATE INFORMATION
ABOUT MASK WEARING NOT MASK
WEARING SOCIAL DISTANCING IT
CETERA. WHAT RESOURCES ARE
BEING PUT- THE CDPH GETTING TO
DO COMMUNICATION- BY THE WAY WE
ALSO KNOW THAT- IT'S NOT JUST
BECAUSE OF IT YOU CUT STDS WE
CUT LOTS OF OTHER. YOU KNOW
OTHER ISSUES THAT WE NEED TO
COMMUNICATE ABOUT WHAT WHAT
SORT OF. COMMUNICATION
RESOURCES THAT IS- CDPH NEED
THAT- THAT THAT DOESN'T HAVE
RIGHT NOW. THERE IS A SO NOW
THAT WE DO HAVE LARGE AND- IN
TERMS OF A- MARKET MEDIA
CAMPAIGN- PROMOTE FACTS AND-
INCLUDING. BUT YET THEY HAD
INTERVIEWS OVER OVER TWELVE
HUNDRED TWELVE HUNDRED PERSONS-
BUT- IT DOESN'T LET ME FOCUS
SORRY AND IF YOU GET PROJECTS
FOR INTERRUPTING. MY FOCUS
PARTICULARLY ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE PART BECAUSE
THIS IS ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE SO I GET WHICH I
HAVE NO. MONEY THAT WE'RE
PUTTING OUT THERE PAYING FOR
SOCIAL MEDIA ADS PAYING FOR
ADVERTISING SO FAR. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BUILD OUT THE
MESSAGING SO YOU HAVE YOUR
EPIDEMIOLOGISTS YOU HAVE YOUR
YOU KNOW FILE TO. SAY OKAY
WE'VE DECIDED THIS IS AND HOW
DO WE TURN WHAT MAY BE A- AND
AGAIN I'M A PHYSICIAN WITH A
BACKGROUND PUBLIC HEALTH HOW
YOU TURN SOMETHING THAT COULD
SOMEBODY RATHER TECHNICAL. INTO
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
COMMUNICABLE TO THE PUBLIC WHAT
KIND OF INFRASTRUCTURE DO WE
HAVE TO DO THAT. NOW OBVIOUSLY
THAT'S NOT JUST BECAUSE OF IT
THERE'S OTHER. ISSUES RELATED
TO THAT AS WELL. YES SIR I.
YEAH WE DID I MEAN WE DO HAVE A
COMMUNITY OFFICE. HERE AT THE
AGENCY LEVEL AND THEN WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND WE ARE
GOING TO BE LOOKING AT WE ARE
GOING TO BE LOOKING AT THAT
BECAUSE THAT'S ANOTHER YOUR-
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY. THAT'S AND
THAT'S AN AREA THAT WE CAN.
DEFINITELY USE THEM AGAIN
IMPROVEMENT IN BEING ABLE TO
REACH THE THEIR FIRST
COMMUNITIES IN THE WAY. THAT
REALLY ARE RESONATES WITH THEM.
AND IT TAKES IT TAKES A LOT OF
EFFORT AND WORK THAT'S ALL PART
TO ME THIS IS ALL PART OF THE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT PROCESS.
BECAUSE YOU REALLY HAVE TO HAVE
TRUSTED MESSENGERS FROM THE
COMMUNITY TO REALLY BE
EFFECTIVE. IT'S NOT JUST ENOUGH
TO SPEND A LOT OF MONEY ON ADS
OFTENTIMES THINGS HAPPEN GET
HIGH HYPER LOCAL. YOU REALLY
HAVE TO WORK WITH CHURCHES
COMMUNITY CBO'S- IS NOT
SUFFICIENT JUST TO JUST TO BE
WORKING WITH THE MEDIA
CAMPAIGNS. THAT'S PROBABLY PART
OF THE ASSESSMENT THAT WE'RE
GONNABE OKAY SO IS THAT
SOMETHING IS GONNA TAKE YOU A
WHOLE YEAR TO FIGURE OUT TO US
WE'RE STILL DEALING WITH COVE
IT AND OTHER THINGS ARE THAT
SOMETHING CAN BE DONE MORE
QUICKLY. WELL THE PLAN IS GOING
TO HAPPEN WITHIN THE NEXT THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS ALSO ALL THIS
ALL COME TOGETHER. BY SEPTEMBER
WE PLAN TO HAVE THIS- OUR
PROPOSAL TO TOGETHER. OKAY SAN
LIKE A FEW. HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET
A LOT MORE. AGAIN I DON'T WANT
TO SIT THERE AND SAY THAT YOU
HAVE A PROPOSAL AND NOW WE'RE
SITTING ON THIS. AND THEN WE'RE
FINALLY GOING TO DECIDE ON
FUNDING YET WHICH WON'T START
TILL JULY FIRST. I THINK THAT'S
I THINK ONE OF THE MAJOR POINTS
I'M TRYING TO MAKE AND SAID. A
LOT OF THESE ISSUES IS TALKED
ABOUT ARE NOT UNFAMILIAR ISSUES
I MEAN THESE ARE THINGS. THAT
WILL BE- SHE WILL ACT ON MORE
QUICKLY IS NOT SOMETHING WE
NEED TO SIT DOWN THINK FROM
GROUND ZERO WE'VE BEEN THINKING
ABOUT THESE THINGS FOR A LONG
TIME. MAYBE I'LL JUST ASK ONE
QUESTION OF L. A. L. THEN-
GIVEN OUR CONVERSATION HERE-
YOU KNOW I REALIZE YOU. YOU CAN
YOUR REPORT- THE STATIC YOU
TALKING ONLY ABOUT ACTION AFTER
ACTION REPORT WHICH I AGREE
WITH ALTHOUGH I THINK THE
ACTION STILL HAPPENING SO IT'S
PERHAPS A BIT ACTION REPORT-
AND THEN YOU TALKED ABOUT A
MULTI YEAR SUSSMAN. BUT TO ME
I'M AFRAID A MULTI YEAR SUSSMAN
JUST MEANS WE PUT THINGS OFF-
WHAT. WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
DEPARTMENT DIRECTOR THAT
PERHAPS IN THE NEXT SEVERAL
MONTHS- BY SEPTEMBER. RELEASE
WE'RE GONNA HAVE SINCE YOU KNOW
SEVERAL. HOPEFULLY PROPOSALS
FOR. INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
THEY'VE ALREADY THOUGHT OUT. I
KNOW THAT WORK HAS BEEN DONE
EVEN PRIOR TO COVE IT PERHAPS
EVEN POSITED BECAUSE OF BECAUSE
OF IT- WHAT WOULD YOU SUGGEST.
IN TERMS OF US MOVING FORWARD.
IN TERMS OF- TRYING TO BE SURE
THAT WE DON'T WAIT A WHOLE
YEAR. TO START ACTING OUT
THINGS THAT WE ACTUALLY NEED
NOW BECAUSE WE HAVE AN ACTIVE
PANDEMIC STILL GOING ON. AS
WELL AS A POTENTIAL OTHER.
PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS THAT WE
FACE. PERHAPS- WE'VE PAID LESS
THE- TO BECAUSE OF COVER BUT
THERE STILL ON. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION DOCTOR HAN AND I
THINK- JUST BEFORE I ANSWER
THAT I THINK THERE MIGHT BE. IF
I'M NOT MISTAKEN THERE MIGHT BE
A BIT OF CONFUSION ABOUT THE-
PROPOSAL THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS
DEVELOPING BY SEPTEMBER AND
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING BASED ON
READING THE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL- THAT. THAT SEPTEMBER
PROPOSAL WILL BE PRESENTED AS
PART OF GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN
JANUARY SO THE FUNDING WHEN
ACTUALLY START TO FLOW INTO A
JACK- JULY FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY
TWO- YOU KNOW I MIGHT BE
MISTAKEN BUT- YOU MIGHT WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT- IN REGARDS TO
YOUR QUESTION FOR US
SPECIFICALLY- WE SUGGESTED THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDERED
TEMPORARY FUNDING THIS YEAR. AT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
FOR BOTH THE DEPARTMENT AND
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS. TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE VERY ISSUES
THAT YOU'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
WHILE AT PERHAPS A MORE LENGTHY
STUDY CAN TAKE PLACE TO
DETERMINE WHAT THE IT'S SORT OF
HARD TO KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
IS FOR THINGS LIKE STAFFING AND
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO OUR SUGGESTION WAS SOME SOME
AMOUNT OF TEMPORARY FUNDING
RIGHT AWAY. COUPLED WITH THE
LONGER TERM- ASSESSMENT TO SEE
WHAT THE LONG TERM ONGOING
INVESTMENT SHOULD BE. OKAY AND
THEN ONE OF COME IN A MOVIE
BECAUSE I'D DIE I THINK BUT
MISTAKES IT IS WHAT I SAID. IN
THE BEGINNING- SO. AND I WOULD
JUST SAY EIGHT THIRTY ARE GONE
I THINK YOU HEAR FRUSTRATION
BECAUSE I WE'VE ALL LIVED
THROUGH THIS- PANDEMIC AND
PEOPLE LIKE MAKE ME MOVE
REPRESENTED AN AREA WITH A LOT
OF AGRICULTURE WHEN I THINK
BACK TO JUST BEGINNING AND
TRYING TO GET PEOPLE TESTED AND
BIG OUTBREAKS AND FARMS AND I
MEAN IT WAS A NIGHTMARE IT WAS
A NIGHTMARE PARTLY BECAUSE- OF%
THE STATE THE STATE WAS PART OF
THE NIGHTMARE THAT WE COULDN'T
GET. FLOWS OF DATA THERE WAS
CONFUSION AROUND TESTING WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE SO I THINK PART OF
WHAT YOU'RE HEARING TODAY IS
THE FRUSTRATION OF WHAT WE'VE
BEEN THROUGH AND THEN THE
FEELING PERHAPS OF THE LACK OF
URGENCY TO ATTACK IT RIGHT NOW
HOME WE ALL UNDERSTAND THAT
EVERYTHING HAS BEEN- FEELING
LIKE IT'S ON THE BOTTOM OF A
WATERFALL AND SOMETIMES IT'S
HARD TO GET A BREATH- BUT WHY
DON'T WE HAVE MAYBE MISSED IN
UNIONS GO BACK MORE QUICKLY
COVER. ISSUE NUMBER SIX AND
SEVEN SO WE CAN JUST MAKE SURE
FOR THE RECORD THAT WE HAVE
COVERED THOSE TWO AGENDA ITEMS-
AND I THINK I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
HEARING DOCTOR ARE GOING TO SET
THAT UP WELL WE UNDERSTAND THE
STATE MUST OCCUR- THERE IS A
LOT OF FRUSTRATION THAT THERE
HAS NOT BEEN MORE INVESTMENT IN
THIS BUDGET ITEM BECAUSE WHILE
YOU TALK ABOUT JUNE FIFTEENTH
AS THE OPENING DATE JUNE
FIFTEENTH IS ALSO THE BUDGET WE
HAVE TO VOTER- WHICH WILL THEN
PROVIDE THE FUNDING FOR THE
NEXT TWO YEARS. THANK YOU CAN I
JUST THE ONE THAT FIVE EIGHT SO
IT WOULD ASK THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION I REALIZE THAT
YOU MAY DISAGREE IN YOUR
PROPOSAL HERE BUT THAT MR
PROVIDED TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
NECESSARY TO BOTH OUR COMMITTEE
IN THE L. A. SO WE CAN CRAFT AN
APPROPRIATE- SOME OF FUNDS-
THAT'S APPROPRIATE TO TRY AT
LEAST JUST ADDRESS EIGHT SOME
PROJECTIONS- THAT- THAT WILL
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH ASSESSMENT. THAT WILL
HAPPEN NEXT MONTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FOR SO DOCTOR
GULLIBLE WILL WILL THAT BE
PREPARED TO COLLAB. WITH US-
WE'RE ALL MEANS. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE TAKE CARE OF THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. MISTER NEWNESS
ISSUE NUMBER SIX AND SEVEN
BRIEFLY- THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
SO BRIEFLY B. TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS-
IDENTIFIED IN ISSUE NUMBER SIX.
IS REALLY AN UPDATE TO- CODE
RELATED EXPENDITURES THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ROUGHLY EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR COVERED
RELATED EXPENDITURES SO THIS
REFLECTS AN UPDATE TO MAYOR
VISION AND IT'S PRIMARILY-
BEING PROVIDED TO- FOR
RESOURCES RELATED TO OUR
TESTING EFFORTS WITH PALENCIA
LABS FALLS COLLECTION EFFORTS
THERE- OUR VACCINE DISTRIBUTION
EFFORTS. SEARCHES ARE ON MOBILE
VACCINATION SERVICES ARE MEDIA
CAMPAIGN AS WELL AS- SUPPLIES
AN ADMINISTRATION RELATED
ACCIDENTS- THERE SOME COSTS
RELATED TO POTENTIAL SEARCH
COSTS FOR CONTACT TRACING. AND
OTHER ITEMS- THERE THERE'S ALSO
SIX MILLION- IN THE BUDGET- AS
A PLACEHOLDER FOR LEGAL
CHALLENGES THAT MAY OCCUR- FOR
EXTERNAL CHALLENGES THERE- THAT
IS BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE THAT-
DISPOSE COSTS ARE INCURRED
REQUEST IS MADE TO DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND- NOTIFICATIONS
AND MAKE. LEGISLATURE SO VERY
BRIEFLY THAT'S AN OVERVIEW OF
ISSUE NUMBER SIX- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MAY HAVE MORE TO ADD ON
THAT AS WELL- WITH ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN. AS YOU'RE AWARE WE
FEDERAL GRANTS- THE MOST RECENT
FEDERAL GRANTS FROM THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN. SO WE
HAVE VARIOUS BUDGET BILL.
LANGUAGE ITEMS IN THERE TO
PROVIDE FORGET YOUR
ADJUSTMENTS- RELATED TO SOME
BRAND SO WE ALREADY KNOW THAT
WE RECEIVED. FROM OUR SB A LAB
CAPACITY GRANTS AS WELL AS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION AND ACTIVITIES-
AND THEN THERE'S SOME GENERAL
LANGUAGE IN OUR STATE
OPERATIONS AND LOCAL ASSISTANCE
ITEMS FOR. ANY OTHER
ADDITIONAL- FEDERAL FUNDING
ITEMS THAT ARE RECEIVED OUT OF
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT.
THE VERY HIGH LEVEL- THOSE ARE
ISSUES SIX AND SEVEN. THANK YOU
MISTER. A DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
THE GENERAL DEPARTMENT FINANCE
I THINK CASH- WILL BRING CAMPUS
WELL BUT BOB BROWN SPEAKING-
SIX OUTLINES. INCREASES S.
COSTS FOR THE TESTING BACKSLASH
OTHER AND IT SPONSOR FOR ONE
HUNDRED GO INTO THAT AND THEN
FOR THE DETAILS BIKE. HAND
ISSUE SEVEN CALLS OUT
SPECIFICALLY VARIOUS FEDERAL
GRANTS BUT THE- STUDENTS
RECEIVED THAT WE WILL BE- TWICE
PLAN SPORTSMEN TO A LEGISLATURE
FOR REVIEW BEFORE EXPENDITURE.
SORT OF A VERY SIMILAR PROCESS
TO WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING THE
PAST FISCAL YEAR. MAINTAINING
THAT PARTNERSHIP AND-
TRANSPARENCY WITH WHICH THE
BRANCH. HELLO RESTORE ARE QUICK
MADAM CHAIR- SEND YOU PICK FROM
THE ILIO THE PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE DETAILED IN ITEM- IN
ISSUE SEVEN ADDRESSES SOME OF
THE SPECIFIC GRANTS PROVIDED
THROUGH- THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN THERE- IT THERE'S ONE THE
LAST ONE THAT'S NOTED- IS.
RIGHT IS THAT ALSO CONCERNS
FUNDING FROM THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN BUT IT'S FOR THE
AMOUNTS THAT HAVE NOT YET BEEN
DETERMINED AND FOR PURPOSES NOT
YET DETERMINED ON THIS SPECIFIC
REQUEST- THE PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE WOULD ONLY PROVIDE A
TEN DAY NOTIFICATION TO THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. WHERE IS THE OTHER
PIECES OF FUNDING- ABOUT WHICH
WE ALREADY KNOW MORE WOULD
PROVIDE THIRTY DAYS
NOTIFICATION TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
WE'D SUGGEST IT BE BETTER TO
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE A BIT
MORE TIME ON THAT PIECE ABOUT
WHICH LESSENS KNOWN THANK YOU.
KERN WHO ASKED NOT TO TAKE NOTE
OF THAT. THANK YOU. PROTECT PAN
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE THE
L. A. AS A KIND AND I THINK THE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT IS
CERTAINLY VERY IMPORTANT AND- I.
AND I AND ALWAYS HAD PREVIOUS
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT IT AND SO.
SHE PROBABLY- SUGGESTIONS
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE
APPROPRIATE AS LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT OVER IS PARTICULARLY-
FUTURE SPENDING THAT IS NOT.
SPECIFIED OR- DESCRIBED AND- SO
WHETHER SUFFICIENT TIME OR
OTHER TYPES OF PROCESSES THAT
WE SHOULD BE GOING THROUGH TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS SUFFICIENT
MUCH THEY'VE OVERSIGHT AND
SAID- AND HOW THAT MATCHES UP
WITH OUR DECISIONS WE HAVE TO
MAKE IN TERMS OF STATE FUNDS AS
WELL SO WE- UNDERSTAND THE
BALANCE BETWEEN FEDERAL STATE
FUNDING AND THE TOTAL FUNDING
THAT'S GOING TO. SUPPORT
VARIOUS ACTIVITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY.
THERE'S NOTHING FURTHER ON THIS
WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
NINE CHILDREN YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND DR PAN I'LL BE
SPEAKING ON ISSUE NUMBER NINE.
ASSEFA CLEAN REGARDING THIS
LARGE MULTI DEPARTMENT
INITIATIVE ON THEIR OWN MY
COMMENTS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH PORTION WHICH IS
A PUBLIC EDUCATION AND
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN. MY NAME IS
ROSE ANOTHER CHRISTIAN AND I
SERVE AS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY. ASIAN OF OUR OFICE OF
HEALTH EQUITY IS THAT EVERYONE
IN CALIFORNIA HAS EQUAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OPTIMAL
HEALTH. MENTAL HEALTH AND
WELLBEING. TO HELP FOR FULLER
VISION WE'RE GRATEFUL TO JOIN
THIS CROSS DEPARTMENT
PARTNERSHIP. CHANGE THE ARC OF
LIVES OF CALIFORNIA'S NEXT
GENERATION OF LEADERS A
GENERATION THAT HAS SUFFERED A
TREMENDOUS TRAUMA. WITH THIS
PANDEMIC UPROOTING THEIR YOUTH
THEIR EDUCATION. AND THEIR
FAMILIES DURING CRITICAL YEARS
OF THEIR DEVELOPMENT. DOING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THROUGH THE
HEALTH EQUITY PARTICULARLY A
RACIAL EQUITY LANDS WE KNOW
THAT STRUCTURAL RACISM AND
ACCUMULATED SOCIAL DISADVANTAGE
MEANS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES ARE BORN
INEQUITABLE. BY LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND LGBTQ
PLUS COMMUNITIES PLACES WHERE
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
OF MORE WIDESPREAD. EARLIER WE
CAN INTERVENE IN THE LIFE
COURSE BUT LESS SUFFERING AND
THE LESS COST. SO LAST DECADE
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN A RAND
STUDIED THE IMPACT OF THAT
SIMILAR EARLIER STATEWIDE
EFFORTS TO IMPROVE STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH AWARENESS AND
DEMONSTRATED THE PROMISE FOR
SIGNIFICANT COST SAVINGS BY
PREVENTING THE NEGATIVE
OUTCOMES ASSOCIATED WITH NOT
RECEIVING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CARE UNTIL A CRISIS OCCURS.
SAVING SUCH AS SCHOOL DROPOUT
HOSPITALIZATION INCARCERATION
HOMELESSNESS AND SUICIDE AND
THEY RECOMMENDED A LONGER TERM
COMMITMENT TO A COORDINATED P.
E. I. STRATEGIES PREVENTIONAND
EARLY INTERVENTION SOMETHING
THAT PUBLIC HEALTH SPECIALIZES
IN. TO ADDRESS THEIR
RECOMMENDATION THE NEW
CHALLENGES POSED BY THE
PANDEMIC ON OUR YOUTH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REQUESTS CAN POSITIONS
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FROM THE
CORONAVIRUS FISCAL RECOVERY
FIND. A FIVE MILLION INITIALLY
AND THEN GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE IN FIFTEEN FORTY
MILLION OVER THE SUBSEQUENT FOR
YEARS. IF APPROVED THIS WOULD
ALLOW US TO IMPLEMENT A PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND CHANGE CAMPAIGN
THAT WOULD BE STRATEGIC AND
EVIDENCE INFORMED THROUGH THE
LENS OF PUBLIC HEALTH. THE GOAL
SHOULD BE RAISE HEALTH LITERACY
ALL CALIFORNIANS ALL AGES MANY
LANGUAGES NORMALIZING HOW TO
RECOGNIZE THE EARLY SIGNS AND
SYMPTOMS OF DISTRESS AND WHERE
TO GO FOR HELP. AND TACKLING
INEQUITIES BY EMPOWERING
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES SO WE WILL
WORK CLOSELY IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY AND MANY DEPARTMENTS ON
THIS INITIATIVE PARTICULARLY
THE OFFICE OF THE SURGEON
GENERAL ON A TOXIC STRESS
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN. AND THE NEW
OFFICE OF SUICIDE PREVENTION
HOUSE WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
OUR OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY HAS
A SMALL BUT IMPORTANT
COMPONENT. THREE COMPONENTS ARE
THE GENERAL ACCEPTANCE AND
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN WITH A
STRONG PUBLIC RELATIONS AND
MARKETING COMPONENTS SOCIAL
MEDIA EDUCATION CHANNELS.
SECOND A CULTURAL AND
LINGUISTIC SPECIFIC CAMPAIGN
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
COMMUNITY LEADERS BUILDING ON
EXISTING AND PROMISING LOCAL
EFFORTS AND THIRD SOMETHING
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO THE
SECRETARY AND GOVERNOR. YOUTH
AND POWER MAKE PEACE AGENCY
WILL HAVE A YOUTH ADVISORY
BOARD THAT WILL PARTNER WITH TO
CREATE POSITIVE CONTENT THAT'S
DESIGNED BY YOUTH. FOR YOUTH
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH A PART IN
THE FINAL ANYTHING. DREXEL.
HELLO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
SENATE HEADACHE L. A. OKAY WE
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT- WITHOUT
YOU KNOW WITHOUT PREJUDICE TO
THE MERITS OF THIS PROPOSAL WE
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF IFORMATION
ABOUT THE BASIS FOR THE
ESTIMATE OF FIFTY MILLION OVER
THAT OVER THESE NUMBER OF YEARS
IS QUITE A HIGH FIGURE AND WE
JUST- WE HAVEN'T SEEN A LOT OF
INFORMATION FROM THE DEPARTMENT
ABOUT- HOW THOSE ESTIMATES WERE
DERIVED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WOULD JUST I WOULD
WONDER IF THERE'S SOME MORE
INFORMATION ON THAT AS WELL
BECAUSE I'M WONDERING ABOUT HOW
THE MEASURING THIS WATER ARE
OUTCOMES WOULD HAVE WE- WERE
TRYING TO. IMPROVE PEOPLE'S
BEHAVIOR HEALTH IQ- AND HOW HOW
WILL WE KNOW. WHEN WE DO THAT
AND I GUESS I ALWAYS AND JUST
WONDER FOR. MAKING SURE PEOPLE
KNOW MORE ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH
THAT IT'S ABLE THEN TO BE TIED
TO RESOURCES SO PEOPLE CAN
ACTUALLY ACCESS MENTAL HEALTH.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY
ANY MORE. INFORMATION ABOUT
THIS- THIS PROPOSAL AT THIS
TIME OR- IS THIS SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GET MORE
INFORMATION ON. ID FREQUENTLY
OR SOON. AT A AND THEN I ALSO
JUST WONDER. I'M NOT I'M NOT
SURE WAS JUST A PART OF THE
OTHER THAT WE HAD THE AT
REDUCING DISPARITIES THAT WE
FUNDED IT WAS A GREAT PROGRAM
AND ANNOUNCED THAT THE
DEPARTMENT AND- DIDN'T SEEK TO
FUND AGAIN THIS YEAR- THEN WHY
DID YOU WANT TO RESPOND. HAPPY
TO MADAM CHAIR SO- IN THE FIRST
YEAR A LOT OF THE RESOURCES AND
STAFFING WOULD BE FOCUSED ON
DOING A LANDSCAPE ANALYSIS BOTH
NATIONALLY OF BEST PRACTICES AS
WELL AS- WORKING WITH PARTNERS
ON VARIOUS CAMPAIGNS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THAT'S THE CORE TEN
POSITIONS WE CERTAINLY WILL BE
BUILDING ON WHAT WE'VE LEARNED
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT WHICH- WE
VIEW HAS BEEN. VERY SUCCESSFUL
BUT IS STILL UNDERGOING ITS
EVALUATION SO THAT REALLY
CHAMPIONS CULTURAL LINGUISTIC
COMPETENCE AND ELEVATES THESE
COMMUNITY TO FIND EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES SO WHILE WILL
LEARN FROM AND USE SOME OF
THOSE APPROACHES AND TECHNIQUES
THIS WILL BE A VERY DISTINCT
AND SEPARATE CAMPAIGN FOCUSED
PARTICULARLY ON. YOUTH IT JUST
SEEMS LIKE WE'RE HAVE SOMETHING
THAT WAS WORKING UP THE WOODEN
JUST SHIPPED ON A REAL REALLY
QUICK. BUT PLANNING THING
HONEST. NO I AGREE WITH YOU
OKAY ALL RIGHT THAT DOESN'T
QUITE MAKE SENSE THAT WE'RE-
MOVING TO SOMETHING NEW THAT
I'LL GO GET WE ALL AGREE IN
THEORY IT'S A GOOD IDEA. BUT WE
DON'T HAVE MUCH DETAIL ABOUT IT
AND WE KNOW THAT THERE WAS SOME
WORK ALREADY BEING UNDERTAKEN.
OKAY SHALL WE MOVE ON THEN TO
ISSUE NUMBER TEN SUPPORT FOR
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE RESEARCH
AWARENESS AND TRAINING. AND PER
NIGHT JUST MEANT. GOOD MORNING
FOR THE RECORD MONICA MORALES
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND- TO THIS SPECIFIC
ITEM OR AN AL SIMMERS AND IT IS
AN INCREASE OF SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
AND WE WILL BE DIVIDING IT UP.
FIVE FIVE SUPPORTING OUR
STANDARDS OF CARE FOR DEMENTIA
AND ALL OF THAT A LITTLE BIT-
INTO WHAT WE NEED BYTHESE TWO
COMPONENTS OF WHAT WE REALLY
SEE IS TRYING TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT MORE
AND MAKE IMPROVEMENTS ON THE
WAY THAT WORKS DETECTING AND
DIAGNOSING DEMENTIA AND
ALZHEIMER'S IN OUR HEALTH
SYSTEMS SO OUR GOAL REALLY IS
TO TRY TO USE PREDICTIVE
ANALYTICS TO ESTABLISH YOU KNOW
POTENTIAL ALGORITHM. OR HEALTH
SYSTEMS WHERE THEY CAN ACTUALLY
USE IT FOR THE PATIENTS WE HAVE
THIS SIMILAR APPROACH FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN IT COMES TO
DIABETES OR SOMETIMES YOU GO
INTO CARE AND YOU KNOW YOUR
PROVIDER ACTUALLY CAN SCREEN
YOU BASED ON YOUR BMI SCREENING
BASED ON YOUR HISTORY- AND LET
YOU KNOW YOUR RISK CRITERIA
BASED ON DIABETES AT THE
SIMILAR APPROACH THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO USE IT COMES REALLY
ADVANCING FAN. CARE FOR-
ALZHEIMER'S IN CALIFORNIA OUR
GOAL IS REALLY TO THINK ABOUT
WAYS THAT WE CAN SCREEN FOR
HUNDRED IMPAIRMENTS PROMOTE
INVALIDATE TOOLS FOR YOU KNOW
COGNITIVE ASSESSMENT AND
EVALUATION AND REALLY FOCUS ON
BANK AND EDUCATION OF WOMEN OF
COLOR AFRICAN AMERICANS AND
LATINOS WHO WE KNOW ARE MOST
IMPACTED FOR OUTSIDERS. I'M IN
TERMS OF OUR- EDUCATION
CAMPAIGN ISN'T REALLY TRYING TO
DO MORE WHEN IT COMES TO
EDUCATING CALIFORNIANS ON OUR
FRAMERS OUR GOAL IS READY TO
ROLLOUT EDUCATIONAL CAMPAIGN
BACKED UP FRONT AND SYMPTOMS OF
ALZHEIMER'S BUT ALSO PROVIDES
AND YOU KNOW A. LINCOLN SOME
PEOPLE TO AXES LINGUISTICALLY
AND CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE
MATERIAL AROUND DEMENTIA WE
HAVE A LOT OF EDUCATION YOU'RE
NOT COMMUNITIES. ESPECIALLY
COMMUNITIES AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER SUCH AS LGBT AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN OF COLOR AND
EVEN YOUNG INDIVIDUALS TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND. THE IMPACT
OF DEMENTIA WHAT IT IS- NOW
SIGNED. SO I'LL THERE. ABOUT
GOOD MORNING AT JACKSON FINANCE-
ON PAGE THIRTY- THE- ALMOST THE
ENTIRE PAGE REFLECTS VARIOUS
CHANGES IN THE EXPENDITURE OF
THE AUTHORITY BONDS ARE THE
MAIN DRIVER OF THIS IS- THE
COMPLETION FASTER
RECONCILIATION PROCESS GIVING
IS A CLEAR PICTURE OF THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE AND FUNDS
IN THE AT THE LITTLE THAT WE
MAY USE APPROPRIATELY TO.
MAINTAIN THE INTEGRITY OF THE
FUND- AT THE END OF THE PAGE
HOWEVER YOU'LL SEE A- EMERGENCY
ADAM REIMBURSEMENTS- THIS IS
ADDING LANGUAGE THAT WILL ALLOW
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS TO TAKE AND-
FEDERAL GRANTS FROM FEMA- WITH
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF VARIOUS
AND PROCESSES IT IT BECAME
NECESSARY TO CREATE A NEW. WAY
TO TAKE IN THESE DOLLARS AND
MARCOS THE LEGISLATURE WILL BE
NOTIFIED. WHEN AND S.
ADDITIONAL. DOLLARS IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE A WILDFIRE
RELATED FEMA REIMBURSEMENTS
ARE- AVAILABLE. ON PAGE THIRTY
ONE. YOU. WILL FIND- TECHNICAL
FOR A IS. OR RESPONSE NAVIGATOR-
THERE A ADDITIONAL STATE
OPERATIONS FUNDING- THAT- THE
PROGRAM IDENTIFIED. COULD BE
SHIFTED TO BOLSTER PROGRAM
ACTIVITIES IN THE LOCAL SYSTEM
SIDE SETTLE DOING THERE- AND-
FINALLY. WE HAVE CONTRACTED
EXEMPTION FOR AT LEAST IN
BISEXUAL TRANSGENDER WOMEN'S
HEALTH. IN NINETEEN BUDGET
PROPOSAL ORDER C. TO WAVES OF A
CONTRACT CODE SO THAT SAYS
SMALLER ORGANIZATIONS THAT
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE THE
SOPHISTICATION. A TO NAVIGATE
THE STATE'S CONTACTING PROCESS
ARE ABLE TO GET FUNDING AND
SERVE THESE THESE COMMUNITIES
SO. THAT'S JUST A QUICK RUNDOWN
OF SPOTS IN TECHNICAL MATTERS
WERE ADDRESSING AT THE MAY
REVISION AND I'M MORE THAN
HAPPY TO ANSWERING QUESTIONS-
SENATORS YEAH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AS EARLIER DO YOU HAVE
ANYTHING ON THIS. DOCTRINE.
YEAH THE ONLY QUESTION I HAVE
IS FOR L. A- IN TERMS OF THE
OVERSIGHT FUNCTION- IN THE RED
SEA LANGUAGE BUT IN THE END OF
THE DAY OPINION ABOUT THAT. I
THINK IT AFTER BEYOND YES WEEK
WE NOTICED- THAT THIS
NOTIFICATION. THIS NOTIFICATION
TO THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WOULD ALSO BE WITHIN
TEN DAYS- THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT
WANT TO CONSIDER MAKING THAT A
REGULAR THIRTY DAY NOTIFICATION
WE WOULD ASSUME FOR THESE-
TYPES OF REIMBURSEMENTS THAT
ARE. YOU KNOW TERE WOULD
ALREADY HAVE BEEN SOME
DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT THE STATE
SPENDING THAT'S GETTING
REIMBURSED BY FEMA- BUT YEAH
TYPICALLY WE WOULD- OUR OFFICE
WOULD RECOMMEND A THIRTY DAY
NOTIFICATION PERIOD. OKAY THANK
YOU AND I'M SURE THE JAIL BC IF
THAT- IS FAIRLY NARROWLY
CONSTRAINED FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND OTHER FACTORS
AND RECOGNIZING THE URGENCY OF
ANY- ANYTHING IT'S FUNDING CUTS
ONLY ACT MORE RAPIDLY THIRTY
DAYS WOULD NOT NECESSARILY MEAN
THAT THE LEGISLATURE NET
NATIONALLY HAVE TAKE THIRTY
DAYS TO ACT BUT- IF THERE ARE
SOME QUESTIONS OR- ISSUES THAT
WOULD GIVE TIME FOR. ADEQUATE
CONSIDERATION AS WELL SO-
HOPEFULLY IN THIS PARTNERSHIP
WILL BE HAVE A OLD LOW ENOUGH
OF A LEVEL OF TRUST THAT- THAT-
THAT THE MINISTERS YOU CAN
COUNT ON THE LEGISLATURE TO ACT
MORE QUICKLY IS SUDDEN DEATH
WHEN THE NEED ARISES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY. LET'S
MOVE ON AND I THINK THAT THAT
THAT CONCLUDES THIS ISSUE AREA
I WILL MOVE ON TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS.
GOOD MORNING MORNING. OKAY
AFTER READING MAKE DAN AND-
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HSPITALS AND I STARTING
WITH ISSUE NUMBER ONE AND THERE
ARE FOURTEEN ITEMS THAT WE'VE
BEEN ASKED TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE
ON WILL COVER THEM VERY BRIEFLY
I AM GOING TO COVER THE FIRST
TEN AND THEN I'M GOING TO
PASSED ON TO DEBBIE DIRECTOR. I
CHRISTINA'S TO COVER THE
REMAINING FOUR SO STARTING WITH
THE FIRST MIND AT THE COMMUNITY
CARE DEMONSTRATION PROJECT FOR
FELONY ISPS UNDER THIS PROPOSAL
IDEAS H. WOULD HAVE CONTRACTED
WITH A SMALL NUMBER OF COUNTIES
TO ASSUME RESPONSIBILITY FOR
INDIVIDUALS FOUND INCOMPETENT
TO STAND TRIAL ON FELONY
CHARGES. AND PROVIDE A
CONTINUOUS SERVICES IN THE
COUNTY TO PROVIDE THE
RESTORATIONCOMPETENCY SERVICES
FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS BASED ON
THE FEEDBACK WE RECEIVED FROM
STAKEHOLDERS AND MAY REVISION
THIS PROPOSAL IS BEING
WITHDRAWN. ALTERNATIVELY THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS INTO NEW
OR EXISTING STRATEGIES- TO
EXPAND LOCAL CAPACITY FOR THE
TREATMENT OF DEFENDANTS FOUND
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL ON
FELONY CHARGES WHICH ARE
PROPOSED TO BE HEARD LATER IN
THE AGENDA SO WE'LL COVER THOSE
LATER. AS THE NEXT ITEM IS THE
METRIC. INCREASE SECURE
CAPACITY IN THE PRIOR YEAR'S
BUDGET WE WERE APPROPRIATED
FUNDING TO CONVERT EXISTING
CAPACITY AT THE ESSEX
METROPOLITAN IN SECURE INTO
SECURE BED CAPACITY FOR THE
TREATMENT OF BIAS TEES. THERE
WERE A TOTAL OF FIVE UNITS TO
BE UTILIZED FOR IDEAS TREATMENT
AND PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC WE
HAD ACTIVATED TWO OF THOSE
UNITS. THANK GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
BUDGET WE REPORTED A CURRENT
YEAR SAVINGS RELATED TO DELAYS
AND ACTIVATION OF THE REMAINING
THREE UNITS. DUE TO THE NEED TO
UTILIZE THESE UNITS FOR KOBE
NINETEEN RESPONSE AT MAY
REVISION THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
BUDGET YEAR. AND I'M GOING ON A
REDUCTION OF ONE POINT TWO
POSITIONS AND BUDGET YOUR ON
GOING IN THIS JUST REFLECTS A
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT DUE TO AN
ERROR THAT WAS DISCOVERED IN
POSITION OF AUTHORITY AND
FINDING. THAT WAS TIED TO A TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN MAY
REVISION CLASS THAT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN ON AN ONGOING INVESTMENT.
ADDITIONALLY AS THE MAY
REVISION WE DO ESTIMATE CONTENT
AND BEING ABLE TO BEGIN
ACTIVATING THESE UNITS FOR AYE
IS TRICKY TREATMENT AND
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
IF THE CURRENT CODE IN.
NINETEEN TRAJECTORY CONTINUED.
ON THE NEXT ITEM IS IN HERE
TREATMENT PROGRAM STAFFING. THE
IN HOUSE TREATMENT PROGRAM IS
AN ENHANCED LEVEL OF CARE
DESIGNED TO TREAT PATIENTS WHO
ARE AT THE HIGHEST RISK OF
VIOLENCE AND WHO CANNOT BE
SAFELY TREATED IN A STANDARD
TREATMENT ENVIRONMENT. IN PRIOR
YEARS BUDGETS WE HAVE BEEN
APPROVED PROVIDE AT. HIS ME
PROVED- RESOURCES AND FUNDING
TO CONSTRUCT AND OPERATE OR
UNITS. I GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE
REPORTED ESTIMATED SAVINGS FOR
THE IN HOUSE TREATMENT PROGRAM.
AT HOME DUE TO DELAYS IN
CONSTRUCTION HAVE DO TO COPE IN
NINETEEN. AND THEN HOURS OF NAY
REVISION WE REPORT INCREASED
SAVINGS OVER TWENTY THREE
POSITIONS AND THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION AND CURRENT YEAR. IN
BUDGET YOU'RE A WE REDUCE THE
ESTIMATED SAVINGS BY THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND DOWN TO ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION. IN IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AN ONGOING
REQUESTS- ONE MILLION FIFTEEN
THOUSAND IN GENERAL FUND. THE
JUSTIN SAVINGS REFLECT THE
CURRENT ESTIMATED TIMELINES T
COMPLETE CONSTRUCTION AND UNIT
CABLING FOR INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY. AND ACTIVATE THE
UNITS. CONSTRUCTION OF THE
FIRST UNIT IN THE S. H.
ATASCADERO IS NEARLY COMPLETE
AND WE ANTICIPATE ACTIVATING
THE FIRST UNIT. INTENTIONALLY
NEXT MONTH IF ALL GOES WELL.
AND THE REMAINING THREE UNITS
D. S. H. EXPECTS TO RESTART
CONSTRUCTION IN THE FALL AND
ESTIMATES COMPLETION. THROUGH
THE SPRING AND TWAN ARE. RAIN
IN SUMMER TWENTY TWO TWO. OTHER
FOR THE ONE MILLION INCREASE
FUNDING. I'M GOING IS TO
CORRECT AN OVERSIGHT IN PRIOR
PROPOSALS RELATED. TO PROVIDING
FUNDING FOR UPDATED SALARIES
AND POSITIONS- AS A BASIN. OR
VACATION SERVICES INPATIENT
MINIMUM WAGE UPDATE THE
VOCATIONAL REHABILITATION
PROGRAM HAS SERVED AS A
THERAPEUTIC PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
A RANGE OF VOCATIONAL SKILLS
AND THERAPEUTIC INTERVENTIONS
FOR PATIENTS. THE S. H. IS
REPORTING A ONE TIME SAVINGS OF
SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND IN CURRENT YEAR AND IS
PROJECTING THE PROGRAM TO
RESUME STANDARD OPERATIONS
EQUIVALENT TO PRE PANDEMIC
LEVELS AS OF JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AND DUDE CIRCLE THE
NINETEEN WE DID AND HOW THE
PATIENT LOCATION ASSIGNMENTS
REFERRALS HAD BEEN IMPACTED AS
A RESULT OF THE RESTRICTIONS ON
PATIENT WORK AND THE MANY JOB
SITES THAT COULD NOT HAS. A
PATIENT WORKERS DURING THAT
TIME- MISSION BASED STAFFING
STUDIES FOR DIRECT CARE NURSING
THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT
INCLUDED A TOTAL OF THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE POINT
FIVE POSITIONS. AND FORTY SIX
MILLION PHASE DOWN OVER A THREE
YEAR PERIOD TO SUPPORT THE
WORKLOAD OF PROVIDING TWENTY
FOUR HOUR CARE NURSING SERVICES
AT THE HOSPITALS. IN RESPONSE
TO THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF THE
PANDEMIC THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT REVISE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS STAFFING
STANDARDS CITIES AND ACROSS
BORDERS. AND FOUR YEAR PERIOD.
AS OF MAY REVISION WE ARE
REPORTING ONE TIME SAVINGS OF
THIRTY NINE POINT ONE POSITIONS
AND FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION IN
CURRENT YEAR. DUE TO HIRING
DELAYS AND REQUESTING FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND IN
BUDGET YEAR AND I'M GOING TO
UPDATE THE SALARIES AND PAY
DIFFERENTIALS FOR PREVIOUSLY
APPROVED UNESTABLISHED
POSITIONS. THAT ARE GONNA BE
PHASED OVER THE NEXT YEARS. AS
OF MARCH FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WE REPORT HUNDRED AND FOUR
POINT FIVE POSITIONS OF THIS
PURPOSE ORIGINAL PROPOSAL HAVE
BEEN ESTABLISHED IN SEVENTY TWO
POINT THREE HAVE BEEN FILLED.
AND A HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE POINT
FIVE POSITIONS THAT WERE
APPROVED ON THE TWENTY NINTH AT
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT ARE
SCHEDULED TO BE PHASED IN IN
THE. TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET- FOR A PROGRAM AND YOU
KNOW THE WORK DEVELOPMENT FOR
PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
AND PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS.
NEED TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT
INCLUDED RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF A PSYCHIATRIC
RESIDENCY PROGRAM. AND EXPAND
RESOURCES FOR NURSING
RECRUITMENT AND PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIAN TRAINING PROGRAM
EXPANSION. IN CURRENT YEAR-
WERE REPORTING A ONE TIME
SAVINGS OF ONE POINT TWO
POSITIONS AND TWO HUNDRED AND
THREE THOUSAND. AND AN ONGOING
SAVINGS OF FORTY THOUSAND
BUDGET YOU'RE DUE TO DELAYS IN
HIRING A RE CLASSIFICATION OF
ONE OF THE PREVIOUSLY APPROVED
NURSING INSTRUCTORS TO
ASSOCIATE. GOVERNMENT PROGRAM
ANALYSTS TO SERVE AS A
RECRUITMENT OUTREACH SPECIALIST
FOR BOTH OUR ENDS AND CENTEX- I
AM PLEASED TO REPORT BAD GENES
PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENCY PROGRAM
HAS RECEIVED ACGME
ACCREDITATION APPROVAL MATCH
THE FIRST SEVEN RESIDENTS IN
THE CONCORD. WILL BEGIN THIS
SUMMER JULY. AND FOR THE
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIAN PROGRAM
BOTH ATASCADERO AND NAPA HAVE
ENTERED INTO CONTRACTS WITH
BLESSED AND HAPPY NAPA VALLEY
COLLEGES TO EXPAND. THEIR
TRAINING PROGRAM CALLED PARTS.
FOR THE MISSION BAY STREET
COURT AND I YOU ASIANS ARE
REPORT. THAT TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT INCLUDED NINETY FOUR
POINT SIX PERMANENT FULL TIME
POSITIONS AND FORTY POINT THREE
MILLION PHASED IN OVER A THREE
YEAR PERIOD. TO IMPLEMENT A
STAFFING STANDARDS SUPPORT OUR
FRIENDS X. SERVICES WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH COURT DIRECTED
PATIENT TREATMENT- IN RESPONSE
TO THE PANDEMIC THIS IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT THIS
WAS REVISED BASIN OVER FOUR
YEAR PERIOD. AT MAY REVISION WE
ARE REPORTING A ONE TIME
SAVINGS OF THIRTEEN POINT SEVEN
POSITIONS IN TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION CURRENT YEAR DUE TO
HIRING DELAYS. AND REQUEST TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
GENERAL FUND ON GOING I'M IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND I'M GOING. TO UPDATE THE
SALARIES AND PAY DIFFERENTIALS
FOR THE POSITIONS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE PHASED IN. AS OF
MARCH FIRST FIFTY NINE POINT
EIGHT. POSITIONS HAVE BEEN
ESTABLISHED IN FORTY ONE HAVE
BEEN FILLED. AND TWENTY SEVEN
POINT TWO POSITIONS APPROVED-
ARE SCHEDULED TO BE PHASED IN
AND BUDGET HERE. FOR THE
TREATMENT TEAM AND PRIMARY CARE
MISSION BASED REVIEW STAFFING
STUDIES WE ARE REQUESTING THE
REMAINING FUNDING IN POSITION
OF AUTHORITY FOR FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE TREATMENT
TEAM AND PRIMARY CARE BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL THAT WAS
PRESENTED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- THIS
USE DATA FOR METHODOLOGIES FOR
STANDARDIZING THE CASELOAD FOR
THE R. INTRODUCED A PLENARY
TREATMENT TEAM AND PRIMARY CARE
RESULTING A PROPOSED INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF TREATMENT
TEAMS IN PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS ACROSS THE STATE
HOSPITALS. IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACTED DUE TO ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY CERTAINTY
SURROUNDING PANDEMIC. THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED THE
METHODOLOGIES IN THIS B. C. P.
AS WELL AS THE B. C. P. FOR
PROTECTIVE SERVICES
AUGMENTATIONS. BUT ONLY
AUTHORIZED BY MILLION AND
TWELVE POINT FIVE POSITIONS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND TEN
MILLION AND THIRTY POSITIONS IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO ON GOING
FOR BOTH OF THE PROPOSALS. AND
THE DEPARTMENT PRIORITIZE ALL
THAT FUNDING AND RESOURCES. TO
BE ALLOCATED TO THIS PROPOSAL
WE ARE REQUESTING THE REMAINING
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THREE POINT
THREE POSITIONS TO BE PHASED IN
OVER FIVE YEARS CONSISTENT WITH
THE ORIGINAL APPROVED
METHODOLOGIES. ADDITIONALLY FOR
THE RESOURCES THAT WERE
APPROVED IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WE PROJECT ONE TIME CURRENT
YOUR SAVINGS OF FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION AND THIRTEEN POINT FOUR
POSITIONS. DUE TO HIRING DELAYS.
AND THE PROTECTIVE SIR. THE
THING IS- HAVE PROPOSES
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET RECEIVED
PARTIAL FUNDING FOR BOTH THIS
AND THE- TREATMENT TEAM. B. C.
P. SO WE ARE REQUESTING SIX
POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND
AND THIRTY FIVE POINT EIGHT
SESSIONS IN BUDGET YEAR ELEVEN
POINT THREE MILLION AND SEVENTY
ONE POINT THREE POSITIONS IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND I'M
GOING. TO SLOWLY IMPLEMENT THE
ORIGINAL HOUSE. I WE DID A
MINUTE ESTABLISHED HOSPITAL
OFFICERS POSITIONS IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND YOU
KNOW LIES THE OVERTIME BUDGET.
BROWN'S TESTING TO BE IN A
PARTIAL IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
PROPOSAL AND THEN WE'LL
IMPLEMENTATION THIS. PROPOSAL
PROVIDES SUPPORT FOR PROTECTIVE
SERVICES FUNCTIONS AT DST IT'S
NOW BUT AN OUTSIDE CáC AN
EXECUTIVE LEADERSHIP SYSTEM
WIDE. AND I APOLOGIZE IF THERE
IS A LOT OF BACKGROUND NOISE WE
HAVE HAVE A LEAF BLOWER GOING
ON OUTSIDE THAT WINDOW HERE SO
I APOLOGIZE. THAT'S GETTING
PICKED UP I. ACTED WAS THE
CULPRIT. I AM GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND IT OH NO SORRY THERE'S ONE
MORE ITEM AND I NEED TO COVER
AND THAT I THE TELL US I TRIED
THREE RESOURCES THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT AUTHORIZED
ON THE DEPARTMENT RESOURCES AND
FUNDING TO ADD CLINICAL
OVERSIGHT AND SUPERVISION TELUS
PSYCHIATRY COORDINATORS AS WELL
AS INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
EQUIPMENT AND RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT THE TUSSOCK COUNTRY
PROGRAM. AT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
WE REPORTED ANTICIPATED CURRENT
YOUR SAVINGS AND IT MAY
REVISION WE ARE REPORTING AN
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME SAVINGS OF
SIX HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND FOUR POINT SEVEN
POSITIONS IN CAR HERE NOW
HANDED OVER TO A DEPUTY RECTOR
CONVENIENCE TO COVER THE
REMAINING FOUR CASE THAT
UPDATE. THAT THE- THANK YOU
VERY. HELLO HI CHRIS ENDS- FOR
ITEM IS- RELEASE PROGRAM NON
STP CASELOAD UPDATE- AS IT
RELATES TO THIS THERE IS
REMISSION COMPARED TO
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AT AT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE REQUESTED
ONE POINT TWO MILLION TO SHORE
UP OPERATING EXPENSES TO
INCREASE. IT OPERATING EXPENSES
I TO SUPPORT CONTRACT PROVIDERS
NEXT ITEM IS CONDITIONAL
RELEASE PROGRAM S. B. P.
CASELOAD UPDATE. AS A MEMBER OF
THE DE TRICK ONE EIGHT IN THE
BUDGET YEAR AN ON GOING TO
SUPPORT AN ESTIMATED AVERAGE
CASELOAD OF TWENTY FIVE S. B.
P. PATIENTS AND CONRAD. AS
REQUEST WILL COVER THE
OPERATING EXPENSES ESTIMATED TO
SUPPORT AN INCREASED AVERAGE OF-FOUR PATIENTS- WHICH ASSUMES A
PHASE IN OF ADMISSIONS AND
DISCHARGES THAT ARE PROJECTED
TO OCCUR OVER THE COURSE OF THE
YEAR. NEXT ITEM BOB IS AN
UPDATE RELATED TO THE CONRAD
CONTINUUM OF CARE PROGRAM. THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE IS A NETWORK
OF FACILITIES I AM DAYS AND
MENTAL HEALTH REHAB CENTRES
IDEAS YOU JUST CONTRACTING WAS
TO ESTABLISH A STEP DOWN
PROGRAM TO SUPPORT- OFFENDERS
WITH MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS AS
WELL AS NOT GUILTY BY REASON OF
INSANITY PATIENTS. TRANSITION
FROM THE STATE HOSPITAL TO THE
COMMUNITY THE GOAL OF THIS
PROGRAM IS TO BETTER PREPARE
INDIVIDUALS FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING IN THE COMMUNITY. AND IS
TARGETED TO THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
INSTITUTIONALIZED FOR MANY
YEARS. ADDITIONALLY THIS
PROGRAM PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SERVE. THE INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL. AB TWO CAR. DUE TO
CONTINUED ACTIVATION DELAYS OF
OUR SEVENTY EIGHT BUT STEP DOWN
PROGRAM IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
HAS A MAJOR REVISION THE
DEPARTMENT HAS IDENTIFIED
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME SAVINGS A
TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION IN THE
CURRENT YEAR ABOUT THE TOTAL
PRESENTED AT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET-
AND THIS REFLECTS A TOTAL
SAVINGS OF NINE POINT THREE
MILLION FOR THE CURRENT YEAR IN
ADDITION THE DEPARTMENT IS
REDUCING ITS BUDGET YOUR
REQUEST BY ANOTHER TWO POINT
SEVEN MILLION ON GOING TO
REFLECT A REDUCTION IN THE
NUMBER OF BEDS ANTICIPATED FOR
ANOTHER NEW PROGRAM THAT WE'RE
PLANNING IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THIS CHANGE
REFLECTS- I CHANGE FROM FORTY
BEDS TO TWENTY FIVE PROGRAM. I
IS- THIS IS AN UPDATE THE
JAPANESE COMPANY TREATMENT
PROGRAMS THIS REFLECTS OTHER
REQUEST FOR BOTH NEW AND
EXISTING G. B. C. T. PROGRAMS.
IN THE MAY REVISION D. S. H. IS
REQUESTING AN INCREASE OF
THIRTEEN POINT THREE MILLION IN
THE BUDGET YEAR AND TWENTY TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION ON GOING AS
COMPARED TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET TO SUPPORT THE COST
INCREASES ENCOURAGED BY.
EXISTING COUNTY PROGRAMS AS
WELL AS TO EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
NEW COUNTY PROGRAMS IN ADDITION
DSHS REQUESTING TO ESTABLISH
SEVEN POSITIONS TO SUPPORT THE
OVERSIGHT AND MANAGEMENT OF
THIS GROWING PROGRAM. COUPLED
WITH THE ADJUSTMENTS PRESENTED
AT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE
DEPARTMENT PLANS TO ACTIVATE A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE NEW
JBC KEYPADS ACROSS ELEVEN
COUNTIES- AND UPON ACTIVATION
OF THESE NEW BEDS. PSH WILL
OPERATE A TOTAL OF SIX HUNDRED
AND SEVEN GB CG- BEDS ACROSS
THIRTY TWO COUNTIES. WHICH
REALLY REFLECT THE MAJORITY OF
COUNTIES THAT WE'RE HOSTING
SUCH A PROGRAM IS POSSIBLE
BASED ON COUNTY CAPACITY. IN
THE RATE OF BIASED YOU
REFERRALS. SEVEN POSITION
REQUEST WILL DO YOU SEE TOOK. A
FORMAL PROBE STRUCTURE TO
MANAGE THE JBC T. PROGRAMS- AS
IT WERE THE CURRENT VOLUME OF
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH-
AREN'T NEW- AN EXISTING.
PROGRAMS REALLY EXCEED OUR
CAPACITY TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE
CLINICAL OVERSIGHT AND CONDUCT
QUALITY ASSURANCE REVIEWS OF
THESE SUCH ESSENTIAL PROGRAMS.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST- THIS IS
A- KEYSTONE UPDATE FOR THE SEX
OFFENDER CONNECT PROGRAM AN
OFFENDER WITH MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS AND VALUATION
PROGRAMS IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
BERMAN HAS EXPERIENCED A
DOWNWARD TREND IN THE RATE OF-
IN DEVALUATION REFERRALS FROM
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
TO DETERMINE IF INMATES
PREPARING FOR RELEASED NEARLY
FOUR CRITERIA FOR COMMITMENT TO
THE DEPARTMENT- THOUSAND-
INDEED ALSO AS A RESULT OF
OPERATIONAL CHANGES IN RESPONSE
TO THE CODE PANDEMIC DCH
EVALUATORS WERE ABLE TO PERFORM
WORK VIA VIDEO IN TELEHEALTH.
EVALUATION INSTEAD OF
CONDUCTING THOSE IN PERSON AT
THE VARIOUS PRISONS ACROSS THE
STATE AS A RESULT AND SEES IN
THE TIME NEEDED TO COMPLETE
EVALUATIONS WERE ACHIEVED.
THESE TWO CHANGES HAVE RESULTED
IN ONE TIME CURRENT YOUR
SAVINGS OF. FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND. IN THE PROGRAM. AND
IN ADDITION THIS DOWN TREND
ALLOW FOR THE TEN. ASSIGNMENT
OF CRITICAL I S. T. EVALUATION
WORKLOAD I TO BE REDIRECTED TO
SOME OF OUR- INDEED EVALUATORS.
YES EACH WILL CONTINUE TO
MONITOR THE- AND DEAN SB P.
REFERRAL TRENDS AND IDENTIFY
FUTURE ADJUSTMENTS THAT MAY BE
REQUIRED TO SUPPORT ONGOING
OPERATIONAL CHANGES. PROGRAM
CONCLUDES- MY TESTIMONY AND I
THINK THAT IS THE END OF ITEM
LINES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
BELIAU. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS
TO REASON THESE PROGRAM UPDATES
ARE KEY SORT OF THESE. THANK
YOU- MISUNDERSTOOD. AS YOU AS
YOU GO OVER SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS I GUESS I'M OF MY ONE
QUESTION IS AROUND AS WERE AS
WE'RE IMPROVING. THAT K. B. C.
T. ARE WE ARE WE ARE WE MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT LOSING BEDS
ON THE STEP DOWN SIDE AS WE
PREPARE MORE PEOPLE FOR TRIAL
WE'RE PUTTING MORE RESOURCES
INTO THAT WHICH WE NEED TO DO
TO REDUCE THE TIMELINE BUT ARE
WE ARE WE TAKING AWAY FROM BEDS
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF FOR THE
STEP DOWN IS THAT WHAT I HEARD
YOU SAY. OH NO NO- FOR THE STEP
DOWN THAT'S REALLY FOCUSED ON-
PRIMARILY STEPPING DOWN
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN THE
STATE HOSPITALS IN INTIMATE.
CONDITIONAL RELEASE PROGRAM
INTO THE COMMUNITY SO THAT'S
PRIMARILY- INDIAN ANGIE I
POPULATION. AND THEN WHERE IS
THE GBC TEAS ARE ARE SPECIFIC
TO THE INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL POPULATION. WHERE ON THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE WE WERE-
REDUCING OUR BEDS SIMPLY HAS TO
DEAL WITH- THE PROVIDER THAT WE
WERE WORKING WITH. COULD NOT-
CONTRACT WITH US FOR TWENTY
BEDS WE HAD REDUCE THAT
CONTRACT TO FIVE BEDS. BUT WE
HAVE BEEN SOMEWHERE ELSE FOR
THOSE OTHER FIFTEENTH YES YES
YEAH WE ACTUALLY TO NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA PROGRAMS ONE IS A
TWENTY BED PROGRAM AND THEN
THIS OTHER- WAS GOING TO BE
TWENTY BUT NOW IT'S REDUCED
DOWN TO FIVE. OKAY THANK YOU.
AND HAVE ANYTHING ELSE OKAY.
THANK YOU LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO THEN WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIMS. MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BRENT HELPED HER
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS-
THE ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
DEPUTY DIRECTOR PROVIDING A
BRIEF OVERVIEW ON ISSUE NUMBER
TWO. OF THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS REQUEST SIXTEEN AND A
HALF MILLION GENERAL FUND AT
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
FOURTEEN MILLION NEW TO SIXTEEN
MILLION ANNUALLY THROUGH TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE. AND SEVEN
POINT OH LIMITED CHRIS TERM
POSITIONS TO ADDRESS WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIMS RELATED TO
COPE AT NINETEEN AND AN ABLE D.
S. H. TO MEET TIME CONSTRAINTS
IN PROCESSING EVALUATING
WORKERS COMPENSATION CLAIMS.
THIS REQUEST DOES ALSO INCLUDE
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE FOR
ADDITIONAL WORKERS COMPENSATION
EXPENDITURES IF NECESSARY OR TO
REFER UNSPENT FUNDS AT THE
CLOSE OF THE FISCAL YEAR.
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARE
REQUIRED DUE TO AN INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF D. SHS WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIMS DRIVEN BY
COBIT NINETEEN. AND TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY THERE WERE A
TOTAL OF ONE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE NEW
CLAIMS AS COMPARED TO AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS OF THE END
OF FEBRUARY. THE DEPARTMENT HAS
A TOTAL OF TWO THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE NEW
CLAIMS. OF WHICH ABOUT SIXTY
THREE POINT 1% WERE COATED
NINETEEN RELATED. IN ADDITION
TO THE INCREASE CLAIMS AS A
RESULT OF COVERT NINETEEN WHICH
IS THE PRIMARY DRIVER OF THIS
REQUEST. THERE ARE REQUIRED
TIME FRAMES TO RESPOND TO
CLAIMS IN THE WORKLOAD FALLS ON
THE DEPARTMENT STAY HOSPITAL
STAFF TO GATHER THE APPROPRIATE
INFORMATION. DOCUMENTATION AND
EVIDENCE TO INFORM THE STATE
COMPENSATION INSURANCE FUND
DECISION TO ACCEPT OR DENY A
COVERT NINETEEN CLING. WORKERS
COMPENSATION BENEFITS MAY
INCLUDE BUT NOT BE LIMITED TO
FULL HOSPITAL SURGICAL MEDICAL
TREATMENT DISABILITY INDEMNITY
DEATH BENEFITS AND OTHER
DISCOVERY DISPOSITION COSTS.
THIS INFORMATION CONCLUDES AN
OVERVIEW THIS PROPOSAL ONE
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS BY
THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF THE BERMAN FINANCE. NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENT THAT TIME
THAT THANK YOU. THANK MANAGER
NOTE NO COMMENTS FROM US AT
THIS TIME EITHER. I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING ON THE SPECTRUM OKAY
MOVE ON THE ISSUE NUMBER THREE.
HELLO HI AGAIN CHRISTIE ENDS-
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FORENSIC
SERVICES THIS IS AN UPDATE TO
THE CONRAD MOBILE FORENSIC
ASSERTIVE COMMUNITY TREATMENT
PROGRAM. I THE FACT PROGRAM
ACTUALLY REPRESENTS A NEW LEVEL
OF CARE WITHIN CONRAD. AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET YES EACH
REQUESTED FIVE POINT SIX
MILLION IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND
EIGHT MILLION ON GOING TO
SUPPORT ONE HUNDRED BEDS
DEDICATED TO THIS EFFORT. WE
HAD ORIGINALLY ENVISIONED FIFTY
BANDS IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND THEN FIFTY BEDS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AT THE MAY REVISION
WERE REQUESTING AN ADDITIONAL
FOUR POINT ONE MILLION IN THE
BUDGET YEAR AND SIX POINT THREE
MILLION- IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
BOND GOING TO SUPPORT AN
INCREASE OF AN ADDITIONAL
EIGHTY BEDS FOR THIS PROGRAM.
WE ACTUALLY BEEN WORKING WITH-
EIGHT ATTENTION CONTRACT
PROVIDER YOU CAN STOP AND
OPERATE A TOTAL OF A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY BEDS. AND THAT WOULD
MEAN SIXTY BEDS IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SIXTY BEDS IN THE
BAY AREA AS WELL AS SIXTY BEDS
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WHICH
WOULD SERVE AS SORT OF THESE
REGIONAL PROGRAMS FOR
CONDITIONAL RELEASE PROGRAM.
ASSUMING APPROVAL OF THIS
REQUEST YES AGENCIES SECURING
THE CONTRACT WITH THE SERVICE
PROVIDER BY EARLY FALL. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO FACILITATE
PATIENT PLACEMENTS BEGINNING IN
JANUARY. TWENTY TWENTY TERRIBLE.
IN TOTAL DO YOU SEE TO SEE AND
ONCE SEVEN- OF. TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION IS ONE TIME. AND
FOURTEEN POINT THREE MILLION
ONLINE GOING IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
MY TESTIMONY HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LMAO. NO COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
AND SHARE ANY DEDUCTIBLE. OKAY
MOVING ADDITIONAL BEFORE. HI
THIS IS AN UPDATE TO THE
COMMUNITY BASED RESTORATION
PROGRAM WHICH I WILL REFER TO
YOU AS A CPR WE'RE REQUESTING
TO SUBSTANTIALLY EXPAND THIS
PROGRAM IS ONE OF OUR SOLUTIONS
TO HELP ADDRESS THE HIGHEST YOU
WAIT LIST AS OF THE MAY
REVISION THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
POINT THREE MILLION IN BUDGET
YEAR AND FIFTY FOUR POINT NINE
MILLION ON GOING TO SUPPORT AN
INCREASE OF. THREE HUNDRED AND
TWO ADDITIONAL CBR BEDS TO BE
ACTIVATED OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD AND FOUR AND A HALF
POSITIONS ABOVE THE REQUEST
PRESENTED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. THE BINDING REQUESTED
FOR THE CBR BEDS WOULD. ON BOTH
HOUSING AND OR TREATMENT
SERVICES- PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION IN START UP
FUNDS FOR THESE NEW PROGRAMS.
AS WELL AS CLINICAL PROGRAM
MANAGEMENT AND NAVIGATION
SERVICES WHICH ARE ESSENTIALLY
JAIL IN REACH SERVICES
IDENTIFY- AND STABILIZE
PROSPECTIVE CLIENTS. IN
ADDITION THE SERVICES WOULD
ALSO SUPPORT CREATE WHAT WE
CALL PRE TRIAL PROBATION
SERVICES TO ENHANCE THE OUR
COMMUNITY OVERSIGHT OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS. BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WE PROPOSED FUNDING TO
SUPPORT AND CREATE YOUR
ACTIVATION TWO HUNDRED BEDS IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. AS WELL AS
A BUDGET YOU'RE EXPANSION FIFTY
BEDS AND ABOUT FORTY FIVE OTHER
COUNTIES- ONGOING FUNDING FOR A
MAJORITY OF THOSE TV OUR BEDS
REQUESTED IN GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
WAS ACTUALLY INCLUDED AS PART
OF OUR COMMUNITY CARE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT PROPOSAL
WHICH HAS SINCE BEEN WITHDRAWN.
AND THAT WAS REALLY TO ALLOW
FOR THE POSSIBILITY OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE C. C. P. PROGRAM. NOW
WITH THE WITHDRAWAL OF THE CCP
PROPOSAL ONGOING FUNDING FOR
THE CBR BEDS IS NOW INCLUDED AS
PART OF- THIS REQUESTED ME
RECOGNITION. I'M NOT MY
TESTIMONY COMPLETED ACROSS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LMAO. NO NO
CONCERNS MADAM CHAIR WE FIND
THIS YEAR PROPOSED INVESTMENT
TO BE REASONABLE GIVEN YOU KNOW
THAT- GROWING DEMAND FOR ICY
TREATMENT ON PARTICULARLY ON AT
THE AT THE COUNTY LEVEL STUFF.
NASSIM L. L. A. COUNTY HAS A
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE AND- WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE AS MANY BEDS. THROUGH
ALL MEANS AS WE CAN THE CRAFT.
SURVEIL YOU ASIAN COMPONENT OF
THIS BUDGET CRISIS MANY FOR
THESE POSITIONS BUT- GIVEN WHAT
YOU'RE TELLING ME THAT WE
PULLED MONEY OUT HERE THAT ARE
SO IN THE END EVER GONNA HAVE
AN EVALUATION AS TO. HOW
SUCCESSFUL INVESTMENT IS I KNOW
WE'VE STRUGGLED WITH THAT. WITH
THAT. DEFINITELY BUT WE DO
HAVE- FUNDS REQUESTED TO
SUPPORT DATA TRACKING SO THAT
WE CAN- YOU KNOW PRODUCE
INFORMATION AND WE DON'T HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE EVALUATION.
EVALUATIVE COMPONENT- SIMILAR
TO WHAT WE WERE THINKING
THROUGH ON ON THE DEMONSTRATION
PROJECT- WE DO HAVE A NOT A
COUPLE OF YEARS A FEW YEARS
AND- ABOUT WITH- THE LA
COMMUNITY BASED RESTORATION
PROGRAM AND- AND SO REALLY.
LOOKING TO BAD EXPERIENCE TO
THEN BRING THAT TO THE OTHER
COUNTY. OKAY CELL YEAH I AM
CONCERNED BECAUSE YOU SEE
PULLED OUT THAT'S WHAT
EVALUATION. WAS THAT MEANS THE
VALUATIONS ARE THIS. WITHOUT
PROGRAM. SO I'M THINKING THAT
WE NEED TO HAVE AT LEAST SOME
OF VALUATION- OF. THIS
INVESTMENT I MEAN IT SOUNDS
GOOD ON THE SURFACE BUT I THINK
YOU KNOW. FOR SOME FEEDBACK
LATER TO LEGISLATURE WE MADE
THESE INVESTMENTS AND THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE ICE TEAS
AND WE WERE ACTUALLY ABLE TO OR
NOT. DECREASE THE CASELOAD
RIGHT SO- I HOPE THAT THAT'S-
THAT SHOULD BE BUILT IN. A IT
INTO THE PROPOSAL'S ANTICIPATED
EVALUATION AND REPORT BACK TO
LEGISLATURE ON ON ON THE
SUCCESS OR- OUR LACK OF SUCCESS
OR THE DEGREE OF SUCCESS OF
THIS OF THESE INVESTMENTS. WE
CAN CERTAINLY DO THAT OKAY
THANK YOU. OKAY LET'S MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER FIVE. FOR THIS
ITEM THE DEPARTMENT PROPOSES TO
DISCONTINUE THE STATE HOSPITALS
AS A TREATMENT OPTION FOR
MANAGEMENT STRUCTURE SHORT
CIVILLY COMMITTED PATIENTS OVER
A THREE YEAR PERIOD PROVIDE
TREATMENT FOR THESE PATIENTS AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL AND HAS
EXISTING LPS PATIENTS
TRANSITION FROM THE STATE
HOSPITALS TO THE COUNTY UTILIZE
THOSE BEDS FOR RESTORATION OF
COMPETENT COMPETENCY TREATMENT
FOR ISPS. UNDER EXISTING LAW
COUNTIES ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE TREATMENT OF LPS PATIENTS
INDIA STAGE IS ONE OF THE
TREATMENT OPTIONS THAT IS
AVAILABLE TO THE COUNTIES WHEN
IT COUNTY REFERS AN LPS PATIENT
TO THE DEPARTMENT FOR TREATMENT
THEY REIMBURSE THE DEPARTMENT
OR THE USE OF THE STATE
HOSPITAL BED. WITH THIS
PROPOSAL THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING GENERAL FUND TO BACK
FILL FOR THE LOSS IN
REIMBURSEMENT OTHERWISE
RECEIVED THEM FROM COUNTIES FOR
THE LPS PATIENT TREATMENT SO
THAT THE DEPARTMENT MAY
CONTINUE TO UTILIZE THESE BEDS
FOR ICE TEA TREATMENT
SPECIFICALLY REQUEST THREE
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS TO
MANAGE THE WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED
WITH THE TRANSITION OF THE LPS
PATIENTS. AND SIXTEEN POINT SIX
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
POINT ONE MILLION IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND A HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE THREE FIVE MILLION
IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR TO
PROVIDE THE FUNDING. TO SERVE I
S. T. PATIENTS. THE H. ALSO.
BUDGET BILL TO BE ABLE ADJUST
EXPENDITURES STORY AS NEEDED
SHOULD THE LPS CASE THAT WOULD
BE REDUCE QUICKER THAN THE
PROJECTED IN THIS PROPOSAL. I
REQUEST TRAILER BILL
LEGISLATION TO ENACT THE
NECESSARY STATUTORY CHANGES TO
IMPLEMENT THIS PROPOSAL AND
REMOVE THE S. H. AS A TREATMENT
OPTION FOR LPS. THE DEPARTMENT
PLANS TO ENGAGE THE COMPANY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION BECOME PRETTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AUTHORITY AND COUNTIES IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE TRANSITION
PLAN. TO FACILITATE THE
TRANSITION OF LPS PATIENTS TO
COUNTY TREATMENT OPTIONS WITH
IN THE THREE YEARS. AND WE
PROPOSED TO STOP ADMITTING NEW
LPS PATIENTS BEGINNING JULY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND STARTING
JANUARY WITH ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TO. BEGIN REDUCING THE LPS
POPULATION FROM THE CURRENT
CENSUS WITH THE TARGETED
REDUCTION OF ONE THIRD OF THE
LPS CENSUS EACH YEAR. THIS
ACTION IS NECESSARY TO ENABLE
THE DEPARTMENT TO DEDICATED
SCHOOL BY CAPACITY TO FORENSIC
PATIENTS. AND REFLECT THE SHS
STATUTORY AND CONSTITUTIONAL
OBLIGATIONS FOR THE TREATMENT
OF THOSE FRIENDS LIKE PATIENTS
WHILE ALSO BEING RESPONSIVE TO
THE WEIGHTLESS. ONGOING
REFERRALS AND LEGAL PRESSURE
SURROUNDING INDIVIDUALS FOUND
IN CONFERENCES STAND TRIAL ON
FELONY CHARGES. AND REFERRED TO
D. S. H. FOR RESTORATION OF
COMPETENCY TREATMENT. THERE WAS
ONE QUESTION IN THE AGENDA I'M
FOR THIS ITEM IT WAS THE
DEPARTMENT'S ASSESSMENT OF
COUNTY CAPACITY TO EFFECTIVELY
TREAT LPS POPULATION THIS
COMMUNITY. AS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED THIS PROPOSAL IS
STRUCTURED TO ACCOMPLISH THE
TRANSITION OF LPS PATIENTS OVER
THREE YEARS. WEEK KNOWLEDGE
THAT SOME INDIVIDUALS WILL BE
EASIER TO TRANSITION TO
TREATMENT OPTIONS WE CURRENTLY
HAVE A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISCHARGED
READY- AND THEY WILL BE EASIER
TO. TRANSITION INTO CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE SPACE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND OTHERS DUE TO THEIR
SPECIFIC NEEDS MAY TAKE
ADDITIONAL TIME TO EITHER
IDENTIFY OR DEVELOPMENT DEVELOP
PLACEMENT OPTIONS. THERE MAY
NOT CURRENTLY BE PLACEMENT
OPTIONS TODAY FOR THE ENTIRE L.
YES I COLLATION. SO WE PLAN TO
WORK WITH THE COUNTIES. TO
DEVELOP THE TRANSITION PLANS
WHICH WOULD TAKE INTO A THOSE.
SPACE TRANSIT OF PATIENTS
ACCORDING IF THE YEARS. TAKING
INTO ACCOUNT CAPACITY MEANS BUT
STILL ACCOMPLISH THE GOALS OF
THE PROPOSAL BY THE END OF THE
THREE YEAR PERIOD. AND WE'RE
COUNTIES DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
ADEQUATE RESOURCES AND THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUUM
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM PROPOSED
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. COULD BE AN
OPTION TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO ASSIST THE COUNTIES
IN MEETING THE NEEDS OF THE
OUTCAST POPULATION AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. ND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH HELLO. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR JUST A JUST A FEW
COMMENTS FROM THE L. A- ON THIS
ISSUE WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
WHILE WE DO FIND THAT- GROWING
DEMAND FOR ICE TEA BEDS YOU
KNOW ALONG WITH THE LEGAL
PRESSURES THE DEPARTMENT IS
FACING TO. ADMIT I ISSUES IN A
TIMELY MANNER MAKES
PRIORITIZATION OF- INCREASING
BED CAPACITIES FOR ICE TEA
WARRANTED. WE WOULD ALSO NOTE
THAT FOR STATE HOSPITAL LPS
BEDS OFFERED THIS THE
HOSPITALS- LPS- DEMAND FOR LPS
BATES APPEARS TO BE- INCREASING
AS WELL AND- WE FIND THAT
WHETHER COUNTIES HAVE CURRENT
CAPACITY FOR TAKING ON-
TREATMENT RESPONSIBILITY FOR
LPS PATIENTS CURRENTLY IN DISH.
REMAINS UNCLEAR- GIVEN THIS
UNCERTAINTY YOU KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO ASK
ADMINISTRATION HOW IT WILL
ENSURE THAT LPS STATIONS THAT
ARE INTENDED TO LEAD PSH. WILL
HAVE A PLACEMENT AVAILABLE TO
THEM FURTHERMORE YOU KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION WHY INCREASED
RESOURCES FOR. COUNTY BASED ISP
TREATMENT THROUGH JAIL BASED
PROGRAMS COMMUNITY BASED
RESTORATION PROGRAMS AND
DIVERSION PROGRAMS INCLUDING
YOU KNOW THOSE REQUESTS
INCLUDED IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET-
WOULD NOT BE SUFFICIENT TO
PROVIDE ENOUGH TREATMENT
CAPACITY FOR ICED TEAS. ARE
SUCH THAT THE S. H. COULD
MAINTAIN LPS BEDS AT ITS
FACILITIES- IN ADDITION WE
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT NO THERE
IS ANOTHER D. S. H. PROPOSAL-
THAT WILL BE DISCUSSED LATER IN
THE AGENDA WHICH WOULD REQUIRE.
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE COUNTIES
TO- TAKE BACK L. I SEE PATIENTS
THAT ARE DEEMED UNABLE TO BE
RESTORED TO COMPETENCY-
ACCORDING TO THE ADMINISTRATION
A SIZEABLE PORTION OF ITS
CURRENT. IDEAS H. LPS PATIENTS
ACTUALLY ENTERED THE U. S. H.
AS ISPS BUT THEN. END UP AS LPS
PATIENTS CIVILLY COMMITTED
AFTER THEY ARE- SORT OF DEEMED
UNABLE TO BE RESTORED TO
COMPETENCY. YOU KNOW WELL THAT
PROPOSAL COULD SIMILARLY FREE
UP SPACE AND B. S. H. UNIT WE
WOULD KNOW THAT IT WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE COUNTY CAPACITY-
INCLUDING POTENTIALLY FOR
ADDITIONAL LPS BEDS- FOR WHICH.
COUNTY CAPACITY REMAINS UNCLEAR.
I FINALLY THAT WE JUST SORT OF
NOTE THAT. YOU KNOW THESE THAT
WE ABOUT COULD PASS FOR TWO.
LPS YOU KNOW DO NOT NECESSARILY
MEAN THAT COUNTIES WOULD BE
UNABLE TO TREAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS IN THE FUTURE. YOU
KNOW- AS AS NOTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION EARLIER THERE IS
A MAJOR PROPOSAL IN THIS
YEAR'S- BUDGET FOR. YOUR HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGH DH CS-
IN CONCEPT COUNTIES COULD HAVE
ACCESS TO FUNDS TO THAT
PROPOSAL TO. BUILD OUT THEIR
CAPACITY FOR TREATING LPS
PATIENTS I'M GOING FORWARD.
HOWEVER YOU KNOW WE WOULD KNOW
THAT THEIR TIMELINE FOR
COUNTIES TO BUILD OUT BED
CAPACITY FOR LPS PATIENTS-
MIGHT NOT NECESSARILY ALIGNED
WITH THE TIME LINES THAT ARE
OUTLINED UNDER THIS PROPOSAL-
THOSE ARE ALL OF OUR COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME AND WE'RE SORT OF
HAPPY TO PROVIDE FURTHER
ASSISTANCE WHERE NEEDED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- EL DIRECTOR I
DID THIS I UNDERSTAND I
UNDERSTAND THIS NEED AND I
UNDERSTAND THIS DESIRE AS AS A
MR SHE TO SAID I KNOW THAT
THERE'S PRESSURE NOT JUST FROM
A LEGAL STANDPOINT TO BE ABLE
TO- TO TREAT THESE FOLKS AND
TO- MAKE THE I. S. T. TIMELINE-
BUT AT THE SAME TIME. THERE'S A
GROWING WITH A CRISIS ON OUR
STREETS WE HAVE A CRISIS IN OUR
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM. AND I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT MOVING
FOLKS- FROM STATE HOSPITALS
BACK DOWN. ON TO PUT IN EVEN
MORE PRESSURE AND- COMPACTION
OF WE SEE AT OUR BED SPACE AT
THIS POINT. THAT MAKES MAKES
SENSE- I'M BETTING CERTAINLY
WHAT WE'VE SEEN BOTH IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS A STATE
HOSPITAL LEVEL. THAT PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES A
SICK PEOPLE ARE GETTING SICKER-
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN AWARE OF FOR A
LONG TIME BUT NOW ALL OF A
SUDDEN WHERE WE ARE ALL.
WORKING UP TO THE CRISIS THAT
WE HAVE THAT SO IT MAKES MORE
SENSE TO ME AND I YOUKNOW I
SORRY I GUESS I WOULD ASK YOU
TO RESPOND TO THIS QUESTION. M.
THERE ARE. THE REST ROOM FOR
MORE. FUNDING IN THE IN THE
LAST PRESENTATION TO. INCREASE
SOME OF HIS BED SPACE. AND NOW
WE'RE TAKING ASKING FOR THIS
BIG MOVE. AT WOULDN'T IT MAKE
MORE SENSE. TO BEGIN TO PERHAPS
WORK TOWARDS THIS GOAL BUT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE FUNDING IN
BED SPACES THERE AS A MISTER
SHE TALKED ABOUT. THE BIG
INFRASTRUCTURE I COULD YOU MOVE
CARE BEHAVIOR HEALTH AND
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS THAT'S
COMING THROUGH SOME OF OUR
PAYMENT RESTRUCTURING. THAT'S
COMING THROUGH HOPEFULLY WE'RE
WE'RE ALL MOVING- TOWARDS HIS
GOAL OF INCREASING OUR CAPACITY
ACROSS OUR SYSTEM- WOULDN'T IT
MAKE MORE SENSE TO WAIT TILL
THOSE RESOURCES ARE IN PLACE.
BEFORE WE MOVE A WHOLE NOTHER
POPULATION UP FROM THE STATE
LEVEL BACK DOWN TO COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I AM I
WOULD JUST. SAY WE DEFINITELY
RECOGNIZE THIS IS A DIFFICULT
PROPOSAL- UNFORTUNATELY WE AT
THE DEPARTMENT ARE FACED WITH-
A DELICATE CHALLENGE WE HAVE A-
WAIT LIST OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
WHO AND CONSTITUTIONALLY NEED
TO RECEIVE TREATMENT- AND THE
DEPARTMENT IS FACING VERY
SIGNIFICANT LITIGATION
PRESSURES WE CURRENTLY. I JUST
RECENTLY- HAD AND THE PEEL
HEARING WITH RESPECT TO OUR
ORAL ARGUMENTS. WITH RESPECT TO
OUR H. IN A MOST SIGNIFICANTLY
GEISHA SURROUNDING THIS
POPULATION AND I WHICH THE
REQUIREMENT OF THAT- LITIGATION
IS THAT TO THE DEPARTMENT-
START- SUBSTANTIVE TREATMENT
FOR ANYBODY THAT IS REFER TO IT
WITHIN TWENTY EIGHT DAYS WE'RE
CURRENTLY WELL BEYOND SIX
MONTHS FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
REFERRED TO THE DEPARTMENT. SO
WE HAVE A VERY- SIGNIFICANT-
THE CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS ON THE ICE TEAS WE
CERTAINLY HAVE AN ROPOSALS IN
THAT HIGH MAY REVISION TO
EXPAND COMMUNITY BASE
RESTORATION COME PASS ANY AND
JAIL BASED COMPETENCY TREATMENT
CAPACITY WE HOPE TO DO THAT AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN. BUT THAT
ALSO IS WERE- ALSO REQUIRES US
TO PARTNER WITH COUNTIES WHERE
WE DON'T HAVE NECESSARILY
CONTROL OVER THE TIMELINES THE
PROCESSES OR THE NECESSARILY
THEIR AGREEMENTS OF THE LOCAL
LEVEL TO BE ABLE TO STAY ON
THAT PASSING A QUICKLY. I WE
CERTAINLY WITH BEING- LPS A
PROPOSAL ALL OF THAT CAPACITY
THAT WE HAVE PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WHICH
INCLUDED NOT ONLY COMMUNITY
BASED RESTORATION JOB IS
COMPETENCY TREATMENT AS WELL AS
EXPANSION OF DIVERSION AS WELL
AS YOU HEARD ABOUT. THE
PROPOSALS TO STEP MORE
INDIVIDUALS OUT OF THIS STATE
HOSPITALS AND TO HOPEFULLY BE
ABLE TO BACKFILL FROM THE WAIT
LIST OF IDEAS TO USE A WELL
WE'RE CURRENTLY PROJECTING
BASED ON ALL THAT CAPACITY-
APPENDING PLACEMENT LIST AT THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO OF SIX
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE AYE AS
TEENS. TODAY WE'RE CURRENTLY
I'D- AT. FIVE FIFTEEN HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FOUR IS TO USE ON
THE WAIT LIST IN THERE'S ABOUT
THREE AND FIFTY NEW REFER THAT
IN. SINGLE MONTH THE- THAT WE
CERTAINLY HAVE. YOU KNOW
THERE'S A THERE'S A CONSTANT
DEMANDS- AND SO WE NEED- STEPS
AND THAT AND OUR EXPERIENCE HAS
BEEN THAT THAT OUR REFERRAL
BASE CONTINUES TO GROW. AND SO
YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO ALSO
PLANNED FOR POTENTIAL GROWTH IN
THE REFERRAL BASED AS WELL SO
AND ULTIMATELY YOU KNOW WELL IT
IS A VERY- DIFFICULT PROPOSAL
FOR THE AT THE TRANSITION OF
LPS POPULATION OUT WE DO PLAN
TO WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
COUNTIES TO HELP THEM WORK ON
THIS TRANSITION PLANS TO AND-
WE CERTAINLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. EVERYBODY THAT IS
TRANSITIONING OUT OF THE STATE
HOSPITAL GETS INTO THE CARE
THAT THE- THAT THEY NEED- BUT
WE ALSO DEFINITELY HAVE TO
BALANCE THESE COMPETING
PRIORITIES AND ULTIMATELY THE
PACKAGE OF PROPOSALS THAT. THE
ADMINISTRATION PUT FORTH IS TO
ADDRESS. THOSE CHALLENGES. I
HEAR YOU. I DON'T KNOW THEM I
DON'T KNOW. CAN ANYTHING HONEST.
I THINK YOU COVERED IT THANK
YOU. OKAY THE. AND WE'RE GOING
TO PLAN C. LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER SIX. HEY CHRIS
HUGHTON'S W. DIRECTOR FORENSIC
SERVICES THIS IS AN UPDATE TO
BE INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
DIVERSION PROGRAM. I BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WE REQUESTED ONE TIME
FUNDING OF FORTY SEVEN POINT
SIX MILLION IN THE BUDGET YEAR
TO EXPAND DSHS VERSION PROGRAM
TO ALL OTHER COUNTIES IN THE
STATE. OF HER THREE YEAR
BEGINNING PERIOD BEGINNING
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO YEARS
THROUGH FISCAL YEAR TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX. ARE CURRENTLY DS
EACH IS FUNDED TWENTY FOUR
COUNTIES TO IMPLEMENT MENTAL
HEALTH DIVERSION PROGRAMS AIMED
AT SERVING THE I. S. T. I. OR
THOSE LIKELY FOUND I ASKED
YOUNG FELONY CHARGE. THIS POINT
WE'VE GOT- WE PREACH EIGHT AND-
INDIVIDUALS WILL BE SIR OVER.
THREE YEAR- AND AS OF THE END
OF DECEMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX CLIENTS AND SERVED
IN THE PROGRAM. AS OF THE MAY
REVISION WE ARE UPDATING THE
AMOUNT REQUESTED FOR RE
APPROPRIATION. FROM THE
ORIGINAL ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FUNDED FOR THIS PROGRAM
IN NOW PROJECTED HAS CHANGED
FROM. EIGHT MILLION TO SIX
POINT SIX MILLION. AS IT
RELATES TO OUR BUDGET YOUR
REQUEST WE'RE ACTUALLY NOT
CHANGING- THERE IS NO CHANGE IN
FUNDING COMPARED TO OUR REQUEST
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET-
HOWEVER DSHS PROPOSING TRAILER
BILL. LEGISLATION TO AMEND
PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS OUTLINED
IN WELFARE AND INSTITUTIONS
CODE FORTY THREE SIXTY ONE THAT
WILL APPLY ONLY TO THE
EXPANSION OF THE EXISTING
COUNTY DIVERSION PROGRAMS THAT
ARE. CURRENTLY FUNDED IDEA
STAGE- DOES A PROGRAMMATIC
CHANGES WOULD BE- THAT THE
EXPANSION MUST SERVE THE FELONY
I S. T. POPULATION- ANY MENTAL
HEALTH DIAGNOSES THAT IS
CURRENTLY AUTHORIZED IN PENAL
CODE ONE THOUSAND ONE TWENTY.
ONE THOUSAND ONE POINT THREE
SIX WILL QUALIFY FOR DS EACH-
DS EACH FUNDED PROGRAM. AS IT
AS IT CURRENTLY STANDS WE ONLY
ALLOW THREE ON MENTAL HEALTH
DIAGNOSES I TO QUALIFY FOR A
PROGRAM THAT SCHIZOPHRENIA
SCHIZOAFFECTIVE DISORDER
BIPOLAR DISORDER. AND I THIRD
CHANGES THAT EXPANSION OF THE
PROGRAM WILL NOT BE SUBJECT
SHOULD BE 10220% MATCHING FUND
REQUIREMENT THAT IS- UNDER THE
CURRENT GUIDELINES OF OUR
PROGRAM. HOWEVER ANY NEW COUNTY
PROGRAM COMES ON BOARD AND THAT
WILL BE FUNDED BY D. S. H. WILL
STILL BE SUBJECT TO THE
ORIGINAL REQUIREMENTS- WELFARE
AND INSTITUTIONS. CODE FORTY
THREE SIXTY ONE HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU- HELLO.
NOTHING FURTHER A NO COMMENTS
ON THIS VENTURE. AT MAKES GOOD
SENSE OKAY IT'S ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN. THIS IS THE COVER
NINETEEN DIRECT RESPONSE
EXPENDITURES AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- BE AT THE STATE MIGHT
BE C. P. FOR KOBE NINETEEN
RESPONSE THE DEPARTMENT
PROPOSED FIFTY TWO MILLION
GENERAL FUND FOR ANTICIPATED
EXPENDITURES IN THE BUDGET
YOU'RE FOR THE DEPARTMENT'S.
RESPONSE THE COSBY NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AS A MAJOR REVISION
WE'RE PROPOSING AN ADDITIONAL
ALLOCATION OF SEVENTEEN POINT
THREE MILLION GENERAL FUND
BUDGET YEAR AND THIS ADJUSTMENT
REFLECTS UPDATED EXPENDITURE
PROJECTIONS BASED ON THE
INCLUSION OF THREE MORE MONTHS
OF ACTUAL EXPENDITURE DATA. AS
WELL AS A TEAM I'M PROJECTIONS
TO INCLUDE FULL YEAR FUNDING
FOR COVE IN NINETEEN TESTING
AND SCREENING FOR PATIENTS AND
EMPLOYEES. HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. HELLO I THINK REST
MANAGER WORKING ON THIS AS WELL
OKAY. MOVING ON ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT. HI STUDENTS TO BE
DIRECTOR ON THIS YEAR SHE WAIT
REEVALUATION SERVICES FOR
QUALITY INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL. THIS IS A REQUEST THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING TWELVE
POINT SEVEN MILLION IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
ELEVEN MILLION IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND TEN POINT TWO
MILLION IN THE OUT YEARS AS
WELL AS FIFTEEN POINT FIVE
POSITIONS TO ESTABLISH THE
REEVALUATION SERVICES FOR.
FELONY I S. T. PROGRAMS ON A
FOUR YEAR LIMITED TERM BASIS.
WELL OF THIS REQUEST WILL ALLOW
THE DEPARTMENT BEGINNING JULY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
PARTNER WITH COUNTY JAILS
ACROSS THE STATE. TO REEVALUATE
INDIVIDUALS TEAMS I S. T. ON A
FELONY CHARGE YOU HAVE BEEN
WAITING IN JAIL. FOR SIXTY DAYS
OR MORE WELL CAN BE TRANSFERRED
TO A T. S. EACH TREATMENT
PROGRAM. THIS REQUEST BUILDS
OFF OF. THE DEPARTMENTS
EXPERIENCE OVER THE LAST YEAR
DURING THE PANDEMIC WHERE WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO CONDUCT REMOTE
FORENSIC EVALUATIONS VIA
TELEHEALTH- ENVY OVER. AT THE
WORKLOAD AND COST FOR THIS
PROPOSAL FALL INTO THREE MAIN
CATEGORIES ONE OF THE PANEL OF
CONTRACTORS FRIENDS THE VALUE
WAITERS TO STATE STAFF TO
PROVIDE CLINICAL ADMINISTRATIVE
AND CASE MANAGEMENT SUPPORT TO
COORDINATE THE SERVICES- AND
THEN ASSUMING THAT THE MAJORITY
OF EVALUATIONS ARE CONDUCTED
VIRTUALLY THIS PROPOSAL ALSO
INCLUDES REIMBURSEMENT TO
COUNTY JAILS. TO ASSIST
REPRESENTATION OF THOSE TELLER
EVALUATIONS- THAT THAT
REIMBURSEMENT- INCLUDES A ONE
TIME FLAT RATE REIMBURSEMENT
FOR TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT SUCH AS
LAPTOPS AND SOFTWARE LICENSES.
AND THEN THE SECOND TYPE OF
REIMBURSEMENT IS A FLAT
REIMBURSEMENT RATE AND FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR EACH I. S. T.
DEPENDENT AND VALUE WAITED ON
THIS PAYMENT ISN'T REALLY
INTENDED TO COVER AND JAIL
STAFF TIME INVOLVED IN
ESCORTING THE HIGHEST YOU
DEFEND IT STARTS AT EIGHT IN B.
HELLO A. WE SHOULD INTERVIEW-
THE DESIGN OF THIS PER IS. WITH
HOW DIFFERENT MANAGE ITS
CURRENT RISK. FOR CREATING
MEANT EVALUATIONS UNDER.
OFFENDERS WITH MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDER IN SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATOR STATUTES. AND AFTER
THE THIRD YEAR OF PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION DEPARTMENT WILL
ASSESS THE NEED TO EXPAND ALL
OR A PORTION OF THE RESOURCES I
REQUEST YOU HEAR ON AN ONGOING
BASIS AND IF NECESSARY SUBMIT
ANY BUDGET REQUEST FOR THE
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
SIX. MY TESTIMONY BE TAKEN
QUESTIONS HELLO. NO COMMENTS ON
THIS ITEM MANAGER. SHOULD YOU
THE L. INGENUITY ASCENDERS AND
TRYING TO FIND EVERYWHERE WE
CAN TO BE ABLE TO MEET THIS
NEED- ARGUED FOR WE DOING ANY
OUTCOME MEASUREMENTS DO WE KNOW
IF THE OUTCOMES ARE THE SAME.
IN PERSON VERSUS USING A
TELEHEALTH MORE REMOTE KIND OF
MODEL ON- I MEAN I DON'T I
DON'T KNOW QUITE HOW YOU
MEASURE IT FROM AN IN PERSON
VERSIONS THIS BUT- OTHER
OUTCOMES DIFFERENT. WE'RE NOT
SEEING OR NOT SEEING A
SIGNIFICANT- DIFFERENCE IF
WE'RE ABLE TO HAVE THAT THAT-
VISUAL INTERVIEW CONDUCTED VIA
THE VIDEO ME WE HAD AN ISSUE.
BETWEEN BETWEEN THE EVALUATIONS
THAT WE CONDUCT IN PRISON AND
THEN THE VIOLATIONS THAT WE
HAVE DONE- IN COORDINATION
WITH. DIFFERENT JAILS ACROSS
THE STATE NEEDS. FOUNDED JUST
AS EFFECTIVE. I THINK- SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES ARE THAT THERE
ARE SOME JAILS THAT ARE REALLY
NOT SET UP TO DO SOME OF THIS
THAT WE DIDN'T IS. A SMALL
NUMBER WALL LIKELY HAVE TO
OCCUR IN PERSON- BUT WE ALSO
RECEIVE ALL OF THE RECORDS AND-
VS RESEARCHER TRANSMISSION.
EMAIL OR- ELECTRONICALLY
ALREADY SO WE DO ALL THAT. WORK
IN ADVANCE FOR BUYING-
REVIEWING- THE CUSTODIAL
RECORDS AS WELL AS MENTAL
HEALTH IN. OUR RECORDS AND SO
WE DEAL WITH A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF OUR- WORK LOAD- PRIOR
TO THE ACTUAL INTERVIEW. ON THE
SHOW. DO YOU THINK THIS IS ALL
OF THEM I MEAN DO YOU THINK
WILL TAKE A CHUNK OUT OF BEING
ABLE TO MEET THAT DE BETTER. I
INTEND WE ARE WE DEFINITELY
NEEDED AS PART OF OUR PACKAGE
OF SOLUTIONS AND ALSO TO HELP-
BY SOME TIME. AS WELL AS-
PROGRAMS THAT YOU SEE ARE IN
THE G. B. C. T. PROGRAMS. RAMP
UP- MIGHT HANDED OVER TO THE
DOCTOR WERE BURTON WHO IS OUR
MEDICAL DIRECTOR AND HE'S HAD
SOME DIRECT EXPERIENCE. AROUND
THIS. DR THANK YOU I'M CAN'T
WORK ON OUR MATTER DIRECTOR AT
THE ESTATE WE HAVE SEEN SOME
SUCCESS AND WE ARE SEEING
OUTCOMES THAT ARE SIMILAR TO
WHAT WE SEE IN HOSPITALS
ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES TO
PATIENTS WHO ARE ALREADY
COMPETENT OUR RESEARCH THREE C.
DAVIS HAS INDICATED THROUGHOUT
THE YEARS THAT MAYBE ONE IN
FOUR PEOPLE THAT WERE ADMITTING
IS ACTUALLY COMPETENT WHEN THEY
HIT THE DOOR AND IN THIS SORT
OF VIRTUAL ENVIRONMENT WE'VE
DONE A LITTLE OVER EIGHTY
EVALUATIONS AND WE FOUND THAT
ONE IN THREE ESSENTIALLY OF THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE'VE
INTERVIEWED VIRTUALLY IS
ALREADY CONFIDENCE SO- IN TERMS
OF THAT OUTCOME IT'S
COMPARABLE. I THINK FIVE
CLINICALLY WHERE WE REALLY. S.
NEED IS THE MEDICATION OF THESE
FOLKS THE VAST MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE SENT TO US IS
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL HAVE
A PSYCHOTIC DISORDER. AND WHAT
THEY REALLY NEED IS IN A
PSYCHOTIC MEDICATION AND- I
THINK THE EVALUATION SERVICE.
OUR COULD BE QUITE ROBUST IF WE
FIND THE JAILS- WANTING TO
PARTNER WITH US AROUND GETTING
THAT MEDICINES THAT PATIENTS.
SO AT THIS POINT THE JAILS ARE
THE ARE OMPLYING WITH
MEDICATION MANAGEMENT UNDER
THEIR CARE. SOME ARE AND SOME
AREN'T. AND WE CONTINUE TO WORK
INDIVIDUALLY- TO TRY TO
ENCOURAGE THAT AND PROVIDE
WHATEVER TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
IS NEEDED. BECAUSE I WOULD
GUESS THAT IF- IF PEOPLE ARE
EVALUATED THAT THE REAL KEY TO
STAND TRIAL WITHOUT MEDICATION
MANAGEMENT IF THEY REMAIN IN
JAIL THAT CAN QUICKLY ADD
DIGRESS. YES YES REALLY
APPRECIATE THE BOTTOM LINE
CLINICALLY IS COMPETENCY AND
MEDICATION ARE PRETTY MUCH-
THANKS RIGHT OKAY AS AS- MOST
OF THESE FOLKS ARE PSYCHOTIC IF
THEY'RE ON MEDICINE HOW WE CAN
GET THEM COMPETENT AND IF
THEY'RE NOT- THEY REMAIN
INCOMPETENT OR- AND RETURN TO
INCOMPETENCE IF THEY'RE NOT
PROPERLY MEDICATED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WOULD I WOULD
NOTICE STAFF THAT REMIND US TO
FOLLOW UP ON THE COUNTY'S NON
COMPLIANCE WITH- WITH
MEDICATION MANAGEMENT- PLEASE
KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO WORK ON
THE FRONT END ON ASSISTED
OUTPATIENT TREATMENT TO GET
MORE PEOPLE ON. MANAGE BEFORE
THEY END UP COMMITTING A CRIME
AND THEN ENDING UP ON YOUR END
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S
MOVE ON TO- OUR NEXT ISSUE
WHICH IS. NUMBER. NINE BUT
HOUSING DEPARTMENT STATE
HOSPITAL SPEAKING TO ISSUE
NUMBER NINE OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF STATE HOSPITALS REQUEST SIX
POINT THREE MILLION GENERAL
FUND AND SIX POINT OH THREE
YEAR LIMITED TERM POSITIONS IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO OF WHICH
FOUR POINT ONE MILLION OR ONE
TIME COSTS YOU BUILD AND
IMPLEMENT A STATEWIDE
INTEGRATED HEALTH CARE PROVIDER
NETWORK IN ADDITION WE TWO
POINT TWO MILLION IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR. RESOURCE IS
INCLUDED IN THIS PROPOSAL
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT
IMPLEMENTATION OF A CONTRACT
WITH THE STATE WIDE INTEGRATED
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER NETWORK
INCLUDING PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
AND THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATION
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT CONTINUITY
OF CARE AND PROVIDE STABLE ONE
TIMELY ACCESS TO SPECIALTY
QUALITY MEDICAL SERVICES FOR
PATIENTS AT AN AFFORDABLE COST.
BY WAY OF BACKGROUND THIS
REQUEST WAS ORIGINALLY
SUBMITTED AS PART OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
WAS MODIFIED AT ME REVISION
ULTIMATELY DEFERRED WITHOUT
PREJUDICE TO THE IMPACTS OF
KOBE NINETEEN. THIS PROPOSAL
LARGELY REMAINS UNCHANGED AS
THE S. H. CONTINUES TO CONTRACT
OUT FOR A VARIETY OF MEDICAL
TREATMENT SERVICES AREN'T THAT
MAY NOT BE AVAILABLE WITHIN A
STATE HOSPITAL. CURRENTLY EACH
HOSPITAL IDENTIFIES CONTRACTS
WITHIN PAYS PROVIDERS FOR
SERVICES AND STANDARDIZED
METHOD. ADDITIONALLY SOME PSH
HOSPITALS IN REMOTE LOCATIONS
SUCH AS ATASCADERO OR CALLING A
WHICH MAKES IT DIFFICULT TO
FIND. OUTSIDE MEDICAL PROVIDERS
WITHIN REASONABLE DISTANCE OR
AT REASONABLE COST.
ADMINISTRATIVELY YES H.
INVOICES PAYMENT PROCESS LACKS.
GATOR DATA CAPTURING ABILITY TO
ENABLE THE S. H. TO ANALYZE
TRENDS WITHIN OUTSIDE MEDICAL
SERVICES WHICH CAN ULTIMATELY
DRIVE. AWESOME SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENTS AND DECISIONS
BASED ON THE DATA THAT WE'RE
SEEING- AND SUMMARY A STATEWIDE
NETWORK OF PROVIDERS ONE ABLE
D. S. H. TO GAIN ACCESS TO A
MULTITUDE OF PROVIDERS. WHILE
ALSO IMPROVING EFFICIENCY BY
WORKING THROUGH ONE
ADMINISTRATOR I WITH THAT HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MADAM CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LMAO. NO
COMMENTS ON THIS ITEM MANAGER.
QUEUE UP MAKES PERFECT SENSE MR
HOUSER I WISH YOU LUCK OF
EVERYBODY'S TRYING TO. WE'VE
GOT. ALL THESE FOLKS- OKAY
ISSUE NUMBER TEN ONE TIME
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ALLOCATION
ADJUSTMENT. YES I WILL ALSO BE
SPEAKING TO ISSUE NUMBER TEN OF
THE DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS
IS REQUESTING ONE TIME EIGHTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS GENRAL
FUND AVAILABLE OVER THREE YEARS
TO ADDRESS CRITICAL DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE SPECIAL REPAIRS
REPLACEMENT AND REGULATORY
COMPLIANCE PROJECTS ACROSS THE
SHS FIVE STATE HOSPITALS. OTHER
PLANNED PROJECTS INCLUDE THOSE
RELATED TO FIRE AND LIFE SAFETY
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND
OTHER SYSTEM REPLACEMENTS I
SPECIFICALLY THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS INTENDED
TO BE COMPLETED VIA THIS
REQUESTED FUNDING INCLUDE ROOF
REPAIR CENTER I REPLACEMENT.
REPAIRING SECURITY AND
EMERGENCY ACCESS ROADS ARE FIRE
AND WATER LINE CONNECTION
PLACEMENT AND REPLACEMENT OF
CHILLERS AND COOLING SYSTEM.
THIS PROPOSAL IS IN ADDITION TO
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REQUEST A
FIFTEEN MILLION DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FUNDING FOR A TOTAL
REQUEST OF A HUNDRED MILLION IN
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FOR
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS.
ARE BY WAY OF BACKGROUND YES
THEY JUST INSTRUCTURE SPANS
FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR
BUILDING BUILDINGS AND TWENTY
SIX HUNDRED ACRES OF LAND-
WHICH IS UP ALL AGING AND
CRITICAL BUILDING SYSTEMS HAVE
EXCEEDED THEIR USEFUL LIFE. WE
FIND THAT ADDRESSING MINOR
PROBLEMS BEFORE THEY ESCALATE
IS ESPECIALLY CRUCIAL AS TO
PREVENT SIGNIFICANT HEALTH AND
SAFETY RESTORE PATIENTS AND
STAFF AND THOSE OCCUPIED
BUILDINGS. I GUESS H. HAS
CONDUCTED A CURRENT NEEDS
IDENTIFICATION PRIORITIZATION
OF ALL SPECIAL REPAIR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS ARE
REQUIRED TO ADDRESS A MAJOR
BUILDING I REPAIRS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. ARE THE
AMOUNT REQUESTED TAKES INTO
CONSIDERATION DSHS ANALYSIS AND
PRIORITIZATION OF THE NEEDED
PROJECTS AS WELL AS CONSIDERS
WHAT MAY BE REALISTIC TWO INCH
TO ACHIEVE ON TOP OF. ALL OF
OUR OTHER EXISTING.
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CAPITAL
OUTLAY RELATED PROJECTS I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HELLO. NO
COMMENTS ON THIS ITEM MANAGER.
TELLS ARE NOTHING NOBODY LIKE
TO SPEND MONEY BUT WE ALL KNOW
THAT IF WE DON'T KEEP P THESE
BUILDINGS. WE HAVE- HEADLINES
THAT NOBODY WANTS TO SEE LATER
ON WHEN PEOPLE ARE BEING KEPT
IN. INHUMANE HOUSING OKAY THANK
YOU- AND THEN. NUMBER ELEVEN
NON RESTORE BILL INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL PATIENTS. IT FOR
THIS ITEM THE DEPARTMENT IS
PROPOSING TRAILER BILL
LEGISLATION TO REQUIRE THAT NON
RESTORE WILL INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL DEFENDANTS FOR WHOM
THE DEPARTMENT HAS FILED A
REPORT TO THE COURT. THAT THERE
IS NO SUBSTANTIAL LIKELIHOOD
THAT THE INDIVIDUAL WILL REGAIN
COMPETENCY OR WHO HAVE REACHED
THEIR MAXIMUM- I S. T. TERM OF
COMMITMENT TO THE DEPARTMENT BE
RETURNED TO THE CUSTODY OF THE
COUNTY WITHIN TEN DAYS. AND IF
THE PATIENT IS NOT RETURNED TO
THE CUSTODY OF THE COUNTY
WITHIN TEN DAYS AUTHORIZED THE
DEPARTMENT TO CHARGE THE COUNTY
AND DAILY BED RATE AS IT IS
CURRENTLY AUTHORIZED TO DO FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE RESTORED TO
COMPETENCY BUT REMAIN IN INDIA
S. H. BETTER AFTER TEN GAMES.
CURRENTLY THERE IS SOME
AMBIGUITY IN THE STATUTE AS TO
WHAT IS TO OCCUR AFTER AN
INDIVIDUAL IS DEEMED NON
RESTORE MALL OR REACHES MAX
COMMITMENT IN DIFFERENT
COMPORTS HAVE INTERPRETED THE
STATUTE DIFFERENTLY. THE
STATUTE CURRENTLY REQUIRES THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE NO
SUBSTANTIAL LIKELIHOOD ARE TO
BE RETURNED TO COURT WITHIN TEN
DAYS HOWEVER THERE IS NOT
AUTHORITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
CHARGE THE DAILY BED RATE IF
THEY REMAIN OVER TEN DAYS AS
CURRENTLY EXISTING STATUTE OR
INDIVIDUALS RESTORED TO
COMPETENCY. ADDITIONALLY SOME
COURTS INTERPRET THAT AFTER
BEING RETURNED TO COURT THE
INDIVIDUAL CAN BE RETURNED TO
THE DEPARTMENT OR REMAIN AT THE
S. H. FUNDING THERE
CONSERVATORSHIP INVESTIGATION.
I THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE DEEMED UNLIKELY TO REGAIN
COMPETENCY AND THERE REMAINED
AND THE DSA SPENT LONGER THAN
TEN DAYS HAS GROWN BY 12100%
FROM TWENTY FOUR IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN. TO THREE HUNDRED
THIRTEEN AND TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY WHEN A NON RESTORE WELL
I. S. T. REMAINS IN A STATE
HOSPITAL BED IT. PREVENTS THE
DEPARTMENT FROM ADMITTING NEW
IC PATIENTS ARE AWAITING
TREATMENT. SO THIS STATUTORY
CHANGE IS NECESSARY TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN MAXIMIZE THE
UTILITY LOOKING UTILIZATION OF
OUR BED CAPACITY FOR ICE TEA
TREATMENT. TO ADDRESS. THE ON
GOING MEATLESS FOR ISPS. I
THINK WITH MY TEST AND HOW. TO
TAKE ANY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF
NOTE NO FURTHER COMMENTS ON
THIS ITEM BEYOND THE POINTS WE
RAISED EARLIER ON SORT OF THE
UNCLEAR NATURE OF WHAT COUNTY
CAPACITY WOULD BE TO TAKE ON
ADDITIONAL PATIENTS AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AS- DIRECTOR HOPE. WHAT
WHAT WHAT KIND OF NUMBER WE
TALKING ABOUT OF THESE FOLKS.
SO WE HAVE ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
THIRTEEN IN NINETEEN TWENTY OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE ON
RESTORE HERBAL. ABOUT SEVENTY
THINK IT'S SEVENTY FIVE OF
THEM. ULTIMATELY STAYED IN A
HOSPITAL BED AND BECAME BEEN
CONVERTED TO LPS THE REST OF
THEM WOULD HAVE GONE BACK TO
THE COUNTY. AND EVENTUALLY BUT
THE SEVENTY THREE OR THE
SOMEBODY FIND THAT CONVERTED
AND ALSO CREATES AN ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGE FIRST BECAUSE- THEY
STAY IN A BAD- SO THERE YOU
TYPE THE I. S. T. BAD DURING.
THE COURSE OF THE TIME THAT
THEY'RE GOING THROUGH THEIR
CONSERVATORSHIP. HEARING BUT
THEN WHEN THEY CONVERT TO LPS
BASED AND THEN ARE IN THAT BED
AND IF WE DON'T HAVE AN LPS BED
AVAILABLE THEY STAY IN THE I.
S. T. BAD. I'M IN THE BY PASS
THE I. S. T. WAIT LIST SO THAT
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY HAVE
BEEN ON THE WAIT LIST- AREN'T
GETTING IN FOR LPS TREATMENT
EITHER BECAUSE THEY'RE JUST
STANDING BY PASSING THAT WAIT
LIST SO IT CREATES A-
UTILIZATION CHALLENGE FOR BOTH
R. I. S. T. IS AN HONOR LPS
WEAKNESS. PEOPLE WITH THE
GENDER THE MIX IS ANA- I KNOW I
DON'T WANT CENTER ADD. I DON'T
HAVE ANY DATA ON THAT COUNTY AT
THE MOMENT BUT I CAN CERTAINLY
CALLS AND CALL BACK AND GET
BACK TO YOU I WOULD JUST BE TO
SOMEONE WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
CHALLENGES OF THE COUNTY I'M
JUST THINKING IS IT IS IT
MAJORITY MALE DEMOGRAPHIC IS
AT. THE HEART FOR THE FOLKS AT
THE END APPEARS IT MORE MORE
WOMEN WHO WHO ARE THESE- DIESEL
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT- SO WE
GET SOME MORE INFORMATION ON
THAT AND THEN YEAH WE WOULD
JUST TO. CONTINUE TO RAISE THE
CONCERNS ABOUT IS THE COUNTY
PREPARED- IN IS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE YET
BEFORE WE SEND PEOPLE BACK OUT
BUT- WE CERTAINLY. APPRECIATE
YOUR- YOUR DILEMMA WITH THE
BILL TO COURT CASES AND
EVERYTHING PENDING AND THE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO MAXIMIZE YOUR
RESOURCES WE APPRECIATE THAT-
BUT CERTAINLY HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE VIABILITY.
OF THIS PLAN IN KEEPING
EVERYBODY SAFE AND CARED FOR.
OKAY SO THAT IS THE END OF ALL
OF THE BUDGET ITEMS NOW I
WOULD- I WOULD ASK THE
MODERATOR IF THEY ARE THERE AND
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE IN THE
QUEUE I WILL PROBABLY TAKE.
ABOUT A TWO MINUTE RECESS
BEFORE WE START WITH PUBLIC
COMMENTS MODERATOR YEAR. I SURE
AM AND YOU HAVE- I WOULD SAY-
CALDERON TWENTY PEOPLE QUEUED
UP SO FAR OKAY. I WILL ADMIT
DECLARE EIGHTY AT RECESS FOR
THE NEXT TWO MINUTES AND THEN
WE WILL RETURN. THANK YOU.
SURE
ARE ALL RIGHT LET'S ROLL. OKAY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT IS- MADAM CHAIRS UP FOR
ALL THE TOPICS TODAY THAT WOULD
BE FOR ALL THE TOPICS YES YES
ITEMS ONE THROUGH WHATEVER MANY
WE DID THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING.
OKAY AND AGAIN TO SHOW YOUR
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR ANY OF THE
ITEMS I TALKED ABOUT TODAY
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. I'M NOT GOING TO GIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE OF
PLACE YOU BACK IN TE QUEUE AND
WE WILL BEGIN TODAY WITH WIND
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU ATTITUDE IS TAXING BURKE
WITH THE HEALTH OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. NOT
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE ANY INVESTMENT AND LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. AND
WE APPRECIATE THE THREE MILLION
DOLLARS ANY BUT WE NEED TO
INVEST NOW. A STUDY WILL SHOW
US AND FINER POINTS AS DR PAN
MENTIONED BUT WE DON'T NEED A
STUDY TO KNOW THAT OUR LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE BEEN
UNDERFUNDED FOR YEARS IF NOT
DECADES. AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
COSPONSORING INVESTMENT GLOBAL
FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IN PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
THIS WILL IMPROVE LIVES TO
BUILD UP ROBUST PUBLIC HEALTH
STAFFING AND HELP CALIFORNIA
RESPONSE NOT JUST TO THE NEXT
PANDEMIC BUT ALSO TO OUR DAY TO
DAY HEALTH NEEDS LIKE STDS.
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH CHRONIC
DISEASE HEALTHEQUITY CALIFORNIA
CAN'T WAIT PLEASE INVESTED TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS NOW IN
THIS BUDGET YEAR THANK. YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK ONE GOING. THANK
YOU CENTER ADMIN AND GDS ON
BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA
COMMENTING ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ITEMS FIRST WE
SUPPORT ISSUE TEN THE CREATION
OF THE TASK FORCE ON
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE AND
PREVENTION AND THE FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS TO FUND THE CARE GIVER
TRAINING AND CERTIFICATION
PROGRAM. AND THEN LASTLY ON THE
PUBLIC HEALTH INVESTMENT WE
STRONGLY AGREE WITH DR I DON ON
THE NEED TO ENSURE OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE
SUFFICIENTLY RESOURCE FOR BOTH
SHORT TERM AND LONG TERM NEEDS
BUT WE DIFFER IN THE APPROACH
AND HOW TO ADDRESS IT NOW WE
ARE REALLY DISAPPOINTED THAT
THE MAYBE ELECTED NOT INCLUDE
ANY PUBLIC HEALTH.
INFRASTRUCTURE WORKFORCE
FUNDING INVESTMENT THAT COULD
BE USED NOW TO STOP UP OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT IN A
JULY ONE TO MEET THE NON CALL
THEY GET COURT PUBLIC HEALTH
ACTIVITIES THAT WE HAVE BEEN
PUT ASIDE DURING THE LAST YEAR
AND A HALF. WE WERE CUT OUT WE
SUPPORTED ASSESSMENT BY AGAIN
WE WOULD REQUEST THE SENATE
INCLUDE R. TWO HUNDRED MILLION
ONGOING REQUEST IN YOUR
PROPOSED BUDGET ALONGSIDE THE
CALIFORNIA CAN'T WAIT COALITION
AND WE THANK YOU SENATORS
EGGMAN AND. CANCEL YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND THIS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MEXICO PLEASE. THANK
YOU LIKE THIRTY PLEASE AHEAD
YOUR- THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
JEFF HAMPTON THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMENT TODAY WE WOULD LIKE
TO SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS OUR
COMMENT ON ISSUE ONE HUNDRED
THAT THE MHC I RELATED TO THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIOR
HEALTH INITIATIVE. HEALTH PLANS
ARE KEENLY AWARE OF THE TOLD
THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAPPENED
ALL MENTAL HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF CALIFORNIANS- BUT THIS
IS PARTICULARLY TRUE FOR
CHILDREN. WE ARE STILL
REVIEWING THE DEPARTMENT
MANAGED HEALTHCARE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE REQUIRING KNOCKING
LICENSE HEALTH PLANS TO
REIMBURSE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES PROVIDED SCHOOL
SETTING REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THE PROVIDER- THE PROVIDERS FOR
THE PLANNED CONTRACTED PROVIDER
NETWORK. BUT WE DO HAVE SOME
INITIAL CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL IN ORDER TO SEE HOW
THE PROPOSAL ADDRESSES THE
VARIOUS DYNAMIC BETWEEN ALL
STAKEHOLDERS NOW WE WILL WORK
TOGETHER TO ENSURE CLEAR
PRACTICAL DELIVERABLES ARE
OUTLINED TO THE FACT THAT WE
DELIVER PAYER HEALTH SERVICES.
FINANCIALLY SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT WE ASKED EARLIER
THIS YEAR IN REGARDS THE SENATE
BILL FIVE OH EIGHT WHICH WOULD
HAVE SIMILARLY REQUIRED HEALTH
PLANS TO REIMBURSE PAYER HEALTH
SERVICES PROVIDED GOAL SETTING
AGAIN CATHOLIC SCORED FIFTEEN
ADDITIONAL DETAIL- AND HAVING
THE DISCUSSION THOSE IN THE
FORWARD THANK. YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THIRTY FIVE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS WHO SHALL GIVE
BUT THAT HELPING THE DISEASE
ACCOUNT LESS LOCAL INTERSTATE I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT
FOCUSED ON THE NEED FOR FUNDING
PUBLIC HEALTH WE WANT TO ECHO
SENATOR FANS CONCERNED ABOUT
LEADING ANOTHER YEAR CAN'T BACK
IN OKLAHOMA DEPARTMENT COULD BE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
CONTRACT. WE DO NOT KNOW
WHETHER PUBLIC HEALTH
CHALLENGES THAT WE DEFINITELY
NEXT YEAR BUT WE DO KNOW THAT
WILL HAVE ONGOING
RESPONSIBILITIES RELATED TO
KOBE AND THE COMBINATION HAS
EXACERBATED AT PUBLIC HEALTH
CHALLENGES THAT EXISTED PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC SUCH AS THAT
RATE WILL KEEP YOU THE BEST YOU
NEED OTHER DISEASES THAT ARE
GOING UNDETECTED. AND WE
SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION
PANDEMIC RESPONSE OR DELAYED
THE PASSING THE CURRENT
LANDSCAPE AND THE NEED THEIR
TITLE BUT THAT SHOULD NOT DELAY
IN INVESTMENT INTO LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT WORKFORCE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE NOW SENATOR PAN
STATED WE KNOW THAT THERE'S
NEED. FOR QUITE SOME TIME AND
WE APPRECIATE THE SENATE
SUPPORT PRAYER FOR INVESTING IN
PUBLIC HEALTH AND WE ASK THAT
YOU PLEASE SUPPORT OUR CALGARY
CAN'T WAIT COALITION BUDGET
REQUEST FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION
ANNUALLY BY LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT REQUESTED FOR
STRUCTURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
I'M TWENTY YOUR- I TWENTY SIX
PLEASE ON MUTE. WE CAN ONLY
LOOK GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE CAN YOU HEAR
ME NOW YES WE CAN. SORRY ABOUT
THAT AND THIS IS DOCTOR TO
MUMBAI VENUE BY TYPING DIRECTOR
FOR SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY CLINIC
I WANT TO SPEAK ON HE SUBJECT
OF A MUTUAL DENTAL MANAGED CARE
I HAVE WORKED WITH DATA
MANAGEMENT FOR MORE THAN A
DECADE AND I WANT TO CREATE
SHARES COME UP MY TALKING WITH
THE INTO BROKEN WITHIN
SHRINKING MANAGED CARE TO
TRANSITION TO PROVIDE THIS
WHICH IS IMPORTANT PROGRAM
COULD YOU CARE. AND WANT TO
PROGRESS OF THE PATIENT IT ALSO
ENABLES US PROVIDERS. TO
INTEGRATE INFORMATION. ADDITION
OUT. INCIDENT THAT. I'M MORE
THE NEW YORKER WON TWENTY
PROVIDE RELEASED. MIGHT TO GET
HAS ALL TO ME REFERENCE FASHION
QUITE. BIJAN WILL FISHING
OFFICE ON OWN BONTA IT COULD
MONTHS BIG GET GORDON'S TO BE
THREE BY SPECIALIST HOWEVER AND
CAN MANAGE CAMPAIGN THE MOST
CLOSE TO HOME AFTER. THE END OF
DONE THIS IS A BIG TO POLICE
WHO DON'T HAVE TO DEAL WITH
HOSPITAL ACCORDING AROUND
LOOKING FOR. OFFICE. I KNOW
THAT THEIR WHICH COULD HAVE A
GROUP HELP TO A PATIENTS
POPULATION. THANK FOR YOUR TIME
ON THE OFFICE TO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CALLER PLEASE. THE
LITTLE LINE FOURTEEN GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND ROUTE GOING TO OF
THE FOR FIVE WOULD TRIP TE FOR
FIVE CAL COMMISSION BLOCK
COUNTY I'M SPEAKING I BMH ISSUE
MD PHD ISSUE NINE REGARDING THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIOR
HEALTH INITIATIVE. FIVE A
PROBLEM THE PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF
INDIVIDUALS AGES ZERO TO TWENTY
FIVE ESPECIALLY THE CREATION OF
THE DYADIC CARE BENEFIT HOWEVER
VERY LITTLE ATTENTION IS GIVEN
TOWARDS CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE
OF FIVE. CHILDREN MENTAL
CONCERN DO NOT STARTING
KINDERGARTEN AND CHILDREN CARED
CHILD CARE DEVELOPMENT EXPERTS
PREDICT A WAVE OF SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS WILL EMERGE. FROM THE
DRAMATIC IMPACT THE PANDEMIC.
ON HOLISTIC ã IS NEEDED AND
WE ARE REQUESTING THAT ONE
HUNDRED TWELVE MILLION OVER
THREE YEARS. FROM THE FINISH
AND BE DEBT DEDICATED TO EXPAND
DIRECT ACCESS TO EARLY
CHILDHOOD. MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM IS IN NON CRITICAL
SETTING. SUCH APPROACHES LOOK
FOR BOTH YOUNG CHILDREN AND THE
ADULTS IN THEIR LIVES TO DATE
AND HELP ADDRESS THE TOWN THE
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC. AS MORE
DETAILS EMERGE FIRST FIVE IS A
PARTNER IN RESOURCE ENSURING
THIS CRITICAL INITIATIVE
REACHES OUR YOUNGEST CHILDREN.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE COMMENT TODAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWENTY FOUR YOU ARE
OPEN. THANK YOU IN THE MORNING
MANJERI COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
ONE OF THE FOLLOWING ON THE
HAPPENED ACCESS DENTAL IN
OPPOSITION TO THE NEW REVISED
PROPOSAL TO RESTORE THAT
HEALTHY PERSPECTIVE SACRAMENTO
AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY WOMAN
NEEDING DENTAL MANAGED CARE
COUNTY WILL DISRUPT ACCESS T
CARE FOR MEDI CAL ENROLLEES WHO
WILL NO LONGER HAVE ACCESS TO
MANY OF THE DIRECTLY PROVIDED
BY THE PLAN. THANK YOU
TRANSPORTATION. ACTUALLY I
THINK THAT'LL BE CARE AND MANY
OTHER. THEY'RE NOT PROVIDING
FOR A PERCENT. FEDERAL DEEPER
SERVICE BE NO IN FINDING IT AN
EXTRA SEE THEM. MICHAEL TO
REALLY WOULD MEAN THE TWENTY
CREE QUE. PRETTY REASONABLE
RESPECTFULLY ASK ME TO REJECT
PROPOSED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALL PLEASE.
NINE FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING I'M TOM
BROOKS I WILL SPEAKING ON TO
EITHER FIRST ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES A CALIFORNIA THE
VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO ADOPT TWO HUNDRED MILLION AN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE IMMEDIATELY WE
CAN DO BOTH INVEST NOW AND DO A
STUDY TO DETERMINE ADDITIONAL
NEEDS. THANK YOU TO SENATOR PAN
ENTER EGGMAN FOR YOUR ADVOCACY
ON THIS ISSUE NEXT ON ISSUE
FIVE UNDERSTOOD HOSPITALS THE
URBAN COUNTY THE CALIFORNIA
DON'T THINK THE PROPOSAL. TO
STOP AND TAKE IN RELIEF.
NANOMETRICS SHORT CONSERVATIVE.
FROM THINK HOPE IS FEASIBLE TO
BE A- AS PROPOSED IN THE MAY
REVISION. WE DON'T HAVE THE
TIME OR CAPACITY TO DEVELOP A
REASONABLE RESOLUTION INCLUDING
PLACEMENT CAPACITY. WE ARE TO
THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO REJECT THE
PROPOSAL ADDITIONALLY I WOULD
NOTE THAT UCC HAS BEEN
PARTICIPATING IN CONVERSATIONS
ACCOUNTING REPRESENTATIVES IN
THE ADMINISTRATION I'M
DEVELOPING ALTERNATIVES TO THE
MAY REVISION LPS PROPOSAL. WE
ARE HOPEFUL THAT THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WILL BE A STEP
PLANTS EITHER UNDER EGGMAN
MENTIONED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FROM THE COLD MORTAL
MEN ON BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP COMMENTING ON THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE. EXPANDING
EARLY CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH
AND TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
INVESTMENTS IS CRITICAL. WE
BELIEVE THE IN ADDITION TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED INVESTMENTS
MADE IN EXPANDING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD WORKFORCE THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA INCLUSION AND
BEHAVIORAL CONSULTATION
NETWORK. AND INCREASED
INVESTMENTS IN THE DYADIC CARE
AND FAMILY THERAPY BENEFITS
THERE MUST BE MORE SPECIFIC
INVESTMENTS MADE IN SUPPORTING
THE SOCIO MAKING EMOTIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. AND TRAUMA
RESILIENCE FOR YOUNG CHILDREN
BEFORE THEY DISPLAY CONCERNING
BEHAVIORS OR EXPERIENCE ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES INCLUDING
THE PANDEMIC. WHICH ACCUMULATES
ON THE DRAFT TO COALESCE INTO.
LONG TERM TOXIC STRETCH. I CAN
RESPOND TO THE PAN MUST INVOLVE
ALL TRIAL WHOLE FAMILY WILL NOT
THE COACH THAT INCLUDES A FOCUS
ON EARLY CHILDHOOD PREVENTIVE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TWO
MILLION EIGHT THE POTENTIAL FOR
MENTAL HEALTH DIAGNOSES OR
CRISES LATER IN LIFE. AND
SYSTEMATIC ATTENTION TO THE
PREPARATION AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT OF OUR EARLY
CHILDHOOD WORKFORCE RESPOND
INCLUDING HOME VISITORS AND
OTHER FAMILY SERVICE PROVIDERS.
WE ARE ASKING THE LEGISLATURE
TO MAKING ONE HUNDRED TWELVE
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT AND
EARLY CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH
STRATEGIES IN NONCLINICAL
STARTING TO ENSURE SERVICES
LIKE EARLY CHILDHOOD MENTAL
HEALTH CONSULTATION AND TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE TRAINING FOR
SERVICE PROVIDERS IT REACHES
OUR YOUNGEST CALIFORNIANS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLOR
PLEASE. ONE FIFTY SIX YOU ARE
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON LINDA WAY
WOULD WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY REGARDING THE
ELIMINATION OF DENTAL MANAGED
CARE WE ARE NEUTRAL ON THE
PROPOSAL BUT WOULD WANT TO
ENSURE THAT TRANSITION PLAN
INCLUDE CONTINUITY OF CARE
PROTECTIONS WHICH EXIST ON THE
FEE FOR SERVICE AND MANAGED
CARE SIDE BUT NOT VICE VERSA
ADEQUATE PROVIDER CAPACITY IN
TIMELY AND TRANSLATED
BENEFICIARY NOTICES. THAT IT'S
BEEN REVIEWED BY THE COLDER'S
OR BENEFICIARY WE ALSO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY TRANSITION
EXPANSION CLEANUP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE THIRTY A PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. BERANEK DATING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA FIFTY
ONE FIFTY EIGHT OKAY I'M GOING
TO SPEAK BRIEFLY ON THREE
ISSUES- I'LL FOR ISSUE NUMBER
ONE AND ISSUE NUMBER NINE OF
THE CHILDREN'S AND YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE-
UNDER. THE NHC IN THE PH OF
QUESTIONS OF THE AGENDA WERE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
CHILDREN WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE- THE WORKFORCE
SUPPORTS WILL BE A GREAT DEAL
OF HELP TO COUNTIES AS WE WORK
SEND UP WITH INITIATIVE AND
WHILE THERE'S MANY MORE DETAILS
THAT NEED TO BE WORKED OUT-
WE'RE VERY VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THE PHONE BILLS IN THE MAIL
REVISION HOW ON- DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC ART AT DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH FORTY FIVE SIX. ISSUE
SIX SEVEN AND EIGHT I'M ALSO A
CLEAN OTHER COMPANY BROKE THE
PURGE FROM AS WELL AS THE ARE
YOU- IN THE HOPE OF SECURING
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ONGOING FUNDING FOR LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AS
PART OF THE CALIFORNIA CAN'T
WAIT THE COALITION- WE DO
SUPPORT THE THREE MILLION
DOLLARS- FOR THE ASSESSMENT BUT
AGAIN AS- MR BURKE FROM THE
HEALTH OFFICER SAID WE DON'T
NEED A STUDY. TO KNOW THAT OUR
HEALTH DEPARTMENT NEED FUNDING
NOW I WANT TO THANK YOU SENATOR
PAN AND SHARE EGGMAN FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS ISSUE HOW DID
YOU. FOUR FOUR FOUR ZERO THE
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS.
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE. THE WHEN
PITCHERS. PROPOSAL WHICH STRONG
OPPOSE FROM. THE STROKE. ARE L.
P. AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. WE DO
ALL FRIEND HIGH. HIGHER NEED
FOLKS TO THE THAT. IT IS- NEED
MORE EXPENSIVE ARE OF BOTH THE
MOST SECURE- AND SO COMPANIES
ARE NOT INCENTIVIZED TO SEND
FOLKS- TO THE PLACEMENT- IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT POINT BUT WITHIN
OUR COUNTRY ALL AND WE- OPPOSE
THE PROPOSAL. AND WE ARE AS
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY WITHOUT
IN. CONVERSATIONS WITH DIRECTOR
CLINTON AND HER STAFF. ABOUT
HOW CAMP YOU CAN BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION. FOR A LESSENING THE
ISP WEIGHTLESS- AND HELPING THE
STATE OUT- AS THEY FACE LEGAL
ACTION IN THE AREA WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING ON A PLAN.
TOGETHER BUT AGAIN LET'S
RESPECTFULLY OUTRIGHT OPPOSED
THE LPS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FINALLY TO
YOU ARE ON. FINALLY HAVE.
INVESTMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL YOU NEED TO
REJECT THE PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE DENTAL MANAGED CARE
HUNDREDS OF OUR MEMBERS HEALTH
SERVICES PROGRAM WE DON'T
BELIEVE THE ELIMINATION LOOK
SAVE MONEY ARE ENSURE BETTER
DENTAL CARE FOR OUR NEEDIEST
RESIDENTS WHAT IT WILL DO IS
ENSURE THAT KIDS IN SACRAMENTO
AND LOS ANGELES GO WITHOUT
CRITICAL DENTAL CARE AND
JEOPARDIZE HUNDREDS OF GOOD
UNION JOBS. URGING REJECT THE
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE FIFTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CORRECT ALSO
PER ON BEHALF OF APLE HELD A
MOCK ANGELA THAN ANY EPIDEMIC-
THE WHITE COALITION OF OVER ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION. UNDER ISSUE ONE
THE PORT THAT TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE REGARDING THE STATE.
GRAHAM WE ALSO SUPPORT ISSUE
EIGHT REGARDING PANDEMIC
RESPONSE RUBIO. HOWEVER I'D
LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM
MY PUBLIC HEALTH COLLEAGUES
ABOUT THE NEED TO WIN BACK THIS
YEAR. TO SUPPORT THE STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
AND ADDRESS THE GROWING AND-
ACTIVE HIV STI VIRAL HEPATITIS
AND OVERDUBS. B. THAT THE
DEMOCRATS WERE ALREADY RAGING
OUT OF CONTROL BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC AND THEY'VE NOW GROWN
EVEN WORSE. PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
FOCUSED ON THE KOBE RESPOND
THANK YOU YOU HAVE LIMITED
ACCESS TO SERVICES. WE SIMPLY
CANNOT WAIT UNTIL NEXT YEAR TO
MAKE THE INVESTMENTS THAT WE
KNOW ARE NEEDED NOW TO GET A
HANDLE ON HIS GROWING CRISES. I
ALSO JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
WHILE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
REQUEST FROM G. ACT AND OTHERS.
THAT BINDING WILL PRIMARILY
SUPPORT WORKFORCE INVESTMENT
THAN WE MUST REMEMBER THAT YOU
NEED BASED ORGANIZATION. REMAIN
A CRITICAL COMPONENT OF OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE. THERE
ON THE FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE WE
MUST TRUSTED PARTNERS FOR
BOULDER GOING UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. BUT JUST ONE
EXAMPLE THE STATE'S NETWORK OF
SYRINGE SERVICE PROGRAMS
PROVIDE LIFESAVING SERVICES. TO
PEOPLE WHO USE DRUGS AND THEY
ARE CURRENTLY BEING FORCED TO
RATION SUPPLIES. BECAUSE THEY
HAD FAILED TO INCREASE FUNDING
TO MEET THE GROWING DEMAND FOR
SERVICES. WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT
INVESTMENTS FROM THE AND THE
EFFORT THAT MAKE COALITION TO
ENSURE THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. THE RESOURCES
THEY NEED. I'D LIKE TO SERVER
THAT THE PEOPLE ACT BY EACH
IDEA YEAH I HAVE PREPARED OVER
THE- WE ALSO- URGE THE LARGEST.
TO ENSURE THE YOU NEED ORGAN.
ARE INCLUDE. IN THE STATE
DEMOCRATS FROM AT ANY FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH INVESTMENT. WE
BELIEVE IT WOULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT OVERSIGHT CONDUCT
REVIEW OF THE STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE. AND NOW
I COULD GO THERE THE VITAL.
ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDING
SERVICES THE STATE'S MOST
VULNERABLE. AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COLOR PLAY. FIND
FORTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CARE EGGMAN IN MEMBERS
STACY ERA MODEL THE DIRECTOR OF
RAM COAL THE RACIAL AND ETHNIC
MENTAL HEALTH DISPARITIES
COALITION I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT TODAY
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT THERE
WERE IMPORTANT ITEMS LEFT OUT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S NEWLY REVISED
AMONG THEM IN AND IN PARTICULAR
THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT. OR THE C.
R. D. P. THANK YOU FOR
MENTIONING THIS SENATOR THE C.
R. D. P. IS ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ALTHOUGH THERE HAS BEEN A LOT
OF DISCUSSION ABOUT HEALTH
DISPARITIES AND SERVING
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY IN THE LIGHT OF THE
DEVASTATION THAT COLBERT.
PANDEMIC HAS BROUGHT UPON THESE
COMMUNITIES IT IS AMAZING HOW
THE SUSTAINABILITY AND
EXPANSION OF THE SECURITY HE
WAS NOT IN THE MAIN REVISED WE
ASK THAT THIS COMMITTEE
PRIORITIZE AN ADVOCATE SO THAT
THIS PROJECT IS FUNDED THROUGH
THE BUDGET AT THE LEVEL THAT WE
ALONG WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
AND DOZENS OF OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE REQUESTED.
THE INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS IN THE
C. R. D. P. ARE CURRENTLY
PROVIDING VALUABLE SERVICES IN
RESPONSE TO CALL THAT AS WELL
AS PROVIDING EARLY INTERVENTION
SERVICES TO ADDRESS THE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS OF RACIAL ETHNIC
AND LGBTQ COMMUNITIES ALL OVER
THE STATE MOREOVER THESE
INDIVIDUAL PILOT PROJECTS OR
IDPS WILL SERVE AS THE MODEL
FOR SIMILAR PROJECTS THAT COULD
BE SET UP AND EFFECTIVELY SERVE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IN
EVERY COUNTY IN THE STATE.
THANK YOU AGAIN TO THE CHAIR
AND DR PAN FOR KNOWLEDGE IN
THIS AND WE HOPE THAT IT
REMAINS. IN THE FINAL BUDGET
NEGOTIATED. YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
PLEASE. ONE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AT. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS TYLER IN THE ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH RECORDS OF THEIR
CREATION WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
EXPRESS OPPOSITION ITEM NUMBER
FIVE UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS TO DISCONTINUE
ALBEIT FISHING CONTRACTS WITH
COUNTY UNDER THIS PROPOSAL THE
STATE INTENDS TO RETURN SEVEN
HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT ALPS GOT
CONSERVANCY THE COUNTY OVER THE
NEXT THREE YEARS IN ORDER TO
MAKE THAT MORE I ASK EACH AND-
THE POPULATION- I- ALBEIT
CONSERVATIVE EITHER HI WE BONE
HERBAL MEDICALLY COMPLEX. IN
SOME CASES THE THING THAT THEY
CAN PRACTICE PUBLIC SPEAKING
WITH THE DOCTOR BEEN BALK
MEANT- HISTORY EITHER SOME OF
THE MOST DIFFICULT INDIVIDUAL
TO SERVE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
ARE PLACED IN THE HOSPITAL
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT ADEQUATELY
AND PRETTY FUNDAMENTAL
CLINICALLY IT WOULD BE
DISASTROUS TO ADOPT THIS
PROPOSAL ON CURRENT THE CURRENT
TIMELINE TO TRANSLATION TEACHER
AT. A LOCAL LEVEL ABOUT THE
PATIENT AND FOR COMMUNITIES
WITH ADDICT WITHOUT ADEQUATE
AND APPROPRIATE PLACEMENT
AVAILABLE WITHOUT APPROPRIATE
CAPACITY IT IS LIKELY THAT SOME
OF THESE INDIVIDUALS MAY
EXPERIENCE HOW MUCH MATH AND
MAY END UP IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND ON THE AYE
IT YOU WAIT LET THE THEME
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FALL FOR COUNTIES ARE WORKING
ON. YOU KNOW AND MEETING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ON FEEDING
COUNTY PARTNERSHIPS THAT BUILD
UP THE CAPACITY TO STIR UP ALL
YOU WANT THE I. AND WHEN I ASK
YOU TO THE LOCAL LEVEL WITHOUT
COMPROMISING OUR DISTINCTIVE
PROPERTIES IN THE POPULATION
THAT WE ARE TODAY AND
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION THE
GATES SAYS FIND A PLANNED YET
MENTIONED BY THE CHAIR THANK.
YOU THANK YOU NICE COLOR PLEASE.
FIND NINE PLEASE GO. HELLO MY
IS SHERRY MEMBERS MY NAME IS BE
FEDERAL GET I AM ONE THE
NONPROFIT HOW EDUCATION CAL NAY
SON THAT FROM I PROJECT THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING IMMIGRANT
INCLUDING FOR AND IF THROUGH IN.
A COURT OF THE CAL BECAUSE GET
PROJECT INTO COUNTY SEX YOLO
AND STANISLAUS PLASTER AND
OTHER PARTNERS ALONG WITH OUR
CONFLICT OUR PARTNER THE
CONSULATE GENERAL OF MEXICO IN
SACRAMENTO I'M THINKING TO
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL TO FIFTEEN
THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT YOU FIFTY
THREE POINT ONE MILLION IN ONE
TIME FUNDING CONNECTOR CLUSTER
THE GENERAL FUND OUR PROJECT
ALONG WITH ALL THE OF THE
PROJECT AND IF YOUR DP. HAVE
BEEN STRATEGICALLY LOCATED WITH
APPROPRIATE AND IMPACTFUL
STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS THE COOK
THE NINETEEN CRISIS AND ARE
PREPARED TO ADDRESS THE
CONTINUED MENTAL HEALTH IMPACT
OF THE PANDEMIC AND THE
STRUCTURAL BARRIERS THE GLOBAL
POPULATION RESEARCH THANK IN
ADDRESSING SERVICES THAT THE
COURT THEIR WELL BEING WE WANT
TO CONTINUE SUPPORTING THE WELL
BEING OF OUR HARD WORKING THANK
YOU KNOW IMMIGRANT. THAT OFTEN
CANNOT TAKE TIME OFF WORK ACT
SERVICES THAT ARE NOT DEFINED
YET CLASSICAL WE WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE PROVIDING TRUSTED
SERVICES THAT ARE CULTURALLY
AND LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE
INSIDE OF THE MEXICAN MEXICAN
CONSULATE IN OTHER TRUSTED
NONCLINICAL COMMUNITY LOCATION
PLEASE SUPPORT OUR WORK THANK
YOU SENATORS FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. PINE SEVENTY YOUR OPEN.
I'M SURE AND MEMBERS ARE HELLO
MY NAME'S ROLLING MORE I'M
CENTER OF PREVENT RESEARCH AND
BURKE. I'M ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING PROJECT AS REFER BY
NATURE THEM DR COUNTLESS
MORNING. I DIRECTLY TECHNICAL
PROVIDER TEAM FOR THE NATIVE
AMERICAN GRANT USED. I ALSO
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL FOR SIXTY
THREE POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
INTERESTING AND EXTEND THIS
YEAR FOUR FOUR MORE YEARS
ALTHOUGH SURPRISINGLY IT'S NOT
IN THE MAY REVISION. I WANTED
TO HIGHLIGHT THE RIGOROUS
EVALUATION THAT IS KEY TO THIS
EFFORT EXCUSE ME OF AMERICAN
RENT YOU SOMETHING SIR I'M
GONNA I'M GONNA I'M GONNA STOP
YOU THERE AND AS WE'RE WE STILL
HAVE A LOT OF CALLS IN THE
QUEUE. SO IF YOU ARE A MINUTE
ASK CALLERS GOING FORWARD NOW
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
REDUCING CALIFORNIA DISPARITIES
THAN JUST SAY THAT WITH YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION- AND THEN
WE WERE GOING TO START LIMITING
CALLS TO ONE MINUTE OKAY SO IF
YOU COULD WRAP UP AND THEN
WE'LL MOVE ON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I THE- SERVICE THE
SUPPORT FOR MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
OF BOTH RURAL AND URBAN-
INDIANS AND ALASKAN NATIVES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATORS FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. FIVE SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
SENATORS I'M TRACY WERE TRAINED
ON THE PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE
AND SPEAKING OF THE COSPONSORED
THE PROPOSAL FOR THE CREATION
OF A CALIFORNIA HEALTH EQUITY
FUND AND FOR THE BROADER FIVE
YEAR PACKAGE YES BUT WE NEEDED
INVESTMENT IN HEALTHEQUITY
RACIAL JUSTICE AND PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE. YEAR IN
AND YEAR OUT WE HAVE INCREASED
SPENDING FOR HEALTH CARE YET
MEDICAL SERVICES ARE ESTIMATED
TO AFFECT ONLY 10220% OF
MODIFIABLE HEALTH OUTCOMES THE
REMAINDER RESULTS FROM THE
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
INCLUDING STRUCTURAL RACISM
CALIFORNIA HEALTHEQUITY FUND IN
BROADER BUDGET PACKAGE WILL
PROVIDE SUPPORT TO ADDRESS
STRUCTURAL RACISM AND THE
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS BY
PROVIDING RESOURCES. TO
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING
NONPROFITS CLINICS TRIBAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IN AREAS THAT HAVE
BEEN HARDEST HIT BY COPING
NINETEEN I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH EQUITY
FUND. AND THE BROADER PACKAGE.
ALONG WITH INVESTMENT INCOME
HEALTH AND- THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
MIKE SIXTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE EGGMAN
BIRTH NAME MISTER GROUPS ARE
REPRESENTING THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION WE ARE APPRECIATIVE
AND SUPPORTIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION PACKAGE OF
PROPOSALS THAT BENEFIT THOSE
IMPACTED BY ALZHEIMER'S AND
WHILE WE DO CONTINUE WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR INCREASED
INVESTMENT PARTICULARLY WITHIN
FIVE IN COGNOS GREENSBURG
MATAGAL I'M SPEAKING TODAY ON
ISSUE TEN AND THE PERMANENT
HEALTH SUPPORT RALPH MEMBERS
WILL BE AWARENESS RESEARCH AND
TRAINING. EITHER PHENOMENAL
INVESTMENT PARTICIPATION FEES
ALZHEIMER'S THAT ABSOLUTELY A
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE THE GOAL
THE BUILDING AWARENESS THAT
ALZHEIMER'S NOT NORMAL AGING
AND HOPEFULLY CONNECTING PEOPLE
TO CRUCIAL RESOURCES AS WELL AS
THE DANCING AT THE MENTION OF
PACIFIC STANDARD OF CARE HE
CONTINUED WITH THE GREAT WORK
ACT EQUITY FOCUSED RESEARCH ARE
ALL LAUDABLE GOAL AND PROGRAMS
AS WELL AS THE DANTE IMPORTANT
WORK IN THE STATE AFTER PLAN
FOR AGING. WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE OPPOSITE PROPOSAL THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FIND TWO CALL. HOW
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR ALL YOUR HARD ON
THE YEAR'S BUDGET AND I. THE
GOVERNOR FOR WORKING ON
GENERATING EQUITY IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET MY NAME IS VALUE
KEEN ON SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE THAT THE PROJECT
CALIFORNIA- AND IF ANYTHING I
JUST WANNA QUICKLY UP. WITH
WHAT- THE DISCUSSION EARLIER I
WENT. AND ABOUT TALKING ABOUT
WINNING YEAR AND- A PUBLIC
<c.red>EALTH INFRASTRUCTURE WITH</c>
MESSAGING I'M LOOKING AT THE
TEMPORARY FUNDING- AND WITH
THAT WE ARE THE ONE UP WITH. A
BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT WE'VE- IN
BEEN GAUGING WITH LEGISLATURE
OF WHAT HAPPENED TO ALL THE
QUESTIONS THAT HE RAISED- AND
USUALLY TARGETING EXACTLY WHAT
HE WAS. TALKING ABOUT WITH THE
DISCUSSION WAS EARLIER. ON THE
CAN HELP. TO RECOVER FROM THE
PANDEMIC OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES LOW INCOME
INTRIGUED COLOR BLACK ONE OF
THE BETTER STRONGER AND MORE
RESILIENT THE BEFORE- THE
GOVERNOR'S REVISED COULD BUDGET
CAN GO FURTHER BY TARGETING
FUND YOU COUNTY. ORGANIZATIONS
WORKING HOW DID MESSENGERS
INCOMING NINETEEN HOT SPOT. AND
HIGHLY IMPACTED COMMUNITY THANK
YOU ARE YOU OUR ATHLETES BIRTH
WHAT YEAH YOU'RE SORRY THAT.
WILL FORWARD READ YEAH THE
MEMBERS THANK YOUNG THANK YOU
MUCH NEXT. CALLER PLEASE.
SEVENTY FOUR EURO. YES MADAM
ANOTHER MEMBERS OF THE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TO THE HEALTH AND
WELLNESS CALIFORNIA MY IS TOM
YOUNG THE I AM C. L. L. BLACK
HEALTH PROJECT WERE ARMED. IT'S
A HOW AND WELLNESS FOR THE DAY
ONE POINT TWO MILLION WOMEN AND
GIRLS AND WE ARE FULLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE EXTENSION OF THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITY
PROJECT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
KAREN MEMBERS DORIAN GREW ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION HERE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL EACH THE AT ISSUE
NUMBER ONE THE PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE THE TWENTY FIVE YEAR
OLD FAILING DENTAL MANAGED CARE
PILOT IN ATLANTA SACRAMENTO AND
TRANSITION BACK TO PAY FOR
SERVICE. DURING JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THERE HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT IN THE
DATA HEALTH PROGRAM OVER THE
PAST FIVE YEARS AND YET NEARLY
ONE MILLION RESIDENTS 7% OF
TOTAL BENEFICIARY FOR STOCK IN
IT INTERIOR SYSTEM THAT IS
ACTUALLY EXACERBATING HEALTH
DISPARITIES. M. PLANS UNDER THE
RESTOF THE STATE IN EVERY
SINGLE METRIC USED TO MEASURE
ORAL HEALTH IN THE STATE.
DESPITE THEIR MANY INVESTMENT
IN YOUR COORDINATION PATIENT
NAVIGATION AND OTHER SERVICES
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE TO BACK UP
CLAIMS THAT QUALITY IS BETTER
COMPARED TO FOR SERVICE. IN
FACT THERE'S NO EXPLANATION FOR
WHY UTILIZATION SO MUCH LOWER
IN THE EMPTY EXCEPT FOR THE
DELIVERY SYSTEM. CAL NEEDS TO
MAKE THESE CHANGES TO EQUALIZE
IMPROVEMENTS MADE IN CHINA
KALLIKRATIS DATE AND DELIVER
MORE CONSISTENT PROGRAM. ABA
HAVE ENGAGED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT IN DEVELOPING THEIR
TRANSITION PLANS. NATION OF THE-
THANK VERY MUCH NICE COLLEAGUES.
SEVENTY FIVE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ROBERT
CAMPBELL AND I'M WITH THE LOS
ANGELES LGBT CENTER AND A
MEMBER OF BEGAN YESTERDAY THE
COALITION THE KEVIN I THINK
TEND TO MAKE HIGHLIGHTED THE
FACT THAT OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE WAS ALREADY
INSUFFICIENT ARTICLE IN AND
CREE COVE IT CALIFORNIA'S
EXPERIENCE MAJOR CRISIS IN HIV
VIRAL HEPATITIS SB I WENT OVER.
EPIDEMIC IS ONLY MADE ALL OF
THE VICTIMS WORSE FURTHER
EXPOSING DECADES OF HEALTH
INEQUITIES DRIVEN BY CHRONIC
UNDERFUNDING IT INCREASES WE
MUST INVEST NOW TO ENSURE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
MAINTAIN CRITICAL SERVICE ALL
OF THE COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY
THOSE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY HELP WHAT. WE NEED
TO MEET THE MOMENTS NOW BIKE
THAT BEGIN THE EPIDEMIC BUDGET
REQUEST AND ALL OTHER PUBLIC
HEALTH INVESTMENT THEY WILL
ENSURE THAT THEY. NOT THIS FOR
THE GROUND. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER. ONE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE ADD. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
FILLED KATHY AND ACT HOW AND WE
ARE ASK WITH COMMON ABOUT THE
TO AND IN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ADDRESS OUR
OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH NEEDS TO
HAVE BEEN DEFERRED AND ARE
BEING COMPOUNDED BY COLD IN AND
THE CHRONIC UNDERFUNDING OF OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM AND BASS
ILLUSTRATED BY THE RAPID RISE
OF SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED
INFECTION RATE THAT WERE
ALREADY SKYROCKETING. UP PRIOR
TO HOLD IT THE LATEST NUMBERS
FROM TWENTY NINETEEN SHOW THAT
ACTUALLY IRATE INCREASED FOR
THE SIXTH YEAR IN A ROW AND
WE'RE LIKELY HIGHER FOR TWENTY
TWENTY UNDER THE CALL THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY THE
COST OF INACTION IS FAR TOO
GREAT TO CONTINUE IGNORING AND
ALTHOUGH ALL COMMUNITIES ARE
BEING AFFECTED BY THE STI
CRISIS IT IS CALIFORNIA YOU.
BLACK INDIGENOUS AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND LGBT COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
THIS IS A SOCIAL JUSTICE PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUE THAT MUST BE
ADDRESSED IMMEDIATELY AND SO WE
ARE THE LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL SUBMITTED
BY THE END THE EPIDEMIC
COALITION. AS WELL AS ALL THE
OTHER. THANK YOU VERY LATEST
INVESTING IN PUBLIC. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT COURT CALLER.
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS CAROLINE
TRIPADVISOR IS ON BEHALF OF
LIBERTY DENTAL PLAN ONE OF THE
STATE'S CONTRACTED PLANS IN
SACRAMENTO AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTIES WERE OPPOSED TO THE
PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE DENTAL
MANAGED CARE AND JUST WANT TO
RESPOND. TO TWO OUT TWO OF THE
RIVER TWO THINGS THAT WERE SAID
TODAY ONE RELATIVE TO THE
COMMENTS IN MANAGED CARE
PERFORMANCE LAGS BEHIND B. FOR
SERVCE THE INPUT INTO
CALCULATING UTILIZATION UNDER
THE FOR SERVICE IN DENTAL
MANAGED CARE ARE NOT THE SAME
SO COMPARING THE TWO
NECESSARILY LEADS TO FLAWED
CONCLUSIONS IF YOU COMPARE LIKE
DATASETS UTILIZATION AND DENTAL
MANAGED CARE IS ON PAR WITH OR
HIGHER THAN PEOPLE SERVICE. AND
THEN SECOND RELATIVE TO THE
DEPARTMENT'S COMMENT THAT 87%
OF MANAGED CARE PROVIDERS ARE
ALREADY IN THE FEE FOR SERVICE
THAT'S THE DEPARTMENT
REQUIREMENT THAT OLE BMC
RENDERING PROVIDERS BE ENROLLED
IN P. FOR SERVICE SO IT'S NO
INDICATION OF A PROVIDER'S
WILLINGNESS TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE FEE FOR SERVICE PROGRAM AND
WE'VE ALREADY HEARD FROM DOZENS
OF PROVIDERS WHO SPECIFICALLY
SAID THEY WILL NOT PARTICIPATE
THE FOR SERVICE PROGRAM. FOR
THESE REASONS AND MANY OTHERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER.
WHY SEVENTY SO PER SKEWS ME
LIFE SO EIGHT PLEASE GOING SOME
EIGHT. HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE NOT
BALLOTS WITH THE LATINO
COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA FIRST WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
HELP ALL SENIORS AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT TO
EXPAND MEDICARE FOR ALL ADULTS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. NEXT WE'RE DISAPPOINTED
IN THE LACK OF INVESTMENT IN
THE MUSICIAN FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
SYSTEM INCLUDING DISTANCE YOU
ARE A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE ON THE
FRONTLINE- WE WANT TO VOICE
STRONG SUPPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO FIND RACIAL
JUSTICE AND HEALTH EQUITY
PROPOSALS SUCH AS THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH EQUITY FUNDS.
AND THE BROADER HEALTH EQUITY
INVESTMENT PACKAGE THAT WILL
FUND CEOS AS WELL AS LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT TO ADDRESS
THE SOCIAL. DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH. ARTICLE TO HELP OUR OF
OUR- AND LASTLY WE THAT YOU.
WITH PRODUCT BAND CAL PRESSURE.
CAN REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MEXICO PLEASE. TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS AUDREY AND I'M- WITH
THE RACIAL AND ETHNIC MENTAL
HEALTH PARITY COALITION AND I
JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT I
SUPPORT A ONE TIME FUNDING TO
SIXTY THREE POINT ONE MILLION
TO THE CALIFORNIA REDUCE.
OBJECT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
SEVENTY NINE YOUR OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS AND THANK ME- MY
GRANDMOTHER SHE HER AND HERS I
AM PART OF- REPEAT MY CENTER
I'M WORKING WITH THE CENTER FOR
SEXUALITY AND GENDER DIVERSITY-
AND WE'RE THE ONLY- THE ONLY
CENTER THAT ACTUALLY SUPPORTS-
LGBTQ PLUS A MENTAL HEALTH.
KERN COUNTY AND I SUPPORT THE
SIXTY THREE POINT ONE MILLION
ONE TIME FUNDING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WHY EIGHTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. EIGHTY THREE YOU ARE
OPEN. I AM VERY MUCH ON A WORD
ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL HARM
REDUCTION COALITION- EVEN
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA
WITH EXPERIENCING A MAJOR
CRISIS OF HIV HEPATITIS AFTER
UNITED AND OVERDOSE BLACK
INDIGENOUS AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
BY THE EPIDEMICS- OVERDOSED
CONTINUES TO BE THE LEADING
CAUSE OF ACCIDENTAL DEATH IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND MAYBE THAT THE
DEMOCRATS EVEN WORSE FURTHER
EXPOSING DECADES OF HEALTH
INEQUITIES DRIVEN BY CHRONIC
UNDERFUNDING AND BENAC RACISM.
WE SEE THIS CLEARLY IN THE
OVERDOSE DEATH RATES THAT ARE
HIGHEST AMONG NATIVE AND BLACK
CALIFORNIANS IN ORDER TO
PREVENT A DRAMATIC INCREASE IN
BOTH DISEASE BURDEN AND BECAUSE
WE MUST THE BEST NOW TO ENSURE
THAT LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO MAINTAIN
CRITICAL SERVICES OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND ASKING YOU TO
STRONGLY I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
AND THE EPIDEMIC BUDGET REQUEST
I'M ASKING YOU TO PLEASE
SUPPORT THESE AS WELL TO ENSURE
THAT THE STATE DOES NOT LOSE
FURTHER GROUND AND ADDRESSING
WITH THE CODE NINETEEN CRISIS
THANK. YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. EIGHTY FIVE
YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM INCOME MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SAY CALLING ON BEHALF OF GLIDE
IS A MEMBER OF THE IN THE
EPIDEMICS COALITION. HOUSE
SERVICES PROGRAM OPERATOR AND
COMMUNITY HEALTH CLUB IN SAN
FRANCISCO'S TENDERLOIN
NEIGHBORHOOD. BLIGHTED
IMPLEMENTED HARM REDUCTION
STRATEGIES SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF THE AIDS EPIDEMIC TO CURTAIL
THE SPREAD OF DISEASE AND
REDUCE STIGMA. FIRE TO THE KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA
WAS ALREADY FACED WITH
PERSISTENT CHALLENGES POSED BY
DRUG OVERDOSE HIV STI AND
HEPATITIS C. NOW THE SITUATION
IS TRAGICALLY WORSENED AND THE
NEED FOR ASSOCIATED SERVICES
HAS AMPLIFIED. OUR MOST
VULNERABLE NEIGHBORS AND LOVED
ONES PARTICULARLY BLACK
INDIGENOUS AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND THOSE ARE AT THE
INTERSECTION OF HOMELESSNESS
AND DRUG USE FOR EXPERIENCING
THE BRUNT OF THE CONSEQUENCES.
AND IT HAPPENING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WELL RIGHT NOW TO
MEET THE NEED GLIDE STRONGLY
SUPPORT IN THE EPIDEMIC'S
COALITION BUDGET REQUEST. THE
FIND KIND OF HARM REDUCTION
INTERVENTIONS IN FACT THE NEAR
EXTREMELY COST EFFECTIVE. NOW
IS THE TIME. TO SUPPORT THESE
EVIDENCE BASED APPROACHES
CALIFORNIA. CALGARY THANK YOU
VERY MCH MEXICO USUALLY SEEN A
STRONG COMMITMENT YOU'RE MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. EIGHTY SIX
YOU ARE OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME SEN DONNELLY
I'M HERE ON BEHALF. AID
FOUNDATION THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC ALLIANCE. COALITION
I THINK BURKE WITH THE COURT OF
THE EXPANSION OF THE PRODUCT
WITH THIS PROGRAM IT'S INCLUDED
IN DPH ISSUE ONE I WANT TO JOIN
YOUR COLLEAGUES AND ECHOING
COULDN'T QUITE NOT THE LACK OF
FUNDING FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT RIGHT NAY REVISED
THE WHILE WE WORK THE
ASSESSMENT WE THINK IT'S
CRITICAL THAT- MONEY FUNDING
HAPPENS NOW ON THAT AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT HELP WE CAN'T
WAIT COALITION REQUEST FOR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION POOR PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE. BROUGHT
THE TRUMP SUPPORT OF THE ETP
BUDGET REQUEST THAT WILL ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S NOT LOSING
FURTHER GROUND INTERESTINGLY
THAT NEXT TO MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
STAFF REQUESTED THAT NECESSARY
NOW BECAUSE THEY DO AND LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS ARE
STRUGGLING TO FIND REPORT BURKE
DOES NOT VULNERABLE TO HIV STI.
I'LL HAVE A QUIET. MANY HAVE
THAT PEOPLE RELATED EPIDEMIC
THAT AFFECTS THANK YOU NEED ARE
SUFFERING HEALTH INEQUITY
PRATICA QUITE THANK YOU MUCH.
THANK YOU MUCH MUCH. THANK FOR
IF YOU SAY AS MAY HAVE SAID
OKAY YOU'RE LIKE I'M SAW THIS
ARE WE DON'T SAID THAT AND WE
STILL A MANY MANY PEOPLE IN THE
QUEUE TO WANT TO MAKE SURE AS
MANY VOICES GET HEARD AS
POSSIBLE. SO I WILL ASK THAT
YOU LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU OUTLINED
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN YES.
PLEASE GO AHEAD RIGHT SIXTY. HI
MY NAME'S TWENTY MILLION THANK
YOU FOR TAKING MY CALL I'M AN
ADVOCATE FOR SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE WITH MENTAL ILLNESS- SH
ONE OF MANY IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
AND I'M CALLING TO ATTRACT TO
THE STATE HOSPITAL ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE. DISCONTINUING THE
CONTRACTS WITH THE COUNTIES-
THIS SUPPOSED TO CREATE. A
CATCH TWENTY TWO SITUATION
WHERE. COUNTIES CURRENTLY DON'T
HAVE THE CAPACITY HELLO
EVERYONE WHO NEEDS CIVIL
COMMITMENT- AND BECAUSE PEOPLE
ARE TURNED AWAY FROM HOSPITALS
WITHOUT TREATMENT THEY OFTEN
END UP IN JAIL. AND THEN THOSE
SAME PEOPLE WILL KEEP ADDING TO
THE QUEUE OF PEOPLE WHO ARE A
COMPANY TO STAND TRIAL WOULD
HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE HOSPITAL
SURE WE NEED TO EXPAND THE
BILLIONS THAT THE GOVERNOR.
WANTS TO END ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE MORE BAD. SO
THAT. EVERYBODY CAN BE HEALTH
NEEDS TO BE AND MY QUESTION IS.
WHY ISN'T THE ONLY OF COURSE IF
I LIMITED BEDS FOR PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA IS TO JAIL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EIGHTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. CAN
YOU HEAR SIGN EIGHTY EIGHT. I
TOTALING LINE VOTE ONLINE AB.
I'M SORRY THAT I'M SURE WHAT
WAS THAT I JUST HAD MOVING
ALONG YOU'RE YOU'RE THERE. OKAY
WELL WE WON WE ALIGN NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ROSS
BUCKLEY ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET REQUEST
FOR ON GOING FUNDING FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
COMMUNICATION HOUSE DOWN TO
INVEST IN PUBLIC HEALTH FOR
PERSON INSTRUCTOR PUTS LIVES AT
RISK MORE SIMPLE DISPARITIES.
CALIFORNIA CAN'T WAIT TILL NEXT
HEALTH CRISIS BEST IN PUBLIC
HEALTH WE'RE SURE SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. FIFTY SEVEN YOU
ARE UP. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
I LIKED IT- MARC ILL CRIMINAL
JUSTICE CHAIR FOR NAMI GREATER
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN A MEMBER
OF CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR
TREATMENT INSTEAD OF SUPPORTING
THE CONSTRUCTION OF IMDB'S
WHICH COULD BE A SIGNIFICANT
PROPONENT OF THIS SOLUTION TO
THE I. ISTI CONUNDRUM- FOR
PEOPLE WHO NEED AHIGHER SUB
ACUTE LEVEL OF CARE IN THE
STATE IS INAPPROPRIATELY
SUPPORTING JEALOUS COMPETENCY
RESTORATION PROGRAMS. OVER
PROGRAMS IN A CLINICALLY
THERAPEUTIC SETTING ALSO BY
REFUSING TO APPLY FOR THE I AM
DEEP SOLUTION TO THE WAIVER WE
ARE CONTINUING TO OPPOSE
FUNDING- IT IS THE KIND OF
SILLY- SO FACILITATED SOLUTION
ON ITEM FIVE I ASK YOU TO
REJECT THIS PROPOSAL I CANNOT
SAY IT ANY BETTER THAN THE
CHAIR HERSELF. NEED RELEASE OF
PATIENTS SHOULD MATCH THE
TIMELINES OF CONSTRUCTION AND I
ALSO CONCUR WITH THE- COMMENTS
BY THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM CDAC.
CAPACITY IS NOT AND CLEAR IT IS
QUITE CLEAR IT DOES NOT ASSESS
AND FINALLY ON NUMBER ELEVEN ON
RESTORE ALLIANCE T. PATIENTS ON
THERE ARE NO SAYS AND I AM YOU
ARE WE SACRIFICING LPA
SPECIFICATIONS AS A LEGAL
REMEDY TO FAST LEGAL PRESSURES-
L. A. COUNTY WORKING FOR SIX
YEARS TO GET AS MANY PEOPLE
SURE AS WELL AS THAT OF JAIL AS
POSSIBLE AND NOW THE STATE
SEEMS TO WANT TO PUT THEM BACK
IN. HIS WORKING AT CROSS
PURPOSES OF THE COUNTIES- YOU
CAN EVEN THIS IS A HORRIBLE
RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MOVING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LEVINE
SEVENTEEN GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
ARTHUR KARYA YEAH DENNIS AS
WELL DONE AND SHOULD BE ALL
FILE DID NOT YOU THINK BACK MY
THAT'S THE PRODUCT PEACE 2%
MEDICARE SHOULD THE AREA. BOB
IT'S EMPLOYEES YOU CAN THAT IS
OUR SPECIALIST TRANSITION THIS
MEDIGAP POPULATIONS OF DATACAP
YOU BECAUSE THERE IS A MASSIVE
MISTAKE AND THEN YOU CAN'T
NEVER GONNA PROGRAM THAT CAN
DELIVER AND HAS THE SAME ISSUES
WITH LIMITED ACCESS TO CARE.
THIS WILL ALSO BROADBAND ISSUES
I KNOW FOR A FACT WE WILL NOT
SAVE. MONEY BY TRANSITION THIS
POPULATION. LET ME ASSURE YOU
HAVE THE PACKAGE AND DENNIS THE
CALL. WHO ARE JUST RELYING ON
AND- PRESENTED THEM THAT BY YOU
MUSICIAN ANY KIND OF BECAUSE
THEY BEING THAN THE A PATH.
HE'S CUTE MADE UP. THE DATA
DESIGN AT THE END OF THE MEMBER
THINK IT AT ONCE PER YEAR YES
THE CHILD GO TO THE DENTIST GET
THE EXAMINATION AND CLEANING
DONE. UNDER DENTAL TREATMENT
NEEDS FOR THE PATIENT HAS NOT
BEEN COMPLETED OR CITED BY THE
DENTIST. AND THEY JUST WANT TO
STARTED BY THE STATISTICS
DEMOCRATS ENCOURAGE INITIAL
THAT THE CHILD DENTAL TREATMENT
IS STARTED. AND COMPLETED UP
THE POST WITH ANY KIND OF
PEOPLE SERVICE WHO JUST WANTED
TO BE A SICK IN THEIR FAVOR.
NOT SURE ABOUT THE WELL BEING
OF THE CHILDREN. I'M SORRY BUT
IT'S VERY MUCH LIKE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LAWLER POLICE WE
UNDERSTAND. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FIND SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU HELLO. AND HAPPY THAT. I
JUST WANTED TO THE STATE. HOLD
STILL OF THE PRINTER MANAGED
PROGRAM ATTACK COUNTY. HE
ACCORDING THAT IT PREVENTS
HELLO WITH THE THAT THERE
REACHING OUT TO BE AND IT ALSO
BEATING THE P. THAT ARE HAVE
PROBLEMS WITH LAKE BECAUSE
VALUE TO LINGER FOR AND I WHAT
TO EXPECT A LOT OF MY A LOT OF
THE I KNOW YEAH DO BETTER OUR
BEEN A BETTER THE MANAGED DIEM
PROBE HAS BEEN HERE. WELL I
ASKED THE THIS COMMITTEE BUT
OPPOSED THE ELIMINATE OF THE
PROGRAM FOR MY JUNE THANK VERY
MUCH FOR LISTENING THANK YOU
MUCH NICK CALLER. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS ALLISON MAY LOW- THE
MOTHER SOMEONE WAS SMALL
ILLNESS- FAMILIES AT FOR THIS
YEAR MAN ILL. AND I LOSE ISSUE
FOR. ON THE- ROOM AND I'M SURE
THEY MORE HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT.
ITEMS SIX EIGHT AND ELEVEN
ABOUT HOW TO DEAL WITH I S. T.
CLIENTS. AGAIN THERE IS NO ROOM
FOR THESE PEOPLE IN THE COUNTY
WERE SENDING THEM TO. LUCIEN TO
THE PROBLEM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. PLAN OKAY SORRY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
BY NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WELL GOOD MORNING SENATORS MY
NAME IS ERICA JOHN A SENIOR
RESEARCHER AT BUSTLE SERVICES
FOR GROUPS INCORPORATED AND I'M
PART OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER TECHNICAL THAT THE
PROVIDER TEAM BUT A TOP
PRIORITY AREAS PROJECT I'M
THINKING OF THE FOR THE
PROPOSAL FOR SIXTY THREE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING TO SUSTAIN AND EXPAND
THE SECURITY PEOPLE FOR MORE
YEARS THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I NINETY FIVE
YOU ARE OFTEN. BY NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MOVING ALONG
WE WILL GO TO LINE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DR
JEFFREY MELCHER I'M THE MEDICAL
DIRECTOR OF THE TERRA. I
APPLAUD THE MOVE BY THE
CALIFORNIA PRENATAL SCREENING
PROGRAM TO INTERNET INTO
EMPLOYMENT ON THE BASIS OF
PRENATAL SCREENING TO ENSURE
THE CALIFORNIA MOTHERS HAVE THE
BASS BIRTH DEFECTS READING
AVAILABLE TO THEM. I AM
CONCERNED HOWEVER THAT THE LOW
PRICE BEING CHARGED TO PRIVATE
INSURANCE COMPANIES COULD FORCE
CALIFORNIA'S PNS PROGRAM TO
MAKE HARMFUL TRADE OFFS ON
PRICE FOR QUALITY. THE
FORTHCOMING RSP SHOULD INCLUDE
THE FOLLOWING BARE MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS ALL CASH SHOULD
HAVE TRUE VALIDATION STUDIES
THIS FOUNDATION MUST BE PART
PUBLISHED IN PEER REVIEWED
JOURNALS. AND ALL TESTS MUST
RECORD-EAGLE FRACTION
CONSISTENT WITH THE QUALITY
DIRECTIVES SET OUT IN AC N. G.
AND A CAR GUIDELINES INCLUDING
REPORTING A FETAL FRACTION
PUBLISHED PEER REVIEWED DATA.
AT THE FORMAL REQUIREMENT WILL
HELP ENSURE THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS MAKING HIGH
QUALITY TESTING AVAILABLE TO
ALL PREGNANT PATIENTS THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWENTY
NINETY FOR PLEASE AT. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANKS FOR MUCHTO
EGGMAN MEANS AND AT THE
RESEARCH YOUR AND LYFT. WITH MY
THE IT THE PACIFIC GRANT THE
BEEN THE YEAR YOU CAN- BUT
SPEAKING SUPPORT EXTENSION
PERSON DPU ENSURE OF PROGRAM
AND THE EQUITY IN OUR PUB
HEALTH OF A BIG YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH COLORFUL. BY NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS HARSTAD B. I AM BIG THE OF
THE REDUCTION COUPLED HAVE
DIEGO I AM CALL ON BE. OF THE
FIFTEEN HUNDRED THAT I KERR- IN
SAN DIEGO ON IN SUPPORT OF THE
IN THE EPIDEMIC BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT.
CALLER PLEASE. R. Y. NINETY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR IT DANNY OFFER WITH THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS ALSO KNOWN AS NOBBY
CALIFORNIA AND I PROMISE TO DO
THE SELECTION THIRTY SECONDS-
WERE OPPOSED TO THE DEPARTMENT
STATE HOSPITAL ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE ELIMINATE LPS CONTRACTS I
CAN'T PUT IT BETTER THAN YOU
THE L. A. L. A. COUNTY ALREADY
DID. SO WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK ON
YOUR RECOMMENDATION FOR A PLAN
C. AND WE ALSO SUPPORT READ THE
BRADY THE PROPOSAL FOR THE
REDUCING THE PROJECT THANKS I
APPRECIATE YOUR. CONCISENESS
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WHY ONE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
INSURANCE MEMBERS MILLIONS.
NINE ONE ONE WE LAST YEAR. FIVE
I WANTED ONE MORE TRY. IT'S A
DIFFERENT SET. IN BERLIN WATER
TO SLEEP GO AHEAD YOU GO. ONE
OR TWO YOU ARE OPEN. AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS A LOT OF
POLITENESS AND I AM CALLING ON
BEHALF OF ACCESS SUPPORT
NETWORKS EVERYTHING A BARBARA
CAN BASEBALL AND MONTEREY
COUNTY. I JUST GOING TO PARTY
AND THE EPIDEMIC AFTER EVEN
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA
WAS EXPERIENCING MAJOR CRISIS
IN HIV VIRAL HEPATITIS AT TI
OVERDOSE AND DIED YOU CAN. THE
PANDEMIC. HAS AB THIS YEAR'S
CAME IN MARCH. WITH STRONG
SUPPORT THE ANY OTHER DEMOCRATS
REQUEST TO ENSURE THAT IT DOES
NOT MOVED FURTHER ADDRESS. THE
WELL THE DOCUMENT QUITE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
PLEASE. ONE OF THREE TO GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM AND MY
FOR SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
PUBLIC. PUBLIC GUARDIANS
JOINING OUR COUNTY PARTNERS AND
OTHERS OPPOSING THE STATE
HOSPITAL L. PS PROPOSAL AND
JUST ASKING ABOUT THE- PLANS
THE THAT THE CHAIR HAS
SUGGESTED WE CERTAINLY HOPE
ABOUT INCLUDES SOME FUNDING FOR
PUBLIC CONCERT OR SOME PUBLIC
GUARDIANS WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND YET RECEIVE NO
STATE FUNDING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CENTURY I AM
HELPING JANE SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF AN EPIDEMIC COLLISION I WANT
TO REMIND IS THE COMING THREE
DOT PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS CALLED
Q. AND VIRAL HEPATITIS BY
TWENTY THIRTY AND WE CANNOT DO
THIS WITHOUT. SOUNDING STRANGE
CHANGE PROGRAMS WHICH ARE
EXTREMELY UNDERFUNDED WE KNOW
THAT SYRINGE EXCHANGE PROGRAMS
ARE ESSENTIAL TO PREVENTING
HEPATITIS C. HIV. AND CORE IN
THE HOPE OF PUBLIC HELD AND
HAVE PLAYED A ROLE IMPORTANT
ROLE IN DISTRIBUTING P. P. E.
R. VACCINE FOR COLEMAN ACTUAL
AWFUL. AND WE- WE ALWAYS KNOW
RIGHT ARI B. ESSENTIAL PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE CDC
IDENTIFIED I THINK PETER IS
SPECIAL PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE ARE IN
NEED OF FUNDING AND WE WILL
MAKE MEANINGFUL IMPACT
OVERBILLED HEPATITIS C. AND C.
D. SO WE ARE ASKING THAT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE CONSIDER A BUDGET
REQUEST AND MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE'S LIVES ARE NOT ARE NOT
NEGLECTED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE FORTY YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO
NAME'S ALL CENTER- WITH LOOK
YOU KNOW FOR HELPING I'M TO
CALLING AND SUPPORT THE OF
CALIFORNIA HELP EQUITY FUND AS
WELL BE BROADER YEAR IN PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE-
CLOSE TO GOVERNOR SOME PRETTY
AT PROMISED TO EXTEND
HEALTHCARE TO ALL REQUIRE ALL
SENIORS REPORT A MATTER
IMMIGRATION STATUS WE'RE ALSO
GOING TO EXPRESS SUPPORT. FOR
FOOD FOR ALL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. ONE OH SEVEN GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN
OKAY YOU'RE GOOD FOR THE
PSYCHIATRIC ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE ADD OUR VOICE
TO ALL THE OTHERS QUESTIONING
THE APPROPRIATENESS OF THE LPS
PATIENT CONTRACTS-
DISCONTINUANCE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS COLOR PLEASE.
ONE HUNDRED AND TWELVE YOU ARE
OPEN. HE HELLO THIS IS SERRA
FIVE MADERA COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH DIRECTOR NEARLY 70% OF
THE MADERA COUNTY POPULATION IS
IN COURT TRIAL ONE OF THE
HEALTHY PLACES AND ACTS OF THE
NINETEEN LAID BARE HOW FAILING
TO INVEST THEIR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE
PUTS LIVES AT RISK AND WORSEN
HEALTH DISPARITIES COLLUDED WAS
THE LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH IN
TWENTY TWENTY AND OUR
ACCOUNTING WHAT WAS STRIKING
WITH AT THE FARM WORKER DAD IN
TWENTY TWENTY ACCOUNTED FOR
THIRTY FIVE POINT 6% OF ALL
THAT. EVEN THOUGH THEY ONLY
REPRESENT THIRTEEN POINT 8% OF
OUR RESIDENTS A LOCAL TRAINED
AND CULTURALLY FOCUSED PUBLIC
pCALIFORNIA CAN'T WAIT UNTIL THE
NEXT CRISIS STRAIGHT TO IMPACT.
PUBLIC HEALTH IT GETS PRECISELY
WHY BECAUSE NINETEEN UPLIFTED
THE STATE EMITTER COUNTY SO I.
WE'LL ACROSS. UNLESS FACT I'M
GOING TO LOW PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE TRUCKS AND WORK NOW. LIVES
OF ALMOST ONE DEPEND ON IT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEXICO. WE WILL GO TO ONE.
PLEASE GO. A LINE ONE FIFTY.
HOW TO PLEASE KELLY CAN YOU
HEAR ME LINE ONE FIFTEEN-
EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT WELL I'M
JUST CALLING SHARE BUT AN ON
FROM A TESTIMONY WAS KEY BY BEN
EDWARDS M. D. THAT RELATE TO-
THE- BUDGET ITEMS TODAY- FIVE
AND SIX AND I THINK THREE THERE
WAS A LITTLE BIT OF CONFUSION
WITH PEOPLE GIVING TESTIMONY
OUT OF ORDER. BUT THAT BEING
SAID BEN EDWARDS MD WHEN
TESTIFYING BEFORE THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON STATE AFFAIRS FOR
THE LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL ON MAY
SIX IN TAXES WAS ASKED IF
PEOPLE CAN DO ANYTHING TO
PREVENT THE SPREAD OF COVERT
NINETEEN. THIS DOCTOR MEDICAL
DOCTOR MD EMPHASIZED THAT
NATURAL IMMUNITY IS MORE ROBUST
THAN VACCINE IMMUNITY MA'AM I
DON'T REMEMBER HEARING THE
ORIGINAL TAXES ARE YOU TOOK
MONEY HEARING. ASIAN WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN AS A REAL TO DATA
WAS THE- IN THIS HEARING VERY
NICE. I. PLEASE THANK YOU MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE FIND WHAT
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO. SHE GOOD
AFTERNOON TO MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF EQUAL HOW. I'M HERE TODAY TO
URGE BACK THEN AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT AND COMMUNITY OR- TO
MAKE SURE THEY HAVE THE- THAT
THEY NEED TO MAINTAIN THE
CREDIT SERVICE AND THE FIGHTING
EACH HAVE A- ACTUALLY I'D AN
OVERDOSE. THE ANY OTHER THAN
COLLISION HAD. BUDGET THAT
WOULD ENSURE THAT THE DO THIS I
MEAN CHARLIE SUPPORT THOSE
BURKE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CLUB. ONE NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON SO CAN BATTING HERE
AND NUMBER THIS IS YOUR YOUR I
DON'T AND- ADDITIONAL DAKOTA.
HOW DO YOU SPELL CHECK AND NEED
PLEASE PROGRAM THAT SERVES
LITTLE FOR NOT CHILDREN AND
TRACK OF COUNTY WE'RE THE ONLY
THAT PROVIDES PREVENTATIVE
DENTAL SERVICES IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY. THE AVERAGE YEAR WE
PROVIDE OUR SERVICE TO CHINESE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE CHILDREN BE PROVIDED FOR
HEALTH EDUCATION CENTER SCREEN
FLUORIDE VARNISH TREATMENT AND
NAVIGATION TEMPLE. WHAT SEVERAL
UNIQUE. IS THE NAVIGATION AND
PUT. THE WORK WITH THREE PM
CENTRAL PLANNING HEALTH NET ACT.
DENTAL FIND A DENTAL CARE FOR
THE TO TELL. AND ALSO PROVIDE
TRANSFER. INSURANCE IF NEEDED
WE ALSO WORK WITH. COVERED AND
LOCAL BALLING AND- TO PROVIDE
DENTAL NOW. TO CHILDREN AT THE
NOT HAPPENED IN. OR CAN'T. A CO.
I'M TRYING IS DOWN PROVIDE.
PROVIDE A JOKE OR HEALTHY.
WHICH I TRY TO PROVIDER DENTAL
SERVICE THANK YOU MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY NINE CALL. FAN I USED
ENCOURAGE YOU TO OPPOSE TO IN
THE MIDDLE AT THE END HE-
SACRAMENTO THANK THANK VERY
MUCH. PRETTY COLORS LEFT THE
QUEUE MONTEREY. I LOOKS FOR
FINALLY OKAY IT'S BEEN ARE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BY ONE ONE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
CHAIR IN MEMBERS I'M DOCTOR CAN
BURNS ONLY WITH LIKE INTO THE
AND IN THE- OF ANOTHER FROM
FROM ON THE HEALTH OF WOMEN AND
GIRLS WHO ARE YOU POSITIVE OR
POTENTIALLY HIGH CLOSE TO HIV
THE MESSY. A STRONG SUPPORT THE
BUDGET REQUEST FROM IN THE
EPIDEMIC COALITION TO ENSURE
THAT THE STATE DOES NOT INSPIRE
THE GROUNDING IT TO ADDRESS
THESE EPIDEMICS WHILE
ADDRESSING THE CALL THE
NINETEEN CRISIS WHICH IS NEARLY
ONE PIECE OF TECHNICAL
EXPERIENCE OKAY THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS RONALD KOEMAN HERE ON
BEHALF OF STEPHEN CALIFORNIA
PAN ETHNIC HELP NETWORKER
SUPPORTIVE AND BE INVESTED FOR
THE CHILDREN AND YOU TO BE A
REAL INITIATIVE AND THINK IT'S
CRITICAL STEP TOWARD ENSURING
WE HAVE A BROADER ACCESS TO OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
WE WERE HOWEVER VERY
DISAPPOINTED ABOUT THE LACK OF
INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE RELATED INFRASTRUCTURE
WORKFORCE RACIAL EQUITY
TARGETING THE DEVASTATING.
EFFECTS OF SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF HEALTH AND PREVENTABLE
DISEASES THAT ARE PARTICULARLY
RAMPANT IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
WHICH FOR THE CALIFORNIA CAN WE
PROPOSAL BECAUSE OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND
WORKFORCE IS IMPORTANT BUT WE
ALSO URGE LEGISLATORS TO FUND
COMMUNITY BASED PARTNERSHIPS
THAT WILL SPECIFICALLY FOCUS ON
RACIAL EQUITY TO START TREATING
RIGHT TO THEM HOW A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS OF THAT ALL
COMMUNITIES CAN DRIVE. WE CAN
DO THAT WE URGE YOU TO FIND THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH EQUITY AND
RACIAL JUSTICE ON TO DO THAT
INITIALLY WE URGE THE SENATE TO
INVEST SIXTY THREE MILLION TO
KEEP THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT GOING FOR
FOUR MORE YEARS TO CONTINUE TO
REAP THE BENEFITS OF THE
COMMUNITY TO FIND EVIDENCE
PRACTICES REDUCING DISPARITIES.
AGAIN THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY.
NEXT PLEASE. WE WILL ONE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON THAT YOU'RE
A MAN I JUST WANTED YOU ECHO MY
UNION PROFESSOR AT ENGINEERS AS
A COMMENT. AND SUPPORT FOR IT
AT THE TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC HEALTH.
ALL WHO WANTED TO OPPOSE THE
ELIMINATION OF THAT DENTAL
MANAGED CARE PROGRAM THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NICE COLOR
PLEASE. THANKS WE WILL GO TO
LINE ONE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO ANON TWENTY FIVE-
MY NAME IS ANDREA HAD STRUM BY
EMMA HAVE A PARTICIPANT IN THE
LEGISLATURE. AND I'M CALLING TO
PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT OF
INSIGHT. BY WAY OF POETRY. THE
SIX BEST DOCTORS TO ANYWHERE
AND NO ONE CAN DENY IT OUR
SUNSHINE WATER REST AND ERROR
EXERCISE AND DIET. THESE SIX
WE'LL GLADLY YOU ATTEND IF ONLY
YOU ARE WILLING YOUR MIND
ABILITIES YOUR WILL THURMOND
AND CHARGING NOT ONE SHILLING.
AND WHAT I HEARD TODAY WAS WEAK
PEOPLE ON WET GET NINE TO
ELEVEN DOLLARS IN FRESH FOODS.
AND YOU ARE SPENDING HUNDREDS
UPON HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS.
DISTRIBUTING A VACCINE WITH
THEM. USE AUTHORIZATION ONLY
WHERE THERE ARE MANY MORE
COLORS. AN INJURY THE FIRST
FOUR MONTHS OF THIS VACCINE AND
THERE HAVE BEEN AN OPERATOR
TWENTY YEARS KALRA KILEY. COURT
DUE TO THIS VACCINE TO ALL
ACTION. AND MADAM CHAIR THERE
ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WELL THAT BRINGS AN END TO OUR
PUBLIC COMMENT SECTION IF YOU
WEREN'T ABLE TO GET THROUGH AND
WANTED TO OR IF YOU WANTED TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT LONGER YOU
CAN ALWAYS EMAIL THE COMMITTEE
AT YOUR AT YOUR INPUT IS
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM YOU.
AND WITH THAT WE WILL ADJOURN
THE HAVE BUDGET SUB.